Nice!
You're not alone
Failfish
Life was easy, spamming all the time
Take your ass to nowhere
So everyone's feeling fine
Twitch emotes
From long ago
Made you feel
You're not alone
People forehead
Ja
Easy
Nice,nice,nice,nice
Stripes 007 schon am Start
Subbox gecampt oder was?
Wobei wie nennt man das auf Twitch?
Auf YouTube ist es Subbox, wie ist es denn?
Wie ist es denn auf Twitch?
Ich bin seit 8 Uhr schon auf wegen der Zeitumstellung
Ja das stimmt
Ich hab's gar nicht gecheckt, dass es heute Nacht war
Ich hab auf die Uhr geguckt heute Morgen als ich im Bad war
Und da hab ich festgestellt wie 8.10
Hä wie 8.10 ich hab grad 9
Klar
Also ich steh ja nicht wirklich nach Uhrzeit auf am Wochenende
So wie sie
Ich hab erst dann später aufs
Auf die Uhr geguckt
Ich steh ja auch unter der Woche nicht wirklich nach Uhrzeit auf
Ich wach immer auf von allein
Also ich glaube ich bin
Die letzten
Okay mal übertrieben
Die letzten 15 Jahre
Vielleicht ne handvoll mal
Durch irgendwelche anderen Sachen geweckt worden
Als dass ich von allein aufgewacht bin
Also ich wach immer von allein auf
Also egal ob ich jetzt irgendwie
5.45 Uhr aufstehen muss
Oder ob ich jetzt irgendwie bis
Frag mich nicht 7.30, 8.30
Ich hab das irgendwie im Hinterkopf weil ich aufstehen muss
Das ist ich
Ich stell noch nicht mal mehr in Wecker
Ich guck ja recht viele so Home Automation Videos
Auf YouTube
Und eines der Hauptbestandteile
Dieser Videos ist Leute die sich irgendwelche Wecker einstellen
Und
Dann machen
Wie komm ich einfacher aus dem Bett mit irgendwelchen
Light Strips die angehen
Und sowas, brauch ich alles net
Hab ich echt Glück
Also ich wach immer von allein auf
Discord Notifikt
Ach stimmt da
Wir haben ja im Discord
Stream Notification
Da hab ich ja schon gar nicht mehr dran gedacht
So was will denn YouTube
Das wir heute gucken
Was übrigens ein cooler Trend
Ist auf YouTube, der mir tatsächlich gefällt
Ich bin ja immer viel am meckern auf YouTube
Aber da kann YouTube nichts für
Und vielleicht doch, vielleicht ist der YouTube
Algorithmus mittlerweile so, dass das ganz gut gefördert wird
Es gibt immer mehr Leute
Die so komplette Kurse auf YouTube hochladen
Sei es jetzt irgendwie so ein Linux Beginner
Kurs, irgendeinen C Sharp Kurs, irgendeinen
Arduino Kurs
Irgendeinen Web Development Kurs
Es gibt total viele komplette Kurse mittlerweile
Die teilweise irgendwie 5, 6, 7, 8 Stunden lang gehen
Insgesamt auf YouTube kostenlos
Finde ich eigentlich ziemlich gut
Und qualitativ sind die meisten
Gar nicht so übel
Wie ich gesehen hab bisher
Ich gucke jetzt nicht allzu viele 8 Stunden Kurse
Kommt nicht so oft vor
Sniper vs Tank
Das kennen wir schon
Was machen sie hier
Terminating Cat 5 Cable
Was machen, ein Grimp Wettbewerb
Was ist denn mit denen los
Bin ich froh, dass ich so eine Kacke nicht mehr machen muss
Ich mein ich weiß wie es geht
Und ich hab hier letztens sogar mal
Mich wieder dran gewagt, aber
Kabel von Hand machen ist wirklich der allerletzte Müll
Da bin ich, da bin ich froh
Dass ich das nicht machen muss
Muss übrigens gerade mal nebenbei gucken
Ob ich den Heizlüfter im Bad ausgemacht hab
Aber das schöne ist
Das kann ich ja dank der gefleschten Steckdosen
Jetzt total einfach sehen
Exzellent
Funktioniert
Wann kommt das Video mit den Servern
Oh das weiß ich gar nicht ob ich
Ja doch das muss ich machen
Die Audioqualität sackt aber
Ich muss mal gucken
Ich bin ja wirklich ernsthaft am Überlegen
Ob ich ein Weihnachtskalender dieses Jahr mache
Ich hab mir schon viele Sachen aufgeschrieben
Ich hab so ungefähr gerade so 12, 13
Verschiedene Sachen
Die man machen könnte
Die Sache bei mir ist ja erstmal, ich brauch erstmal die Ideen
Die mich dann motivieren, dass ich's mache
Vielleicht mach ich dann auch das Server Video
Schreib ich mir gleich nochmal rein
Lichak
1,9,7,8,11 Monate
Das ist ja 1 vor
Aktuell ist es
Aktuell ist es erst
Erst
Aber in einem Monat ist es
Pantschamp
Die Leute sind auch richtig beknackt
Ich hab jetzt Ankündigungen gesehen
Von Sony auf Twitter
Und hier auf YouTube haben sie irgendwie Zeug gepostet
Und immer wenn Sony
Jetzt was postet
Zu PS5 kommen die Leute
Gleich an
Dead Game, Shit Console, Xbox Better
Also das haben die den ganzen Tag nichts anderes zu tun
Oh, Cobalt Stream, hör mal auf
Da hab ich ja schon gar nicht mehr dran gedacht
Alter Cobalt Stream, ja das muss ich an Weihnachten machen
Weihnachten lern ich Cobalt
Ja, ich würd sagen wir gucken uns mal ne Runde
Wir gucken uns mal ne Runde Battlefield an
Oder ich geb YouTube nochmal ne Chance noch was vorzuschlagen
Was spannend ist
Fips, ich weiß nicht was du meinst
Dieser 60 Euro Media und Gamer Pizzorker
Das sieht da aus wie von 2005
Nein, YouTube schlägt uns nichts
Gescheites vor
Ach komm, einmal Schlösser knacken
Das guck ich mir immer gerne an
Chat, ich muss euch mal was fragen
Wir haben doch hier bestimmt, was ist das denn
Full Quartz Satra Head
Das ist ja mal huge sinnlos
Warum soll man denn sowas
Ok Moment, warum
Warum soll ich sowas bauen
Das ist ja schon ne komplette
Zweckentfremdung der Hardware quasi
Ne Quartz Satra
Nass mitm Raspberry Pi zu bauen
Das ist ja
Ich mein es geht, aber es geht viel
Was nicht unbedingt sonderlich sinnvoll ist
Kennst du Moneyboy Trap House Kitchen
Ja, hab ich sogar letztens
Aber wir haben 69 Zuschauer
Exzellent
Hab ich sogar letztens geguckt
Ne Runde
Ich überleg grad, was hat er denn gemacht
Chicken Wings glaube ich
Ich glaub Chicken Wings waren es
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich
Das geht an mir vorbei
Warum das die Leute so geil finden
Das ist weder ne gute Kochshow
Noch ist es irgendwie lustig
Noch kann ich
Diesem auf
Ultrakrass Gangster Hip Hop
Man machen da irgendwie was abgewinnen
Das kann man sich einmal angucken
Aber sonderlich
Warum das
Crispy Wings genau
Warum das jetzt so geil ankommt
Verstehe ich nicht, aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich zu Boomer
Dass ich das verstehe nicht
Windows Fan Tested Linux Laptop
Ok, das können wir uns mal angucken
Was ist das hier
S-Clap
Ach der Scheiß
Oh yeah
Ach der Kram
Oh ne, das muss jetzt nicht sein
Sowas, das ist so ein typisches
Twitch Ding, was auch keiner versteht
Jetzt wo wir grad beim Thema Twitch sind
Ihr habt das bestimmt alle mit diesen Copyright
Geschichten mitbekommen, oder
Das ist so unglaublich bescheuert
Also es geht ja grad so wieder die Angst um auf Twitch
Deswegen haben Leute wieder ihre
Wots gelöscht, zum Beispiel hier
Wenn man mal bei Dance Gaming guckt auf Twitch
Video, Wots
Dann stellt man fest, dass der
Moment, ich will echt nichts
Dass der kaum
Wots am Start hat
Sonst hatte der Wots
So, und das liegt daran
Weil die grad
Extrem umtriebig sind, wieder was Copyright
Geschichten auf Twitch angeht
Was natürlich heißt, dass
Man auch keine
Games mehr streamen kann, mit Musik drinnen
Also ich mein, so ein bisschen
Mixgedudel im Hintergrund wird noch gehen
Da wird wahrscheinlich keiner großartig jetzt irgendwelche Rechte drauf haben
Aber wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel GTA
Spielst
Mal gucken, ob das schon
irgendwelche Mainstream-Dinger aufgegriffen
haben, bin ich mal gespannt
Ja
Ja genau, hier sind sie alle, sind sie alle schon
rumspampt
Also sprich, GTA spielen ist nicht mehr
Spiele mit Zwischensequenzen, mit Musik ist nicht mehr
So, und der Witz ist ja
Dabei
Dass ich, also okay
Erstens muss man sagen, ich weiß warum die jetzt anfangen
Weil Twitch
Durch diese ganze, und da ist tatsächlich mal Corona
dran schuld, meiner Ansicht nach zumindest
Twitch ist grade in der
Corona-Zeit jetzt vom Mainstream
fast schon zum Ultra Mainstream geworden
Und die
Dass jetzt so die ganzen
Anwälte und
Stonks-Manager
Jetzt nicht grade so bei neuen Medien sich
gut auskennen, ist ja glaub ich allen klar
Das heißt, die haben bisher von Twitch gar nichts großartig
mitgekriegt und ging Twitch, ging
ein bisschen an denen vorbei
Und jetzt in der Corona-Zeit, weil Twitch halt so
richtig, richtig beliebt wieder geworden ist
Ich mein, die View-Zeiten
überall gehen ja durch die Decke
Außer, außer bei der Overwatch League
Aber da sind die, da sind die
bei Blizzard selbst keine Schuld, aber ansonsten gehen die
View-Zeiten ja komplett durch die Decke überall
Das heißt Twitch ist jetzt auch in Fokus gerückt
von irgendwelchen Anwälten und
Stonks-Managern, und das schieb
ich tatsächlich auf Corona, dass das grad
so ist
So, ja da sag ich gleich was zu SplinterX
Nee, nee
Splixer, nicht Splinter, Splixer
Ähm, so
Und dadurch kommen die jetzt
halt alle hier auf Twitch
Und jetzt übertreiben sie es halt total
Jetzt übertreiben sie es halt total
dass, ähm
die ersten Systeme
irgendwie implementieren wollen, dass live
Streams ausgeschaltet, dass du quasi live
die Streams scannst nach Copyright
Music und Tagdown kannst
Und dass du die Wots scannen kannst und Striken
und Tagdown kannst, so
Das Problem bei der ganzen Geschichte ist nur
dass, ähm
die Lage, was du jetzt machen kannst
so wie der absolut unklar ist
Also du musst halt einfach nur hoffen
Du machst nichts, was zum Beispiel Disney anpisst
Weil wenn du Disney anpisst, dann hast du wahrscheinlich
gleich 80 Anwälte am Arsch, wenn du nicht irgendwas machst
Die haben zwar
schöne, bunte, niedliche Sachen
Aber
Die Anwälte sind nicht schön
bunt und niedlich bei Disney, garantiert nicht
So
Oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, aber mittlerweile kannst du eigentlich fast sagen
Du musst aufpassen, dass du Disney nicht anpisst
Weil irgendwie 90% gefühlt mittlerweile Disney
in irgendeiner Art und Weise ist
So und
Das Problem dabei ist jetzt, dass du halt
erstens keine Ahnung genau hast, was du machen kannst, was du nicht
machen kannst, also wirklich
Man würde ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, zum Beispiel
Irgend, zum Beispiel sowas hier
Würde man eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass
man sowas hier spielen darf
Das ist ein Cover
mit einem extra Text, selbst gespielter Musik
aber halt was nachgespielt
Das ist Grauzone
Soweit sind wir schon, sowas ist Grauzone
Also normalerweise würde man sagen, ja
das ist gar kein
Musik
Das ist gar kein Problem
Also man kann natürlich was nachgespielt
das nachgesungenes mit anderem Text springen
Aber
Du kannst das... Kleines Gummis glaube ich nicht
Das glaube ich nicht
Er schreibt, das macht Twitch
auch wegen ihrem eigenen Musikprogramm, das glaube ich nicht
Also wenn Twitch
das forcieren würde, wären die ja selbst schön doof
Die, die das
forcieren, ist die rechte
Verwertungsindustrie, noch nicht mal unbedingt
die ganzen Künstler, aber die rechte
Verwertungsindustrie ist da ganz
hinterher. Twitch, wenn Twitch das selbst
forcieren würde, wäre ja blöd, die wollen doch nicht selbst
ihre eigenen Leute verkraulen oder
dafür sorgen, dass sie vielleicht Sachen nicht
überspielen können, die Leute anziehen
Das wäre ja total beknackt
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, also ich glaube nicht,
dass das an Twitch liegt, das liegt an
Contentverwertungs...
Sagen wir mal Mafia
Die das Ganze machen
So und was jetzt auch, was ich aber
halt nicht verstehe ist
Vielleicht erinnert sich noch der ein oder andere dran
Twitch hat auch viele Möglichkeiten mit Amazon Music
Weil die garantiert mit Amazon Music nicht
die Lizenz haben, sie weiterzugeben
an Streamer. Hätten die das, würden sie
das machen
Hä, was geht bei YouTube nicht?
Bei YouTube ist doch schon
jahrelang viel restriktiver als Twitch
was Copyright-Sachen angeht
Twitch war lange Zeit, du
konntest mehr oder weniger machen, was du willst
Solange du es nicht total übertrieben hast und
irgendwelche rein
Musikworts gemacht hast
und sowas
Aber YouTube ist schon
ist viel restriktiv, jahrelang
fast schon, um übertrieben zu sein
Jahrzehnte lang, weil YouTube gibt es ja schon eine Weile
restriktiver als Twitch was Copyright angeht
Und auf YouTube wurdest du schon früher gestrikt
wenn du 10 Sekunden das Falsche drin hattest
So und
Also was ich aber nicht ganz verstehe
ist, was da unterm Strich bei rauskommen
soll. Vielleicht erinnert sich die ein oder anderen
Leute noch dran, als die
gleichen
Medien, Stonks
Anwalt, Management, Mischmasch
vor
so 2005, 2000
rum, gesagt haben
so als Napster auch am
angesagt war und später
Audio, Galaxy und was es da nicht alles gab
Kauf CDs
Die haben damals gesagt, Kauf CDs
Wer sich Sachen im Internet illegal
runterlädt, ist böse. Ganz ganz schlimm
Vielleicht, vielleicht kennt jeder noch die
Moment, vielleicht, vielleicht finde ich die Werbung jetzt
Vielleicht, vielleicht kennt ihr das auch
Papa Raub
Kopierer
Ja
Hier, das da. Vielleicht kennt das noch jemand
Vielleicht kennt das noch jemand
Alter, Hals Maul
Ich hasse, ich hasse Kinder die rumschreien
Das ist so schlimm
Papa
Happy Birthday
Das eigentliche, eigentliche kommt jetzt
Ja
Papa
Happy Birthday
Das war super
Raub, Kopierer werden mit
Bezug auf den Freiheitsentzug
So, und jetzt muss man mal vorstellen, diesen
Shit
Diesen Kack
Musste man sich geben, genauso wie
das Netzwerfel schreibt, wenn man legal diesen Kram
Abonniert hat
Ich meine, das ist schon harter, harter, harter Kram
Ja
So, und das sind die gleichen
Stonkstypen, die jetzt an Twitch am Start sind, die hinter
sowas stecken. So, und früher haben sie erzählt
So nach dem Motto
Ja, kauft euch CDs und uns entgehen ja
Millionen, Milliarden, Billiarden
Was weiß ich, wir haben ja eh schon zu wenig Geld
Durch
Illegale Sachen
Und was damals der Fall war, die Leute haben gesagt
Fickt euch
Die haben nämlich keine CDs gekauft
Und die Leute haben sich damals auch nicht einreden lassen
Kauft euch CDs
Weil CDs in der damaligen
Zeit schon damals nicht mehr
Zeitgemäß waren
Also, wenn die Leute die Auswahl haben
Ich will Musik haben
Sie können daheim vorm Rechner sitzen bleiben
Und
Im Internet nach einer Musik suchen, runterladen,
anhören, gut ist. Oder
Sie müssen ihn laden, dort vielleicht
noch was Probehören, dann eine teure
CD kaufen, dann wieder zurück
Und dann, also was machen
die Leute? Es geht da gar nicht so
sehr ums Geld, es geht darum, was ist einfacher
Und natürlich haben die Leute damals gesagt
Internet, einfach runterladen. Es gab ja keine
offiziellen Angebote. Und was
die sich damals auch schon unglaublich schön
gerechnet haben ist, dass jeder
der illegal etwas
downloadet oder illegal
was Probehört
Ich nenne es ja lieber Probehörn
Es ist genauso wie, dass keine Raubkopien sind, sondern
Sicherheitskopien, ne?
08MAX7, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub
Huge
Big Brain Subscription
So, und dann haben die ja gesagt
Entgeht ihnen pro
downloadeter Song entgeht ihnen quasi
ein Verkauf, was natürlich Schwachsinn ist
Blödsinn
Es ist vollkommen an den
Hahn herbeigezogen. Aber
warum haben das die Leute
damals gemacht? Weil das absolut
nicht mehr zeitgemäß war
Die Leute wollten keine CD kaufen
Die wollten auch nicht in Geschäft
ins Geschäft gehen und dass sie dann
noch anhören müssen, wenn sie was legal
erworben haben. Die sind Raubkopierer
und kommen in den Knast
Ähm, mal ganz davon auf
Genau, was Felix Splitzer sagt, ist auch vollkommen
richtig. Das Wort Raubkopien
triffts eh nicht, weil
es ist noch nicht mal Diebstahl
Das ist sogar rechtlich
tatsächlich wirklich so
Es ist kein Diebstahl, weil Diebstahl
bedeutet immer
dass irgendwie einer was hat
das wird geklaut und ist danach
weg und bei wem anders
Das ist ja bei Raubkopien nicht so
Also es ist weder Raub
noch Diebstahl noch sonst was. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung was es genau ist
Wahrscheinlich umgehend von Copy. Da gibt's ja
mittlerweile eigene Gesetze für. Aber es ist definitiv
kein Raub und kein Diebstahl
Ähm
Das heißt damals war das ganze Zeich
nicht zeitgemäß. Die Leute
wollten das nicht. Und siehe da
Man hat jetzt Streaming Angebote
Man hat Video-Streaming
Angebote, Musik-Streaming Angebote
Und siehe da, wer hätte das gedacht
Die Leute
kaufen es tatsächlich und keiner lädt sich
Guck mal, wer lädt sich heute noch mal illegal irgendwas runter
Das einzige, wo man sich
heute irgendwas, ich kann's
zumindest von mir sagen
Das einzige, wo man sich heute mal vielleicht
auf irgendwelchen zwielichten Seiten
irgendeinen Stream zu Gemüte führt
oder irgendwo Musik runterlädt
ist, wenn es das woanders
nicht gibt. Also zum Beispiel
ich will irgendeine
sagen wir jetzt mal, es gibt irgendeine BBC
irgendeine Serie oder irgendwie was, was ich
aus England gucken will und die
bieten das quasi
nur Region Locked UK
an. So, da bleibt mir
ja gar nichts anderes da übrig, wenn ich das gucken will
als mir das auf irgendeiner Streaming-Seite
anzugucken. Also ich weiche heute
nur noch auf irgendwelche zweifelhaft
legalen Angebote aus
wenn ich die Sache
nicht normal
bekomme. So
Das ist genauso wie mit
Spielen. Also die meisten Leute kaufen
sich heute Spiele absichtlich auf Steam, selbst wenn sie ein bisschen teurer sind
Abzucht, dass alle schön in Steam Trimmer haben
Also siehe da, wenn es Angebote gibt, dann
wird das auch gemacht und funktioniert
und damals mit CD's war das einfach
absolut nicht mehr zeitgemäß
Genauso wie ich dieses ganze Copyright
Zeug in der heutigen Form nicht mehr zeitgemäß
finde, weil
die Sachen, diese Gesetze
sind ja ursprünglich mal entstanden, fragt mich nicht
also lange, lange bevor es das Internet
in der Form, wie es das heute gibt, gab
und dementsprechend passt das Ganze auch
nicht. Und was ich letztendlich unterm Strich
gar nicht verstehe ist, was sich
die rechte Anbieter auf Twitch davon
versprechen. Das verstehe ich nämlich nicht
weil wenn man sich mal überlegt, was passiert
die
Streamer, die jetzt quasi
also es gibt natürlich auch Streamer, die
einen Lebensunterhalt damit verdienen, das heißt für die
ist das nicht so wie bei mir, wo ich
sage, hey, wenn da mal irgendwie was gesperrt
wird oder so, dann warte ich halt sechs Wochen und mache
weiter oder so. Ähm,
Leute, die damit ihren Lebensunterhalt verdienen, ist wenn die
mal sechs Wochen nicht streamen dürfen, ist halt
Scheiße, ja?
Was machst du als Vollzeit
Streamer, wenn du jetzt nicht einer der Riesen
großen bist, der schon hunderttausende
geschaffelt hat, wenn du so im Mittelfeld bist,
was machst du, wenn du sechs Wochen nicht
streamen kannst? Da bist du
ziemlich im Arsch, ja? Ziemlich, ziemlich kacke
ist das. Du bist nicht gleich verhungert, du hast vielleicht
ein bisschen Reserven, aber sechs Wochen nicht streamen ist
schon was. Gut, sechs Wochen
habe ich jetzt einfach mal aus der Luft
gegriffen, ja? So,
das ist schon ganz schön scheiße, deswegen gewähren die das
Risiko nicht eingehen. Das heißt,
im Endeffekt wird das dazu fühlen,
dass um alles, was auch nur
ansatzweise irgendwie
verdächtig
sein könnte, da irgendwie dagegen zu
verstoßen, wird nicht mehr gemacht. Was dazu
führt, dass viele beliebte Sachen
auf Twitch nicht mehr gemacht werden, zum Beispiel
kein GTA mehr.
Oder keine Spiele mit Zwischensequenzen mehr
oder was auch immer. Was natürlich
Twitch auch nicht gefällt, weil das das Programm
einschränkt und den Streamer nicht gefällt
und die Frage ist, ob das
den Spieleherstellern gefällt. Letztens
hat ja wieder irgend so ein Typ auf Twitter erzählt, dass
Spielehersteller
sollten Gelde für nehmen,
dass Let's Player die Let's Playen dürfen.
Warte mal, der Lost
hat das glaube ich, Twitter,
netlost, ey,
ich glaube da heißt es nur noch Lost,
letzten auf Twitter gepostet
und was ich ganz witzig fand, den Typ,
von dem habe ich schon öfters mal was
gelesen. Wisst ihr wer das ist?
Wisst ihr wer das ist? Er hat es nicht in seinem Profil
stehen, aber wenn ich es euch sage, lachte er echt kaputt
diese Aussage.
In der Wahrheit ist es so,
dass die Streamer die Entwickler bezahlen
sollen, wenn sie Spiele
streamen.
Der Typ
der macht neben dem,
dass er für Assassin's Creed zuständig war
und sowas.
Wisst ihr wo der noch mitarbeitet? Der Chat
hat schon gespoilert. Der gleiche
Typ ist bei
Google Stadia mit dabei, an
der Position.
So, da wundert mich jetzt nichts mehr.
Wenn solche Leute bei Stadia dabei sitzen, dass
da nichts klappt. Er hat
es irgendwie nicht mit
hier drin stehen, aber
wenn ihr danach sucht, der Typ ist
Stadia, irgendein Stadia,
er ist kein Stadia CEO oder so, er ist
Stadia Creative Director.
Also der hat schon was zu sagen bei
Stadia. Also
solche Leute sind da am Start.
Das ist natürlich komplett
bescheuert.
Ne, in seinem Profil steht nichts von Stadia, oder?
Steht da was von Stadia?
Oh nein, das ist Rob Kupial, G-Fart.
Das steht nichts von Stadia,
oder?
Ne, da steht nichts von Stadia.
Das hat er nämlich rausgenommen, oder was auch immer.
Das steht nicht
drinne, deswegen dachte ich auch, der Typ
kommt hier bekannt vor, aber der ist es nicht.
Doch, dann hab ich ihn angeschaut, das ist der
Stadia-Mann.
Und
ja, um jetzt diese Copyright-Geschichte mal abzuschließen,
also alle Streamer werden einen großen
Bogen drum machen, das wird nicht funktionieren, und was
die sich davon versprechen,
kapier
ich nichts.
Was wird denn die Folge sein?
Oder was kann ihnen denn Schlimmes
passieren? Überlegt doch mal, was kann
einem Contentvermarkter
denn so Schlimmes passieren, wenn jemand
im Stream ein Spiel spielt,
wo Musik eines Künstlers,
in dem er vermarktet drin ist.
Meint der wirklich, ihn entgehen dadurch
Verkäufe?
Also, was ist
wahrscheinlicher?
Irgendein großer Streamer
spielt GTA.
Oder spielt irgendein Spiel
mit Sachen im Soundtrack.
Also, sagen wir GTA.
Irgendein großer Streamer spielt GTA.
Und dann macht er das Radio an
in GTA. Oder es läuft eine Spiele-Zwischensequenz
mit irgendwie coolen Songs
in einem Spiel.
Meint der dann wirklich, die Leute sagen dann,
also, jetzt habe ich den Song ja
schon gehört,
jetzt kaufe ich mir nicht mehr.
Das ist doch total
beknackt.
Also, was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Dass jemand in einem Spiel, in einem Stream,
in einer Zwischensequenz
ein Lied hört, das googelt, wer
es ist, und sich eventuell mal
Probe anhört, ob ihm der Künstler gefällt.
Und wenn ihm der Künstler gefällt,
vielleicht auch Spotify oder Amazon Musik kauft.
Also, was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Dass der sich das aus dem Stream rippt
und sagt, das muss ich mir nicht mehr kaufen,
weil mir reicht die Musik 30 Sekunden mit dem
Streamer, der dabei labert.
Oder dass der sagt, ja, ich kaufe es mir vielleicht.
Also, die Chancen, dass er sich danach
die Sache zulegt, wenn er sich das mal
im Stream angehört hat, ist meiner Ansicht nach viel höher,
als dass jemand dadurch
nicht mehr die Sache kauft.
Was natürlich auch noch sein könnte, ist,
dass die selber mitbekommen haben,
dass qualitativ vieles,
was released wird, absoluter Scheiß ist
und sie nicht wollen, dass man schon
im Vorfeld erkennt, bevor man es sich vielleicht
kauft, dass die Musik scheiße ist. Allerdings
ergibt das keinen Sinn, weil
wahrscheinlich Spiele nicht die
Scheißtracks von einem Künstler nehmen würden.
Also, ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
So, also deswegen verstehe ich den Sinn nicht,
was man haben möchte, was die
wollen, wenn man
diese ganze Copyright-Geschichte
auf Twitch macht.
Flobob sagt, schade, dass Twitch
sich da raushält. Ja, gut.
Es ist schwierig. Also, was soll Twitch
großartig machen? Ich meine, die Gesetze gibt es ja.
Und es kommt durch,
wie gesagt, es kommt meiner Meinung nach durch Corona,
dass jetzt das immer mehr in Fokus
rückt von irgendwelchen Stonks und
CEO-Rechen.
Wie heißt denn eigentlich der,
wie heißt denn der Chef der Rechtsabteilung?
Es gibt einen CTO, das ist der Technologie-Mensch.
Wie heißt denn der
Chef von, von der, von
der Rechtschef
CLO?
Chief Lawyer
Office, keine Ahnung, wie nennt man
sowas?
Zumindest, die sind jetzt halt darauf aufmerksam
geworden.
Also, es führt, es führt meiner Meinung nach
zu nichts. Und was passieren wird, ist
das komplette Gegenteil von dem, was
die sich erhoffen in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Was passieren wird, ist, dass
einfach alle Streamer in einen riesen,
riesen Bogen um alles machen, was
irgendwie Copyright
ähm
äh, Kram
anrüchig ist, ja.
Und dann wird sich Twitch aufregen,
dann werden sich die Spielehersteller aufregen,
dann werden sich letztendlich die Künstler aufregen, es werden sich alle aufregen.
Und am Ende gibt es irgendeinen Deal
mit Twitch, dass man das wieder machen kann.
In etwas geänderter
äh, Art und Weise.
Da gehe ich mal von aus.
Weil der aktuelle Zustand ist letztendlich,
das ist so ein bisschen Muskelflexen
voreinander, ähm,
im Endeffekt hat keine Seite
mit der aktuellen Regelung wirklich was von.
Weder die Streamer, noch die
Zuschauer, noch Twitch,
noch die rechte Inhaber,
ja, die hoffen einfach beide Seiten
oder alle Seiten, dass sie irgendwie
was für sich erträglich ist,
quasi damit jetzt raushandeln können.
Die einen hoffen vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Lizenzverträge abzuschließen, mit Amazon
für Twitch, die andere Seite
ähm, auf das ihre
Spiele und Sachen weiter gezeigt werden, die Streamer
hoffen natürlich auch, dass das, dass das
funktioniert und, äh, können natürlich
auch dementsprechend Druck aufbauen, indem sie
einfach nicht irgendwelche
halblegalen, grauen
Sachen, äh,
machen, sondern, und da gehe ich auch von aus,
dass die meisten Streamer das machen werden,
die werden einfach nichts
und jetzt wirklich gar nichts mehr
zeigen, was irgendwie Musik enthält.
Was aber, was halt dazu
führt, dass das den Druck auf
Spielehersteller, Twitch und Zuschauer, also
im Endeffekt hat keiner was von.
So, und deswegen denke ich, wird es da über
kurz oder lang eine Einigung geben,
dass das, äh, wieder möglich ist.
Vielleicht
gar nicht so lange
in Zukunft.
Was ist denn, wenn sich
ein Streamer eine GEMA-Lizenz holt? Ich glaube,
das ist in dem Fall ziemlich wurscht, weil das
eine Ami-Plattform ist, aber ehrlich gesagt, keine
Ahnung. Was ist mit DJ-
Musikstreamern? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, die
können erstmal einpacken.
Sofern die irgendwas verwenden, was
Copyright rechtlich relevant ist,
was die meisten wahrscheinlich machen.
Das heißt, äh, DJ,
also Musikstreams wird es nicht mehr geben.
Es ist ja auch schon, also, viel, viel
eingeschränkter als jetzt.
Also es, zumal es ja auch wirklich, es ist
ja, es ist ja Grauzone aktuell.
Es ist ja Grauzone aktuell, ob du zum
Beispiel was, äh,
covern darfst und sowas.
Normalerweise bauchmäßig würde man sofort sagen,
klar darfst du was covern und spielen.
So klar ist das gar nicht.
Das ist zwar geduldet und eigentlich
auch okay,
aber ob das noch so ohne
weiteres jetzt, sich die Leute trauen,
ist einmal dahingestellt, ja. Also
DJ-Musikstreams wird, ist aktuell ganz, ganz
schwierig auf, auf Twitch.
Auf YouTube ja auch,
eh schon. Deswegen läuft der nur so gedudel
hier auf YouTube.
Tja, so sieht's aus.
Total bescheuert, hat keiner was von.
Also total hat da
wirklich keiner was von. Twitch nicht, Zuschauer
nicht, Streamer nicht, Musikindustrie
nicht, Künstler
erst recht nicht. Die haben ja lustigerweise von
allem immer am allerwenigsten.
Ja.
So, also, was gucken wir,
was gucken wir mal.
Warum? Also das, das
leuchtet mir jetzt überhaupt nicht ein.
Ich will das Video jetzt gar nicht großartig gucken,
aber warum
missbraucht man
einen Raspberry Pi so
und baut da draußen einen
vier Platten Nass?
Das taugt dafür doch überhaupt
nix.
Aber anscheinend interessiert das viele Leute.
Und der Grund warum
das für eine Nass
nix taugt, ist ganz einfach,
weil sich die,
wie nennen die sich denn? Ist das die Raspberry Pi
Foundation? Keine Ahnung, die
Raspberry Pi Hersteller, der Raspberry Pi
Hersteller, der hat sich bei der
Arm-Lizenz nämlich was gespart.
Der hat's gedacht, wir kommen da ganz ohne aus.
Unrun Dead
kannst du machen.
Die haben sich nämlich gedacht, wir sparen
uns die Lizenz für die Krypto
Extensions im Arm,
in der Arm-CPU.
Und das Dove ist,
dass eine Nass ohne Krypto
Extensions mit so einer schwachen Hardware,
wie es der Raspberry Pi ist,
leider suckt.
Es sei denn, man möchte wirklich
rein, also man
möchte gar nichts darauf verschlüsseln oder so,
aber ich finde, ein ganz normaler
Anwendungszweck auf einem Nass ist
eigentlich auch, dass die Platten
vollverschlüsselt sind.
Also Nass ohne Verschlüsselungs
Fähigkeiten zu bauen heutzutage, finde ich
nicht sinnvoll, zumal es genug Hardware
gibt, die ähnlich günstig ist, die das
kann.
Also da muss man sich, oder vielleicht nicht ganz so
günstig, aber die das kann.
Und an sich ist ein Raspberry Pi
mit 4GB
RAM ist das vollkommen in Ordnung, aber
sowohl von den Schnittstellen her,
als auch von der CPU-Leistung her und vor allem
den fehlenden Krypto Extensions her,
ist der Raspberry Pi kein allzu gutes
Nass-System, gerade wenn die hier
vier Platten anschließen wollen.
Der Rasp intern sind die Sachen ja alle,
ob man das hier irgendwo sieht. Wie sieht denn das
mit den Platten eigentlich aus dann, zeigt mal her.
Wie sieht denn das
eigentlich aus mit dem, wobei wir suchen
mal kurz danach.
Ja, wie sieht denn das Gehäuse
so aus? Okay, das sind einfach
ganz normale SATA
Backplanes.
Okay, und es sind auch noch,
jetzt kannst du nicht, ach du Scheiße, ist das eine
technische Konstruktion.
Will man sich das wirklich geben?
Also mal ganz im Ernst,
der Kram kostet, was kostet das?
Quads, SATA, Head.
Kostet.
Kostet was?
Kostet so ein komisches Gehäuse.
Shop.
Okay, keine Ahnung, kann man nicht kaufen.
Ja.
All net China.
Also 35 Dollar, dann nochmal
irgendwie 70 Dollar für einen Raspberry Pi.
Guck mal, du bist mit dem Gehäuse
und diesem ganzen Kram,
du bist, wenn du alles zusammen hast,
bist du vielleicht bei 150 Euro
am Ende. Du brauchst ja noch ein Netzteil, du brauchst
noch ein Gehäuse, äh du brauchst noch,
ne, eigentlich brauchst du nur ein Netzteil.
Also sag mal, du bist
bei ungefähr 150 Euro
ohne die Festplatten.
So, und dafür kannst du dir eigentlich auch
schon entweder das Einsteiger
Synology kaufen, wenn's unbedingt sein muss,
oder irgendwas anderes selbst bauen. Also ich bin immer noch dafür,
der Raspberry ist kein, kein gutes
Nasssystem. Und hauptsächlich wegen den fehlenden
Krypto Extensions.
So.
Ähm.
Ja.
Nur hier Pi
seh ich auch so.
Das seh ich genau so. Er hat eigentlich
eigentlich keinen, keinen Sinn sich einen Raspberry Pi
nass zu bauen.
So. Ähm.
Ja. Also gibt ne Frage.
Ich habe das Problem bei mir, dass alle Daten
plus zwei anzeigen. Also wenn es um
elf passiert steht, ist um eins in
Grafana. Egal welche Zeitstone ich in Grafana
einstelle, bleibt das Problem bestehen. Du
kannst mal über die Restapi was abrufen
und gucken, was da wirklich für ein Timestamp
drin steht. Ähm. Aber
ansonsten kannst du, hast du
irgendwie dockermäßig laufen oder auf dem Host
installiert.
Da kannst du nämlich mal gucken, was du für
ne Zeitzone auf deinem Server eingestellt hast, falls
das dir was bringt.
Hab ich aber wenig Erfahrung mit, also mein,
ich hab übrigens ein paar neue Grafana
Dashboards bei mir am Start. Also
das ist ja meine Heizung, die hab ich euch jetzt ja schon oft genug
erzählt. Guck mal, der Qt-Mod ist da.
Äh Fenris, äh ESX
auf dem Raspberry Pi haben wir ausprobiert.
Funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Ist zwar nach wie vor reichlich sinnlos,
aber funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Xen muss ich noch ausprobieren.
So, also das ist ja eben die Sache für die Heizung, die kennt ihr ja schon.
Übrigens, das ganz neue Grafana
gestern, das geupdated 7.1, noch was.
Ähm.
So.
Dann hab ich nämlich noch den Plattenplatz
für die Fernsehaufnahmen im
Wohnzimmer, der aus
irgendwelchen Gründen hier meint, dass es
irgendein Alarm gegeben hat. Okay, was auch immer.
Was eigentlich Blödsinn ist,
ich hab gestern an dem Alarm
rumgespielt, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich deshalb.
Aber was ich gestern gemacht
hab, ist
ich hab alle meine Domains,
also
alle meine, äh, nicht Domains,
alle meine SSL-Zertifikate mal
reingemacht mit Ablaufdatum.
Dass ich
nicht übersehe, sollte irgendeine Zertifikat
Verlängerung nicht funktionieren.
Also sprich, das sind alle Zertifikate, die ich
ausgestellt hab, Jon.
Ist das easy? Das ist ziemlich easy
mit Kafa, naja.
Und guck, hier neben sieht man, wie lange die Zertifikate noch
gültig sind.
Also sprich,
am...
Ja.
Also sprich,
die meisten
laufen noch über 50 Tage.
Und das ist tatsächlich ziemlich easy,
so was zu machen in Grafana.
Du brauchst erst mal
ein Prometheus-Exporter, der das macht.
Das kann man aber autodiscoveren lassen.
Macht das nicht Sinn?
Doch, das könnte man auch machen.
Ja, wobei, ne, wenn du das hier
meinst, also das auf 0,
dann ist das zu
klein, dann siehst du die Änderungen kaum noch.
Also ich lasse das autodiscoveren,
und
dann brauchst du eigentlich nur eine
Sache einzubinden. Ich bin jetzt hier leider nicht eingeloggt,
deswegen kann ich das nicht zeigen. Das ist ein Befehl,
den man hier eingeben muss. Ich hab gesagt, wenn du
noch 5 Tage übrig sind, dann soll er mir eine Nachricht schicken.
Ja,
PC lustig kann man machen.
Du musst dafür
sorgen, dass dein Prometheus
das autodiscovert, was du
für Hosts hast.
Das können wir vielleicht mal in einem Stream
machen. Also wenn du
so Enterprise-Business-Geschichten laufen hast,
wie jetzt irgendwie ein Docker-Swarm
oder ein Kubernetes oder irgendwie
Konsul und noch was, also
in größeren Container-Deployments ist es kein
Ding, dann hat man ja schon so einen
zentralen Store, wo drinnen steht,
was man für
Server,
Container, was auch immer laufen hat, dann kann das
Prometheus discoveren daraus.
Wenn man das nicht hat, was ich im
Heimbereich nicht habe, entweder
macht man das selbst, ich mach das über
DNS, ich mach das über DNS
aktuell. Ich hab 2
Zeilen Bash
etwas mal programmiert,
die eine Datei erstellen, die Prometheus
einliest. Ich mach einfach einen Dick
auf mein DNS für die eine IP,
Reverse Lookup für die eine IP,
Reverse Lookup für die andere IP, weil ich
hab da plus 2 Hosts,
wo intern wirklich großartig was läuft.
Ich hab hier einmal diese
die Intel-Power-Kiste,
wo Heim-Automatisierung
und sonst was drauf läuft und ich hab
den einen Raspberry Pi-MW-Lan, wo Unify
und sonst wie Kram drauf
drauf läuft.
Ich mach einfach einen DNS
Reverse Lookup, der spuckt mir dann alle
Hostnames aus und das schreibe ich in eine Datei,
die Prometheus einliest. Das sind wie gesagt
in 2 Zeilen Bash und das lässt einfach
alle 5 Minuten laufen und
oder kannst auch alle 10 Sekunden laufen lassen,
DNS abfragen, kosten ja nicht viel.
Und sobald du einen neuen Server
in deinen DNS einträgst,
was du ja eh machen musst, wenn du ihn intern
auflösen möchtest, sobald du einen neuen
Server in dein DNS einträgst,
dann ist der automatisch damit drin.
Also ich kanns hier zeigen,
wenn du willst, wie das aussieht.
Hier stehen keine Systeme fest
drin.
Jetzt zwar eigentlich ist Aufwachen
im Stream, aber das zeige ich dir trotzdem noch kurz.
Blackbox
muss mich
einloggen.
Dann habe ich das
M
Ah, exzellent.
So, Edit
Das ist alles, was man abfragen
muss. Also sprich,
es kommen
automatisch alle Hosts rein,
die diese Sache
hier exportieren.
Beziehungsweise alle Hosts, die automatisch
abgefragt werden. Also du siehst hier nirgendwo
explizit einen Host drinne stehen.
Und er zieht
die aktuelle Zeit davon ab, dass es immer aktuell
ist. Das ist alles.
Das ist der normale Blackbox Exporter.
Du sorgst einfach dafür, dass
der überall Zertifikatinfos
abgreift.
Also wenn ich jetzt
neues System
in DNS eintrage, ist es
dann nach ein paar Minuten da.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht zeigen, weil das neue
System muss auf HTTPS
antworten.
Das
erscheint nicht da drinnen,
wenn dort kein Webserver läuft. Also der muss
einmal initial gültiges Zertifikat
abgefragt haben. Ist ja logisch.
Greife so die Heizungsdaten vom
Ebus ab. Nein, ich greife die Heizungsdaten
mit einem
damit ab.
Mit
so einem Kabel greife ich das ab.
Jeder Heizung hat vorne so ein
Ding. Da kann man so ein Kabel reinstecken.
Genauso sieht das bei mir im Keller auch
aus.
Und ähm...
Ja.
Exzellent.
Und dann machst du das dran. Auf die andere Seite
kommt ein Raspberry Pi dran. Und dann musst du
ein bisschen Magic machen. Dann brauchst du das hier.
Was die Wiesmann-USB
Geschichten versteht.
Und damit kannst du die Sachen auslesen. Das ist nicht
so schwierig. Die haben auch ein gutes Wiki, wo sie erklären
wie es funktioniert. Das Projekt ist auch
aktiv maintained.
Musst du dir angucken.
Dann hab ich noch was drumherum programmiert, was das
Ganze als Prometheus
metric exportiert, damit Skrafana einlesen
kann.
Moin Michael 50 Billiarden. Exquisite
kalte Pizza morgens um 9.40. Exzellent.
So. Also.
Gucken wir uns mal was an. Was
schauen wir uns denn an? Wir gucken uns erstmal
Schlösser aufmachen.
Ähm. So.
Ich guck mal schnell. Hab ich irgendwas vergessen hier
im Chat?
Max ich hab am Freitag das geilste meines Lebens erlebt.
Ähm.
Bei uns in der IT Security Abteilung
da ruft ein Supporter mich an.
Hinter uns sagt XY Kunde will einen Raspberry Pi
vier Bear bauen
um ihn als USB Stick zu nutzen.
Geht das?
Ja das
geht. Aber warum?
Also du kannst
ich glaub der Raspberry Pi
kann sich als Storage Device melden
über USB. Das geht.
Aber warum?
Das ist ja dann nur ein
Oversized Micro SD zu USB Adapter.
Wo ist denn der Sinn?
Den Sinn versteh ich auch nicht. Ne.
Hast du deine Monitore nahtlos aneinander
oder ich hab die direkt nebeneinander stehen?
Also. Ähm.
Das ergibt für mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch
wenig Sinn.
Also ich muss sagen
mein Lieblingsanruf
den ich jemals
bekommen habe
auf der Arbeit
war eine die gesagt hat
ihr System geht nicht mehr.
Wobei stimmt gar nicht. War gar kein Anruf.
Das hatte ich E-Mail geschrieben. Ihr System geht nicht mehr
und die ist lustigerweise bei mir rausgekommen.
Also ich hab damit eigentlich gar nichts zu tun
so supportmäßig wenn das System nicht geht
aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist die Mail bei uns im Gruppenpostfach
aufgeschlagen und ich hab mich dazu
herabgelassen mal
zu sagen ja ich kümmere mich drum
und hab ihr dann geantwortet und hab
gefragt ja ähm
von welchem System spricht sie denn?
Weil die auch von irgendeiner
von irgendeiner Klinik
oder so geschrieben hat wo ich gar keine Ahnung
hab was will die eigentlich von mir?
Ja also ich wüsste nicht dass wir
Support für Krankenhäuser machen oder so
und da hab ich mich gefragt ja ok
wer genau ist sie denn von wo und
und äh um welches System gehts genau?
Und sie hat halt drauf geantwortet
es geht um das System mit dem wir täglich
arbeiten Ausrufezeichen.
Und da wusste natürlich Bescheid.
Ich hatte danach genauso wenig Ahnung
wie vorher was die eigentlich will.
Ok was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an?
Das System mit dem wir täglich arbeiten
was soll ich denn wissen?
Das ist so geil auf die Frage
ja um was gehts?
Übrigens da gucken wir jetzt das passende Video zu an
das war echt ganz lustig ich hab schon mal
angefangen zu gucken.
Moment wo ist es denn?
Ja das da das ist echt ganz witzig.
Mal gucken ob es laut genug ist.
Wie man Programmiere ärgern kann
und da ist wirklich was wahres dran.
Das geht mir auch auf den Sack
das kennt glaube ich jeder
also das erste wird man wahrscheinlich eher kennen
wenn man im Support arbeitet
oder na wobei wobei also bei uns
auf der Arbeit ist es auch öfters so
dass irgendwie einer ankommt so nach dem Motto
und was macht die Kiste?
Ja welche Kiste?
Ja die Kiste die irgendwelche
sagen wir mal PDFs generiert ja
und die PDFs sehen heute anders aus.
Ja was weiß ich was habe ich mit der
PDF-Generierung zu tun?
Ja ihr macht das doch ja sowas haben wir auch
aber das geht mir auch auf den Keks.
Da kommt dann irgendwie einer an
und sagt ja also wir bräuchten jetzt mal
irgendwie eine neue Metrik für
keine Ahnung jetzt bräuchte ich mal irgendwas abgedrehtes.
Wir bräuchten in unserem
wir bräuchten in unserem Monitoring
eine neue Metrik für
genau die fangen meistens an also wir bräuchten
eine neue Metrik und wir bräuchten ganz simpel
mal eine neue Metrik in unserem Monitoring
und zwar für
jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen was
komplizierteres muss ich mir jetzt mal ausdenken
für BIOS Version
für Server BIOS Version
wir möchten unbedingt Server BIOS Version
in unserem Monitoring drin haben
das kann ja nicht so schwierig sein
mach das mal schnell für uns
oder sagst du Moment mal also
du kommst nicht so einfach an die BIOS Version
von dem System dran um das zu exportieren
das ist euch schon klar oder?
Ich finde es immer geil wenn die also das
machen viele Leute die tun so als ist das total
einfach
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein
du musst doch nur an dieser einen Stelle da drücken
und das machen und jenes machen und guck mal
das ist doch nur das ist doch nur eine
neue Metrik das kann doch gar nicht so schwierig sein
ja das stimmt also Support
ich würde nie freiwillig im Support arbeiten
hier genau das
hatte ich auch
wo ist der Chat
und hier habe ich den Chat zugemacht
Kacknoob warum habe ich den Chat zugemacht
muss ich den Chat auflassen
Netzmuffel schreibt
er kennt auch so was
also
was ich auch immer geil finde ist
also ich habe es ja
letztens auf Twitter geschrieben
schon
wenn die
ich überlege gerade was für ein Beispiel
auf Twitter genommen habe
genau letztens
ruft jemand an
so sinngemäß
ich kriege es gar nicht
mehr richtig zusammen
irgendwas mit Host Skripte
und dann hat er gesagt die Host Skripte genau
so sinngemäß
hallo sind sie hat mich jemand angerufen
ob ich zuständig bin für irgendwelche Host Skripte
ich meine Host Skripte
das ist so
das ist ein Schritt weiter
wie Skripte oder sind sie zu
sind sie für etwas zuständig fragezeigen
also das ist absolut nichts sagen
also es gibt glaube ich kaum
zwei Wörter
die so in der IT so mehr
allgemeingültig generik
sind wie Host und Skript
und das in Kombination sagt
überhaupt nichts aus sind sie zuständig für Host Skripte
da habe ich dann gefragt ja welche was meint
er denn für Skripte welche Host und da gibt es ja
tausend Möglichkeiten und da war seine Antwort
ja ich meine die Skripte um die sie sich
kümmern
das ist immer du weißt
auch genau Bescheid ja
vor allem sind die bei mir immer die sind bei mir eigentlich
zu 90% falsch mit irgendwelchen
Support Sachen außer es ist wirklich was
womit ich mich drum kümmere und sie haben sich schon um drei Ecken lang
gefragt ja
und dann was mich dann immer noch
übelst triggert ist wenn dann einer ankommt
und meint
ja wir bräuchten ihr noch ein weiteres Skript
bis zur
bis zur bis zur Status Runde
ja wann ist die Status Runde
ja in einer halben Stunde
also sprich
ihr wollt irgendwas haben bis in einer halben Stunde
wo ihr mir noch nicht mal sagen könnt
was und wo ihr eigentlich haben wollt
ja genau
alles klar
so
das wird jetzt hier nochmal falsch angucken
ja also das geht mir auch auf den Keks wenn die Leute
immer sagen das ist doch total einfach
die gibt es natürlich auch
das gibt Leute die möchten immer
super super clever klingen
das gibt es aber auch nicht nur in der Technik
das gibt es nicht nur in der Technik
ich muss jetzt nochmal was aus
meinem eigenen Leben erzählen
wo es jemand gibt der das auch gerne macht
mein Vater macht das nämlich gerne
also ich habe nicht so wahnsinnig
viel Kontakt mit meinem Vater
aber
also in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so viel
so bin ich ehrlich gesagt auch ganz
froh drum aber
unabhängig davon hat jetzt
jetzt hier mit nichts zu tun
macht das auch extrem gerne
der sucht sich
immer Themen raus
und tut dann so als kennt
er sich aus so und ich weiß
es klingt jetzt erstmal abgedreht aber ihr
kennt den nicht aber der war mal der Meinung
er versucht sich jetzt als Holzverkäufer
der wollte mal Holz verkaufen
so einfach random dem ist einfach
von heute hat er gerne gemacht so Dinger
dem ist von heute
von heute auf morgen eingefallen ich werde jetzt
verkaufen Holz so richtig echt
ist Holz und er hatte
natürlich keine Ahnung von aber
was er sieht dann geht
ins Internet und sucht ein bisschen danach und das
erste was ihm aufgefallen ist ist
dass man Holz irgendwie in Raummeter
misst und ihr glaubt das nicht
der hat mich die nächsten zwei drei
Monate war jegliche
Einheit in die was umgerechnet wurde
war Raummeter der hat alles in Raummeter
Holz umgerechnet
und einzig und allein nur
weil das wichtig
weil das mehr klingt
als hätte er Ahnung vom Holz verkaufen
als er eigentlich hat er hatte keine also
er hat generell absolut keine Ahnung von Holz
und Holz verkaufen und
und Holz und Forstwirtschaft also null gar
nicht das ist überhaupt nicht sein Gebiet gewesen
absolut nichts
und dann hat er immer erzählt
nach dem Motto ja das sind ja also jetzt sagen
sie mal wie viel Raummeter ist das hier und Raummeter
da und Schüttmeter hier und
und sonst wie und Raummeter da
halt versucht so wirkt ihr so zu klingen
als kennt er sich aus
also so leute kenn ich auch genug
das ist auch was was mir bei
Leuten extrem auf den Sack geht hier
wartet mal hier
die erstens Abkürzungen verwenden
das ist auch was was mir bei Leuten extrem
auf den Sack geht hier wartet mal
hier die erstens Abkürzungen
verwenden
das oh die Leute
ringen mich auf die Abkürzungen
verwenden von denen sie keine Ahnung haben und dann
meinen sie sind so schlau
dass sie dir die Abkürzung nochmal erklären
müssen
das ist auch immer richtig ätzend
im Gegensatz dazu
hast du irgendwelche Stonks Leute
die den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchen
Stonksbegriffen um sich werfen und davon ausgehen
selbstverständlich dass es jeder kennt
das ist auch geil
wir haben ein Ticketsystem und brauchen einen MP3 Player
da drin
ja klar gar kein Problem machen wir sofort
oh ja die Leute gibts auch
hieß der Typ Eierkopf gerade der ihm was schickt
hieß der Eierkopf
wartet mal
wo ist der Typ der Nachricht schickt
Ach Erik Knopf nicht Eierkopf
ich hab Eierkopf gelöst
ja so Leute hast du leider wirklich
die dir
die dir alle 15
ja so Leute
hast du echt
alles ASAP
man muss übrigens mal
wenn man das wörtlich nimmt
die meisten Leute
die meisten Leute verwenden ASAP
nicht für das was es heißt nämlich sobald es geht
sondern für sofort
kennt ihr das auch so Leute sagen oh wir müssten
wir müssten das und das jetzt machen
aber ASAP
so nach dem Motto von der Betonung
und von dem Kontext bedeutet das
wie die das sagen aber sofort
bedeutet ASAP gar nicht sofort
so Typen
so Typen hast du wirklich manchmal
also das kann jetzt wenn man im Homeoffice ist
nicht mehr wirklich passieren
aber ich hatte schon ab und zu mal Leute
wenn ich runtergefahren bin mit dem Fahrstuhl
die gesagt haben ah ich fahr mal kurz mit
und dann wollten die noch irgendwas
so Leute
Leute
Wenn dann einer zu dir sagt, so, jetzt sofort, dann kannst du sagen, ja, Moment, da muss erstmal mein Chef fragen, weil da muss ich ja andere Sachen für liegen.
Das ist eh, das ist so ein Ding, was man glücklicherweise, wenn man in ein bisschen größeren Laden arbeitet, immer gut machen kann.
Wenn, waddu?
Wenn irgendwie einer zu euch kommt und sagt, ihr sollt was machen, auf was ihr jetzt absolut wirklich gar keinen Bock habt,
dann könnt ihr immer sagen, oh ne, ähm, ist jetzt grad, ist jetzt grad schlecht, ich hab da grad so viele andere Sachen zu tun.
Geh mal zu meinem Chef und frag den, ob der der Sache irgendwie Priorität gibt.
Das macht keiner. Niemand.
Also, vielleicht ein Prozent der Sachen, die wirklich wichtig sind, gehen wirklich zu deinem Chef und fragen.
Also, wenn dir jemand loswerden willst, musst du einfach nur sagen, ja, also, priorisierungsmäßig geht das grad nicht,
geh mal zu meinem Chef und frag, ob ich das machen darf jetzt.
Das machen eins bis fünf Prozent, wenn's hochkommt, der Leute.
Dann ist man, die meisten Sachen, ist man los.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Windows-Fan-Tested-Linux-Laptop.
Ah ne, das kommen wir uns irgendwann später an, ich glaub das.
Äh, das stimmt tatsächlich, ja, ja.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal an den Schloss, den guck ich mal gerne an.
Ups.
Äh, nein, ich kenne keinen Pineapple.
Ich kenne Pineapple Pizza, ne, also, ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ah, yes.
Oh, Big Brain Design.
Erstmal die Flex holen.
Gar nicht, dass es so Mini-Magnete gibt.
Das erinnert mich irgendwie so ein bisschen an Zahnarzt, immer wenn man mit diesem Zeug da anrückt.
Ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt, wie einfach die meisten Schl-
Gut, wahrscheinlich zeigt er auch nur Sachen, die er einfach aufkriegt.
Aber der Rest wird noch ein bisschen komplizierter, weil das Video ist acht Minuten.
Silbaro geht mir auch so, ich weiß gar nicht in welche Richtung ich überhaupt drehen muss.
Also wenn ich den Magnet da rein machen würde, ne, ich würde den irgendwo hinschieben wahrscheinlich und nie wieder rausbekommen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Easy.
Aber schon heftig oder? Wie easy der das aufmacht.
Der hat halt auch Übung, der Kerl. Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwie der 0815 Random Dude mit dem passenden Werkzeug das irgendwie in zwei Minuten aufkriegt.
Aber trotzdem heftig, wie easy das bei dem ausschaut.
Jawohl, gibt's ihm.
Es klappt.
Wenn mir einer sowas zeigen würde, ich wüsste nicht mal, zu was für einem Gerät das überhaupt gehört.
Also ich würde im Leben nicht erkennen, dass das irgendwie der Zylinder von einem Schloss ist.
Also wenn mir das irgendwie einer von Amis zeigt, würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, das ist irgendwie eine Schrotpatrone oder so.
Was?
Ah, yes.
Kriegt er die Sachen danach auch wieder zusammen?
Weil ich habe teilweise schon Probleme, wenn ich eine Steckdose mit fünf Teilen auseinanderbaue, dass die danach wieder an die richtigen Stellen hinkommen.
Ich wüsste absolut nicht, wo da was herkommt.
Aber anscheinend ist das ein Thema, wofür sich viele Hackermans interessieren.
Weil beim letzten CCC habe ich auch mehrere Vorträge gesehen, irgendwie was über Schlösser knacken und Alarmanlagen ausmachen und so.
Das scheint so Hexahobby zu sein.
Das geht ja schon fast als ASMR-Video durch hier.
Okay, so spannend finde ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, was da alles drin ist, weil ich check eh nicht, was was macht.
Also nicht übel, das ist echt heftig. Also wie easy der das aufgekriegt hat am Anfang.
So, kurz noch mal husten.
Ei, so.
So, was trinke.
Exzellent.
Kriegt Corona.
Hab ich euch erzählt, dass wir auf der Arbeit den ersten Corona-Fall haben?
Aber was mir egal ist, also für mich persönlich, weil ich mache ja schon Homeoffice seit einer Weile.
Also ich kann es nicht haben.
Also nicht von ihm zumindest.
Was? Next Level Github Profil Read Me? Hä? Was? Ja, ach so.
Okay, was ist die Next Level?
Was denn das?
Es ist Markdown.
Okay, er hat eine Next Level Github Read Me.
Exzellent. Also ganz ehrlich, der braucht länger für die Read Me, als ich wahrscheinlich für die erste Testversion von irgendeiner Software.
Kann man mal machen, wenn man sich denkt, ich habe eigentlich gar kein Projekt heute, keinen Bock an dem Projekt weiter zu arbeiten.
Dann machen wir einfach die Read Me schön.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Also Windows-Fan-Nades gucken wir uns an.
How does Microsoft make money? Mit Azure.
Also ich würde mal sagen, Microsoft macht das meiste Geld nach wie vor mit Azure.
Also mit Azure, mit irgendwelchem Office-Strat 65 gedürnt.
Das ist ja mehr oder weniger Azure. Mit was macht Microsoft noch Geld? Also mit Windows eher weniger.
Vielleicht noch mit irgendwelchen, wobei die mit Hardware-Verkäufen kein Microsoft Geld machen.
Was macht Microsoft eigentlich Geld? Mir fällt ja jetzt nur Azure, Github wird jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel bringen.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung. Ja Office und Azure ist ja mehr oder weniger.
Außerdem heißt es jetzt ja sogar Microsoft-Strat 65. Mit der neuen Xbox machen die auch gerade noch nicht allzu viel Geld.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt legit keine Ahnung, mit was Microsoft Geld verdient außer Azure.
Und mit Sicherheit auch so Sachen wie Server-Betriebssystem, SQL-Geschichten und sowas.
Aber ich glaube, das ist gegen Azure wahrscheinlich alles kleiner Anteil.
Nee, Xbox bringt nicht so viel Geld. Also die letzte war nicht so wahnsinnig erfolgreich.
Aber es ist ja eh so, dass gerade am Anfang, wenn Konsolen neu sind, dass da die Hersteller immer gerne ein bisschen drauflegen, um ihre Plattform mehr zu verbreiten.
Was sagst du zu Office?
Nein, das heißt nicht mehr Office-Strat 65, das heißt Microsoft-Strat 65 und läuft alles in Azure. Azure.
Das ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche, wo das drauf läuft.
Wird halt nur als Office vermarktet, aber die Infrastruktur drunter ist das, was man sich auch in Azure mieten kann.
Ok, das gucken wir uns mal nach. Die 5 besten Windows 10 Apps. Ok, das ist wieder was, wo ich schön drüber abplästern kann.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt schnell angucken.
Der hört sich immer so ultra glücklich an, der Sprecher.
Ja, die ist wirklich gut. Die ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Das ist die einzige App, die ich kenne, die ich mir überhaupt aus Windows Store installieren würde.
Die ist wirklich nicht schlecht. Das kann man wirklich empfehlen.
Ich habe es trotzdem nicht installiert, weil man kann ja auch hier drüber gehen.
Ich glaube, du hast hier ein paar andere Funktionen, so dass er sich die letzte Einstellung merkt, aber mir reicht der Mixer hier.
Am integrierten Lautcheck.
Ich kann einfach nicht akzeptieren, dass eine App ein Prozent leiser als der Rest ist.
Ansonsten möchte ich noch erwähnen, dass man mit einem einfachen Rechts-Leak eine spezifische App auf ein anderes Wiedergabelgerät legen kann.
Cool ist auch, dass sich mit dem Mausrad direkt auf das Icon drehen lässt im Tray, um die Lautstärke zu regulieren.
Das spart dann im Alltag nochmal einen Klick.
Die zweite App, die ich euch heute vorstelle, ist der Microsoft Store.
Ach ne, so eine kacke ey.
Da haben die sich so verrannt drin, in ihrem komischen Microsoft Store.
Nicht mal Microsoft selbst verwendet den Microsoft Store.
Weder Visual Studio noch Visual Studio Code noch, was gibt es denn sonst noch von Microsoft,
weder noch der neue Edge noch sonst was.
Nichts kommt über den Microsoft Store und sogar die offiziellen Sachen von Microsoft nicht.
Ich glaube, das neue Windows Terminal gibt es über den Store.
Moment, das kenne ich.
Hieß das nicht WinDeerStat oder so früher?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
WinDeerStat gab es doch sonst immer.
Ja, das da meine ich.
Das habe ich früher unter Windows immer verwendet, um zu gucken, wo was ist.
Okay, aber mein, das geht auch. Das sieht eh relativ ähnlich aus.
Treesize sieht ein bisschen moderner aus, ja.
Falls ihr also etwa Speicher auf eurem Computer freiräumen möchtet,
sei es Spiele, vergessene Videos oder auch temporäre Dateien,
dann ist Treesize genau das Richtige für euch.
Quick Look klingt nicht nur so wie ein Mac OS Feature,
es ist tatsächlich eine Kopie einer beliebten Funktion aus Apples Betriebssystem.
Wie der Name schon sagt, können wir schnell einen Blick in Dokumente werfen,
ohne dass damit verknüpfte Programme starten zu müssen.
Erst so einfach im Windows Explorer irgendeine Datei markieren
und dann auf die Leertaste eurer Tastatur drücken.
Ich meine, das ist auch so ein Feature, was irgendwie,
also ich kenne das aus Mac OS, ich benutze zwar nicht aktiv Mac OS,
aber gesehen habe ich schon, wo ich so genau nicht verstehe, warum es da ist.
Vielleicht merkt man das erst, wenn man das öfters verwendet.
Aber habe ich nicht genau extra Programme für bestimmte Dateitypen installiert,
weil ich sie darin öffnen möchte?
Also zum Beispiel habe ich doch einen PDF-Reader installiert,
damit ich PDFs darin öffne.
Wo ist denn der Sinn, wenn ich PDFs in einem Vorschau-Programm öffne,
um sie dann im PDF-Reader zu öffnen, anstatt sie...
Also bei manchen Sachen, so genau verstehe ich den Sinn nicht.
Und dann auf die Leertaste eurer Tastatur drücken.
Es ist einfach und schnell und es werden wirklich sehr viele Dateitypen unterstützt,
seien es Office-Dokumente, Videos, Bilder oder PDFs.
Eine Frage, die sich viele von euch bestimmt schon gestellt haben,
wieso kann man eigentlich nicht die Helligkeit seines Monitors mit Windows steuern?
Kann man?
Ja, ich frage mich vieles, warum man das unter Windows nicht machen kann.
Nach der Installation aus dem Microsoft Store erscheint die App,
ähnlich wie ihr Trumpet, im Trail-Bereich der Taskleistung.
Ich meine, über die Grafikkartensettings kann man das machen.
Auf das Icon kann man ganz einfach per Schieberegler die Helligkeit
mit aller angeschlossenen Monitore einzeln oder als Gesamtes regulieren.
Weitere coole Funktionen verbergen sich in den Einstellungen.
War nicht so schlecht.
Eyeburner ist ein guter Name.
Hotkeys festlegen oder auch die Anpassung der Helligkeit nach Uhrzeit automatisieren.
Ein Beispiel hierfür wäre die Reduzierung der Helligkeit von 70 auf 40 Prozent um 19 Uhr.
Strom spart man dadurch definitiv nicht.
Vielleicht spart man dadurch Strom, wenn man einen Monitor hat mit dimmbarer Hintergrundbeleuchtung.
Dann vielleicht, aber normalerweise nicht.
Verbergen sich in den Einstellungen ist und kein lebender Zombie ist, sollte es eigentlich klappen.
Also einfach herunterladen und ausprobieren.
Wenn es nicht läuft, kann man sie ja sauber deinstallieren.
Der grünende Abschluss unseres Videos stellt einen würdigen Ersatz für das alte, eingestaubte Notepad dar.
Ja, einfach Visual Studio Code installieren und gut ist.
Welches seit Jahrzehnten in Windows herumgeistert.
Also wenn jetzt nicht Visual Studio Code kommt, da weiß ich auch nicht.
Weil das ist die einfachste Variante, Cross-Platformen einen gescheiten Editor zu kriegen, den jeder bedienen kann.
Wenn es nach mir geht, würden wir alle Wim verwenden.
Aber ich bin ja nicht jeder und ich kann es verstehen, warum die meisten Leute lieber Visual Studio Code verwenden.
Ich ja mittlerweile auch.
Einfach weil Visual Studio Code sehr schön erweiterbar ist mit vielen nützlichen Sachen.
Da kann so Plime Text und Notepad++ leider nicht mithalten.
Also gerade wenn man auch was machen möchte, außer ein bisschen Text eintippen, sind gerade die Visual Studio Code Plugins echt Gold wert.
Das ist das aktivste Editor Plugin Ökosystem, was es zurzeit gibt für alle Editors.
Also eigentlich kommt man in vielen Bereichen um Visual Studio Code gar nicht mehr rum.
Hängen wir ein S an den Namen, bekommen wir eine schöne und moderne Version des Notepads.
Im Endeffekt kann Notepads genau das, was der Editor kann.
Nichts außer unformatierten Text bearbeiten.
Nur, dass es dabei wie ein modernes Windows-Programm aussieht.
Dann noch lieber gleich Visual Studio Code.
Die App wäre natürlich nicht auf dieser Liste, wenn sie nicht noch ein paar Vorzüge besäße.
Mein Lieblingsfeature ist der kompakte Modus, bei dem ein kleines Fenster voll lässt und noch über alle anderen spielt.
Man muss sagen, das Einzige, was echt ein bisschen nervig ist an Visual Studio Code, was ich aber auch leg, nachdem man es ein paar Mal geöffnet hat, ist, dass es beim ersten Start ein bisschen dauert.
Ich hatte es noch nicht offen, wenn ich jetzt Visual Studio Code aufmache, also es dauert schon so 5 Sekunden bis es dann da ist.
Allerdings, wenn man es ein paar Mal öffnet, dann geht es natürlich schneller.
Und man kann irgendwo in Windows, fragt mich nicht wo, kann man irgendwo einstellen, dass er solche Programme standardmäßig schon preloadet.
Gibt es einen Dark Mode? Tja, gute Frage, keine Ahnung.
Na gut, also Notepads. Die anderen Sachen fand ich tatsächlich gar nicht, also Quicklog brauche ich nicht.
Das mit der Helligkeit ist ganz nett, aber ihr Trumpet ist wirklich gut, wenn man da irgendwie Anwendungszweck für hat.
Das würde ich wirklich installieren.
So, das hatten wir schon.
Übrigens, das wollte ich euch mal zeigen, das ist mega geil, was der Typ mit seinem Haus gemacht hat.
Ich würde es im Leben nicht machen, das Problem ist nur, Musik, Musik im Stream.
Geht nicht.
Gibt es da irgendwie einen Cover von, was ich spielen kann, als Alternative?
Einen Cover oder so?
Cover.
Zumindest das hier, ist das ein gutes Cover.
Oh nein, das hört sich schon schlimm an.
Zumindest der Typ hat, ich kann das jetzt nicht zeigen, das geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Der Typ hat so Lichtershow gemacht an seinem Haus mit der Musik.
Übels nice.
Ihr wisst ja was, was auch geil ist, wenn der Typ anfängt zu singen, kommt sogar so ein Kürbis.
Übels nice, oder? Richtig poggers.
Ich meine, du kriegst epileptische Anfälle, wenn du da vorstehst, wahrscheinlich.
Übels geil.
Die Nachbarn sind wahrscheinlich auch am kotzen, ja?
Das ist doch echt geil gemacht. Ich meine, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen aufwendig, ja?
Also guck mal, der muss sein komplettes Garagentor mit LED-Strips versorgen.
Der macht sein ganzes Haus mit LED-Strips voll, der hat irgendwie die LED-Strips-Spinnen.
Strahle auf dem Dach, LED-Dinger im Fenster, also das ist schon nicht ohne.
Aber geil gemacht, oder?
Also es ist schon poggers.
Da kannst du echt nichts sagen, schon geil gemacht.
Der hat noch mehr, der hat auch, hier, das ist auch geil.
Übels nice.
Die Arbeit, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, die Arbeit wäre es mir nicht wert.
Außerdem ist der Stromverbrauch gar nicht mal ohne.
Also jetzt nicht auf Dauer betrachtet, sondern du brauchst ordentliche Netzteile,
dass du diese LED-Strips betreiben kannst.
Also jetzt mit irgendeinem 5V Raspberry Pi Netzteil kommst du da nicht so weit.
Und ich gehe auch nicht davon aus, dass es 5V LED-Strips sind,
weil 5V LED-Strips über so eine Reichweite klappt nicht.
Das wären wahrscheinlich, was ist denn das, wahrscheinlich 24, was gibt es denn sonst noch so?
Ich habe bloß 5V LED-Strips, was gibt es denn noch? 12V, 24V LED-Strips?
Zumindest 5V LED-Strips werden es nicht sein, weil die sind nach ein paar Metern,
dann funktionieren die LEDs nicht mehr, da zu viel Spannungstrop über,
wahrscheinlich in 12V USB-Strips.
Zumindest ist es geil gemacht.
Und du brauchst ordentliche Netzteile.
Also ich denke mal nicht, dass du da mit wie gesagt so ein paar kleinen Stecker-Netzteilen,
mit so kleinen Bollern da auskommst, da wirst du schon im Keller
so 3, 4 fette 1200 Watt Server-Netzteile brauchen oder irgendwie sowas,
wo du dann die 12V abgreifst.
Oder falls es dafür irgendwie, da gibt es wahrscheinlich schon fertige Netzteile für.
Aber das braucht schon ein bisschen was.
So eine einzelne LED-Lampe und LEDs brauchen nicht viel, aber in der Summe ist es schon nicht ohne.
Ich glaube, wenn man sowas in Deutschland macht, ist das erste, was passiert,
dass die Nachbarn bei der Polizei anrufen oder sowas.
Mittlerweile wird es ja auch wieder von, wie kann man das nennen,
von staatlicher Stelle angeregt, seine Mitbewohner und Mitanwohner,
zu verpetzen, wenn die irgendwas machen.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt aus dem Fenster gucken würde und sehe,
mein Nachbar sitzt im Garten mit 10 Leuten und trinkt ein,
dann müsste ich dann bei der Polizei anrufen.
Leute, Leute, mein Nachbar macht illegal, illegal Corona-Party hier.
Das geht nicht, kommt mal vorbei hier und schnappt euch den Sack.
Das wird ja gerade angeregt.
Also, dass man so Leute wieder verpetzen soll.
Was ich auch nicht gut finde.
Wir hatten das schon in dunkleren Zeiten in Deutschland,
das Verpetzen einer Tagesordnung war und du nicht mehr sicher sein konntest in deinen eigenen vier Wänden.
Ich finde, das muss nicht unbedingt wieder sein.
Gerade in der aktuellen Zeit nicht, wo eh schon jeder jedem irgendwie misstraut.
Da braucht man das nicht.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was wieder geil ist auf Twitter?
Ich habe den Fehler gemacht, dass ich Twitter mal wieder auf Deutschland umgestellt habe.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe Twitter immer auf Andorra stehen,
dass ich keine Trends aus Deutschland mitkriege,
weil mir die Trends aus Deutschland und international meistens so sehr auf den Sack gehen.
Das ist immer wieder der gleiche Kram, das sind immer wieder das gleiche dumme Gelaber,
was ich mir nicht mehr geben kann.
Andorra hat einfach gar keine Trends.
Und deswegen ist das nicht so wild.
Da kann man Twitter sich einfach nur angucken, was getwittert wird von denen,
die immer voll laut und sieht sonst nichts.
So und zumindest, ich habe den Fehler gemacht,
habe Twitter mal wieder auf Deutsch umgestellt.
Mal gucken, wie es heute ist.
Mal gucken, was heute auf Twitter trendet.
Twitter in Germany trendet.
Ob immer noch Klopapier trendet, weil da wollte ich mal was.
Da habe ich den Fehler gemacht,
habe Twitter wieder auf Deutsch umgestellt.
Und Trends, wo sind die Trends?
Nein, keine.
Es trenden kein Klopapier mehr.
Zumindest, ich habe Twitter mal wieder umgestellt auf,
wie sie sich hier drüber aufgeregt haben, wenn man China tweetet.
Also ich habe Twitter umgestellt auf,
wo man das einstellen kann, hier neben bei den Trends,
wenn du eingeloggt bist.
Oder am einfachsten umstellen kannst du es über Smartphone-App.
Aber es geht auch hier über den Browser.
So, ich habe es auf Deutsch umgestellt.
Und da haben sie sich wieder über Klopapier aufgeregt.
Wie dumm Leute sind die Klopapier jetzt horten und kaufen und sowas.
Und ich sehe es komplett anders.
Ich habe eh manchmal das Gefühl,
also ich sehe die Sachen nicht anders,
weil ich sie auf das Prinzip anders finde.
Also ich sehe die Sachen nicht anders,
weil ich sie auf das Prinzip anders sehen will.
Aber ich habe oftmals das Gefühl,
wenn ich gerade Twitter-Trends lese,
dass ich 90% der Sachen anders sehe wie Twitter.
Und ich die meisten Leute auf Twitter einfach für low-brain halte.
Total hängen geblieben.
Also zumindest haben sie sich wieder über Klopapier aufgeregt,
dass die Leute mit der Klopapier kaufen würden
und dass kein Klopapier mehr da ist.
Und wenn einer geschrieben hat, er hat Klopapier bekommen,
dann haben die Leute wieder gleich ihn gehatet.
So nach dem Motto, du bist Teil des Problems.
Blablabla.
Haben sich wieder alle empört.
Übrigens der Beste, wenn ihr euch mal kaputtlachen wollt,
bei Antworten,
dann müsst ihr mal mein Klopapier tweeten.
Mein Klopapier tweet euch angucken.
Das war auch witzig.
Exzellent.
Ich habe ja Klopapier bestellt im Internet.
Vor einer Weile.
Also hier, das ist noch vom April,
wo das erste Mal so angesagt war.
So.
Und eine Sache, das ist nicht von jetzt,
das ist ein halbes Jahr her.
Ich habe davon übrigens immer noch welches,
weil ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
Ich habe quasi nur zwei, drei davon verwendet
und den Urlaub, den ich jetzt habe,
ich habe quasi nur zwei, drei davon verwendet
und den unteren habe ich zusammengelassen.
Ich habe den ganzen unteren,
den ganzen unteren Pack habe ich noch,
fragt mich nicht, 68 Rollen oder 70 Rollen
oder was das ist, was ist denn das hier?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 oder?
Sind das 6? Nee.
4, 4, 8, ne?
8 pro Packung.
8, 16, 24,
48,
72?
Das 72 habe ich richtig gerechnet.
72, 72 Rollen noch, kann das sein?
Den unteren Teil habe ich noch.
Sind das 72?
He doesn't know,
he lacks critical information, quick maths.
Ich glaube 72 Rollen habe ich noch.
Zumindest worauf ich raus will ist,
also erstens witzigerweise,
da haben sie sich übelst drüber aufgeregt schon
und ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
das war die einzig sinnvolle Entscheidung damals
zu sagen, hey, ich mache diesen ganzen Wahnsinn
im Laden nicht mit,
aber man möchte ja im gleichen Fall
auch nicht das Risiko eingehen, kein Klopapier mehr zu haben.
Deswegen, was machen wir?
Das was im Entwicklungsland,
digitalen Entwicklungsland halt
nun mal nicht so viele Leute
kapieren ist, man kann die Sachen auch im Internet bestellen.
Also bin ich zu irgendeinem Händler gegangen,
der Klopapier verkauft
und habe einfach mal so eine
Albe-Palette bestellt
und gut ist.
Du darfst deine Windows-U umstellen.
Ist doch, ist doch schon.
Ist doch schon.
Ach nee, Moment, es ist 10.30 erst.
Warum macht das
Windows nicht automatisch?
Warum macht das Windows nicht automatisch?
He lacks critical
information, ja?
Warum macht das Windows nicht automatisch?
Wie stellt man überhaupt
die Uhrzeit um?
Ich hab das noch nie gemacht, jetzt ernsthaft,
ich hab das wirklich noch nie gemacht.
Was?
Ich brauche
Admin-Rechte
Ich brauche Admin-Rechte
für
Na gut.
Ah, jetzt stimmt's.
Exzellent.
Gut, aber um zu der eigentlichen Sache mal zu kommen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung,
das war damals die einzig sinnvolle Entscheidung.
Aber ich bin der Meinung,
Und zumindest jetzt ist es so,
dass die Leute, die
pissen
Geil, jetzt ist wieder
jetzt ist mein
Maus-Freigebe-Ding abgekackt.
Ich kann nicht mehr auf den anderen Bildschirm wechseln.
Exzellent.
Hallo?
Warum?
Alter,
jetzt ist mein Maus-Freigebe für den
zweiten Bildschirm abgeschissen.
Primo, dann Dankeschön.
Warum ist das so?
Ich starte das mal neu.
Exzellent.
Geht immer noch nicht.
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Jetzt kann ich zu der eigentlichen Sache zurückkommen,
die ich sagen wollte.
Ich habe so eingestellt, dass ich mit einer Maus
von einem Bildschirm auf den anderen kann, obwohl der am gleichen Rechner
angeschlossen ist.
Ja.
So.
Auf Twitter haben sie jetzt nämlich wieder so getan,
als sind die Leute alle böse,
die
Klopapier gerade wieder kaufen.
Wobei ich persönlich der Meinung bin,
dass es eigentlich genau umgedreht.
Also ich verstehe nicht, warum man sich so
überhaupt darüber aufregt, dass andere Leute
Klopapier kaufen. Und was ich
ganz besonders lustig finde, ist, dass
es wird so getan, als wären die
Leute dumm, die Klopapier kaufen.
Dabei ist es genau umgedreht.
Die Leute, die das nicht kaufen,
sind eigentlich dumm.
Warum? Weil es im Prinzip schon
so ist, was damals Vars in
Far Cry gesagt hat. Wenn man den
gleichen Scheiß immer wieder gleich dumm macht,
ist man halt verrückt.
Das heißt, man hat gelernt das letzte
Mal, okay,
die Leute drehen am Rad und kaufen
eine Klopapier. Das heißt, wenn ich
jetzt kein Klopapier kaufe,
bin ich eigentlich doof.
Weil ich weiß, was kommen wird und ich
weiß, wie es das letzte Mal gelaufen ist.
Also eigentlich
ist es genau umgedreht. Jemand, der
jetzt kein Klopapier kauft,
ist doof. Nicht der, der Klopapier
kauft.
Weil ansonsten haben sie aus dem Letzten nichts gelernt.
Und natürlich
ist es so,
wenn alle Leute
sich
am Riemen
reißen würden
und nur, ganz
stur, nur das kaufen,
was sie aktuell benötigen,
so wie immer,
dann gäbe es das Problem nicht.
Aber,
wir wissen ja, dass es nicht so ist.
Also sprich,
jeder, der sagt, dass Horten
zu Engpässt zu Problemen führt, hat Recht.
Aber, nachdem wir wissen,
dass sich garantiert nicht alle Leute
am Riemen reißen werden,
hat man eigentlich gar keine
andere Wahl, aus dem
gelernt, vom letzten Mal
die Rückschlüsse zu ziehen.
Hey, ich kauf lieber schon mal was.
Weil ansonsten
musst du dich wieder darauf verlassen,
dass andere Leute das
Richtige machen.
Oder das für die Allgemeinheit,
das Richtige kann man nicht sagen, aber
das für die Allgemeinheit Verträglichere machen
und darauf kannst du dich nicht verlassen.
Und nachdem man weiß, dass man sich darauf nicht verlassen kann,
ist man blöde, wenn man jetzt nichts bestellt.
Allerdings,
was ich immer noch denke,
was sinnvoller ist,
nicht in Laden rennen und dort irgendwie
50 Pakete Klopapier kaufen,
sondern einfach in einen Online-Shop gehen.
Dann kauft man den Laden nicht leer
und man hat trotzdem seinen Klopapier.
Genauso hab ich ja hier auch gemacht.
Ich hab das ganze online bestellt. Ich bin ja nicht etwa
in Lidl gefallen und hab hier funny Klopapier gekauft.
Ich hab einfach online bestellt.
Da kommt jeder der Reihe nach dran
und
es führt auch nicht zu eng
im Supermarkt.
Also ich hab hier bestellt, Moment.
Aber da hab ich schon
von einem anderen gehört im Stream, dass es bei ihm
nie angekommen ist.
Hier, da hab ich das letzte Mal bestellt.
Klopapier.
Hier, funny.
Müsst ihr gucken, die haben verschiedenste Sachen.
Manchmal haben die sogar Angebote.
Auch in der aktuellen Zeit.
Und da kriegt ihr alles.
Zumindest was ich sagen will ist,
es ist nachvollziehbar,
jetzt Klopapier zu kaufen.
Und die, die sich auf Twitter darüber empören,
sind die ersten, die rumheulen,
wenn sie nichts mehr bekommen.
Wie böse ja alle zu ihnen sind.
Und ich finde, das ist eine Art
von Dummheit letztendlich.
Also wenn ich doch schon weiß,
was auf mich zukommt, und wenn ich aus dem
letzten Mal
nichts gelernt hab,
dann bin ich doch dumm, oder?
Oder verstehe ich die Twitterlogik nicht?
Ich mein, es gibt
zwei Sachen. Es gibt die
die Betrachtungsweise ja,
es ist
schlecht für die Allgemeinheit
oder unsolidarisch wie auch immer,
wenn die Leute Klopapier haben.
Aber auf der anderen Seite
für individuell
betrachtet, ist man doch doof,
wenn man nicht daraus gelernt hat, wie es das letzte Mal
gelaufen ist.
Und deswegen
verstehe ich die Leute nicht, die jetzt rumheulen
und sagen, oh nein, Hilfe,
jetzt kaufen wir den Leuten Klopapier.
Die ersten, die jetzt sagen, Leute kauft
kein Klopapier, sind die ersten, die
weinen, weil sie keins mehr bekommen.
Also, eigentlich richtig, richtig dämlich.
Es gibt ja auch genug.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir zu wenig
Klopapier. Es gab ja das letzte Mal
auch genug, die haben bloß Probleme gehabt,
genug in den Supermarkt zu bekommen.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir allgemein zu wenig
Klopapier gehabt, als wäre Klopapier jetzt
irgendwie
aus der Goldmine, als wäre die Goldmine die
Klopapiermine in Afrika leer gewesen. Ist ja nicht
so.
Wir hatten genug Klopapier, aber das kam nicht
genug in den Supermarkt.
Wieso Klopapier? Oh, ich glaube, das ist eine psychologische
Frage, wo es mit Sicherheit
schon irgendwelche Studien zugibt.
Habe ich nicht einen Sub eben übersehen?
Moment.
11 Monate, danke schön. Ich glaube, das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Danke schön.
Warum Klopapier?
Keine Ahnung. Das ist, glaube ich, irgendeine
psychologische Geschichte, dass die Leute
quasi denken, okay,
wenn es der Welt schlecht geht,
was ist, also das ist jetzt so eine
Hobbypsychologie-Interpretation von mir.
Was ist das, was
mich quasi
ganz intim betrifft? Und das ist natürlich
das Klopapier.
Irgendwie sowas wird der Gedankengang
da unter Bewusstsein, warum gerade Klopapier?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
VTS Twitch Prime, danke schön.
Exzellent Subscription.
Ja.
Also ich sehe schon im Chat,
dass es wieder welche gibt, die empört sind
darüber. Aber wie würdet ihr das
denn nennen, wenn man absichtlich
sagt, das ist kein
Problem.
Wenn man absichtlich
Sachen ignoriert,
die man
in der Vergangenheit
quasi gesehen hat,
die nicht richtig funktionieren und sie dann ignoriert
und das absichtlich wieder
verkehrt macht.
Das ist doch eigentlich
bescheuert.
Also man hat das letzte
Mal gesehen, ja, es wäre schön,
wenn sich alle solidarisch verhalten
und
nur in
normalem Ausmaß
Klopapier kaufen. Aber man
hat doch das letzte Mal gesehen, das ist
nicht so.
Und man kann davon ausgehen,
es wird jetzt auch nicht so sein.
Du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass die Mehrzahl der Leute
jetzt auf einmal, wir haben es ja gesehen,
dass es das letzte Mal nicht so war,
sagen, wir denken solidarisch und machen
das für die Allgemeinheit und kaufen nichts doppelt
und dreifach. Da kannst du dich nicht darauf verlassen.
Das heißt, wenn man daraus
gelernt hat, was das letzte Mal
passiert ist, dann kauft man sich jetzt
bei irgendeinem großen Händler, keine
Ahnung, einen
8er Pack Klopapier
und macht bei diesem ganzen
Wahnsinn einfach nicht mit.
Das ist
kein
Das ist eigentlich die einzig logische Variante.
Und außerdem, es gibt kein
Problem. Es gibt genug
Klopapier.
Aber du kriegst halt Probleme,
wenn die Leute den Supermarkt leer kaufen
und dort
die Regale leer machen und die müssen das
rankarren.
Das ist ein Problem, dass es zu wenig
Klopapier gibt.
Das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das ist ja nicht so. Das heißt, wenn man im Internet
geht
und bestellt sich
bei irgendeinem Großhändler
einen 8er Pack, dann ist das
für alle Beteiligten am besten. Man selbst
hat genug,
weil man hat daraus gelernt, man bekommt nichts.
Die Leute
im Supermarkt können nach wie vor einkaufen.
Es gibt mehr als genug.
Letztendlich
wenn man diese Schlüsse
daraus gezogen hat, ist eigentlich für alle Beteiligten
das Beste.
Also was Besseres kannst du eigentlich nicht machen.
Ich sagte, die ganze Zeit online bestellen. Bei Amazon
kannst du ja teilweise gar nicht mehr online bestellen.
Wenn du bei Amazon Klopapier bestellen willst
dann hast du teilweise bis
November Wartezeit. Ich meine, es geht noch.
Es sind noch zwei Wochen. Es gibt auch welche, die sind
jetzt direkt lieferbar. Aber man sieht schon,
es wird ein bisschen enger.
Ich denke, man muss da
grundsätzlich, das geht jetzt nicht
nur wirklich für Klopapier, man muss da
zwei Sachen unterscheiden.
Die ideale Ansicht,
die wir alle teilen, denke ich,
mal, dass es
das Beste wäre, wenn sich alles
solidarisch verhalten.
Das ist die eine Sache. Ich glaube, da sind
wir alle der gleichen Ansicht. Wenn man
davon ausgeht, im Optimalfall sollte
jeder nur das kaufen, was er gerade braucht.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, man könnte nicht im Internet bestellen,
nur im Supermarkt. Dann wäre
das der Optimalfall.
Aber wir haben ja gesehen,
das ist nicht so.
Und man kann davon ausgehen,
so sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche,
dass nicht auf einmal
jetzt alle anfangen und sie so
verhalten werden.
Das ist vollkommen klar. Das war
das letzte Mal ja auch so.
So, und jetzt ist halt die Frage,
was man macht. Entweder
man empört sich da drüber
und sagt, ihr seid alle
böse und steht
dann am Ende ohne
Klopapier da. Das Klopapier ist ja quasi
nur stellvertretend für andere Sachen.
Hat sich aber empört
und fühlt sich moralisch auf der richtigen Seite.
Das ist die eine Variante.
Also die eine Variante ist, man fühlt
sich moralisch besser, dass man quasi
solidarisch gehandelt hat und putzt sich
den Arsch im Zweifelsheim mit der Hand ab
oder geht unter die Dusche. Das ist das eine.
Oder man sagt, okay,
in Abwägung
der Umstände und was wir aus dem letzten Mal
gelernt haben, ich kann mich
nicht drauf verlassen, dass sich die anderen
da solidarisch verhalten.
Klar, natürlich ist das eine gewisse
Kettenreaktion. Das ist schon klar.
Und ich scheiß drauf
und verhalte mich unsolidarisch. Dafür habe ich
im Ende für Klopapier. Das ist eine Abwägung,
die musst du bei ganz vielen Sachen treffen.
Also das ist eigentlich, finde ich, ein ziemlich
komplexe, komplexe Geschichte.
Aber man kann nicht einfach nur sagen,
jemand, der jetzt Klopapier
kauft, ist dumm. Und das ist das, was Twitter
macht. Das ist, finde ich, verkehrt.
Derjenige, der jetzt Klopapier
kauft,
macht eigentlich genau das,
was er macht, also was
nachvollziehbar ist.
Er hat aus den Fehlern
das letzte Mal gelernt.
Also, so die zwei Sachen
gibt es. Und natürlich
muss sich jeder selbst überlegen, was er macht.
Aber viele Probleme,
also viele alltägliche Problemstellungen,
die man hat, sind
eine Abwägung aus,
was mache ich jetzt individuell
und was mute ich der Allgemeinheit
zu?
Da gibt es ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz
viele, viele Sachen.
Zum Beispiel,
ich gehe jetzt
Was habe ich letztens in einem Video gehört,
hat auch einer so was Ähnliches
gesagt. So nach dem Motto, wenn ich
bei einer Versicherung bin,
melde ich den Schaden jetzt
oder bezahle ich ihn selbst?
Das ist ja auch so eine Abwägung.
Bezahle ich das selbst? Okay, weil dann vielleicht die Beiträge nicht steigen.
Oder sage ich,
ne, ich lasse es von der Versicherung übernehmen,
mit dem Hintergrund wissen,
dass vielleicht die Beiträge steigen.
Das sind so Abwägungen.
Es gibt ganz viele alltägliche
Entscheidungen, die Abwägungen
sind zwischen
dem, was ich für die Allgemeinheit
mache und
abgewegt das, was ich individuell
für mich mache.
Klopapier ist halt so das offensichtlichste
gerade.
Ja, und außerdem
gibt es bei mir,
was Klopapier angeht, eh weniger Probleme, weil ich
habe hier mein Profi-Klo
mit Wasserstrahl für Bobbes.
Ja, Max, du Tant sehe ich auch so.
Das ist auch so ein Ding,
warum ich die Twitter-Trends ausgeschaltet habe,
ist, weil
die Twitter-Trends eigentlich
alle möglichen Gruppierungen
an Leuten mehr oder
weniger nur untereinander posten, um sich
gegenseitig zu bestätigen, wie überlegen
und geil sie sind. Deswegen kann ich mir Twitter
auch nicht mehr geben auf Dauer.
So.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Speed up Windows 10
with one? Okay.
Also, von dem habe ich schon ein paar Videos geguckt,
die sind eigentlich recht gut.
Normalerweise sind solche Videos eher
keck,
aber ich finde, die sind
eigentlich recht gut.
Also, ich finde,
die sind eigentlich recht gut.
Normalerweise sind solche Videos eher
keck W, keck W.
So.
Aber mal gucken. Mal gucken, was wir
für ein Command ausführen,
damit Windows 10 schneller wird.
Okay, mal raten. Ich versuche mal,
zu raten.
Okay, Festplatten-Defragmentierungsgedöns
kann es nicht sein. Das ist
kein Ding mehr.
Was könnte man machen, dass
ein Command,
was Windows schneller macht?
Die CPU in Performance-Modus stellen,
was eigentlich gar nichts bringt, aber man weiß ja nie.
Daniel Null, 16
Monate. Oh, Massive-Pock.
Ja, das ist ja schon Hyper-Subscriber.
Alles Dankeschön für 16 Monate
Subscription.
Man braucht eigentlich 10 Minuten
für einen...
Okay, okay, okay.
Ich habe eine Idee, was das ist.
Das ist nicht ein Kommando, was der
ausführt. Der
lädt sich irgendeinen
Skript runter und führt das aus,
was
wahrscheinlich 50
Kommandos macht.
Okay, jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Ach nee, hat er schon gesagt, dass das
ein Kommando ist. Okay, das ist G-Babe.
Also das ist so eine typische Windows-Geschichte.
Wir führen erstmal ein Kommando aus
oder wir laden uns
random im Internet
irgendwelche Skripte-Programme was auch immer runter
und führen sie aus. Das ist so eine typische Windows-Geschichte.
Ich will nicht behaupten, dass ich nie
Weget was nach Bash gepiped
habe oder so, aber in der Regel gucke ich mir
zumindest das erste Mal an, was es ist.
Ich muss mal kurz Pause machen.
Es ist im Chat wieder...
Ich muss euch mal an der Stelle loben.
Ich sehe es selten auf Twitter,
sowohl als auf Twitch,
dass es sinnvolle Diskussionen
im Chat gibt. Das ist ja eh schon kaum so
und auf Twitter gar nicht mal.
Aber ich muss sagen, hier im Chat,
ich muss euch da mal wirklich sagen,
das ist selten. Es ist wirklich selten,
dass die Leute halbwegs normal miteinander kommunizieren
und diskutieren können. Und bei mir im Chat
ist es auch selten.
Es ist exquisite Big-Brain-Chat.
Deswegen muss ich noch mal eine Sache kurz sagen,
weil es gerade in den Diskussionen
im Chat gibt, ob man
egoistisch sein sollte,
solidarisch sein sollte, sonst was.
Man darf nie den Fehler machen,
alles immer absolut zu sehen.
Die wenigsten Entscheidungen sind
100% schwarz, 100% weiß.
Also sprich,
jeder wird tagtäglich
Entscheidungen fällen,
die eher aus
aus,
nennen wir es mal so,
ich angetrieben egoistischen Sachen
getroffen werden, als auch welche,
die abgewägt werden, wo man sagt, hey,
ich mach das jetzt nicht
so, wie es für mich am besten ist,
sondern so, wie es für mich, meine Familie
allgemein am besten ist.
Also es gibt ja auch, es gibt halt
bei den wenigsten Sachen schwarz und weiß.
Also keiner ist
immer egoistisch und keiner ist
immer, macht immer alles für die Gemeinheit.
In Wirklichkeit macht jeder
alles.
So, natürlich hast du
Leute, die sind ein bisschen mehr
auf sich selbst fokussiert und
Leute, die sind ein bisschen mehr auf die Allgemeinheit,
aber im Prinzip macht
jeder alles.
Deswegen kann man das gar nicht so
sagen, so nach dem Motto,
es ist, es ist, es ist
eine schlecht, das andere gut,
weil es macht eh jeder alles.
Wie hieß die Windows 10
für den Lautstärke-Mixer von dem
Ear Trumpet? Das hier glaube ich
hier. Ach ne, Ear,
Ear Trumpet.
Das da, hier.
Was von 2016 ist die?
Kann das sein, dass die schon komplett
outdated,
overrated ist?
Alter, Windows, geben wir nicht auf den Sack.
Sag mal, Leute,
Reddit, geht euch das,
in letzter Zeit ist Reddit richtig
ätzend geworden.
Ähm, zum Beispiel
du gehst auf,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es so im Desktop so ist.
Wenn du,
warte mal,
Google, Reddit, Linux,
zum Beispiel, irgendwas, man geht,
man geht hier irgendwie über
Google da drauf.
Oh, und jetzt, ich glaube im Desktop-Bereich
ist es nicht so, aber
ich hab' mobile immer das Problem,
dass wenn ich jetzt
auf weiterlesen klicke, möchte der,
dass ich mich einlogge oder die App installiere.
Also sprich, ich kann
kein Reddit mehr lesen im Browser,
auf dem Handy,
ohne dass ich mich einloggen muss oder eine App verwenden muss.
Was kein Ding ist, ich meine, ich verwende
eine App dafür, aber
also, ich
finde es kacke, weil viele Sachen lese ich
im Browser und gehe rein und versuche einfach
kurze Informationen anzugucken
und dann gehe ich wieder raus.
Zumal die Reddit-App hardcore
scheiße ist.
Ja, beste.
Beste App für Reddit.
Apollo Reader.
Also die einzige
Reddit-App auf iOS, die man sich geben kann.
Aber trotzdem,
das Switchen in die App ist zum größten Teil total
unsinnig, weil
man sucht,
also, du suchst irgendwas
auf Google,
das ist ja irgendwie was, keine Ahnung, du suchst jetzt mal
Linux,
How to, Bash, irgendwas.
Und die Chancen, dass ein Reddit-Eintrag
unter den ersten Treffern hier ist,
ist relativ hoch.
Ich gebe jetzt mal Reddit mit ein, weil es natürlich,
ist relativ hoch, das heißt, viele
sinnvolle Antworten findet man heutzutage
halt nur mal auf Reddit. Und deswegen, du gehst
in den Browser und
willst jetzt da durchlesen und du willst nicht erst
noch eine App starten.
Weil vielleicht bist du ja gerade in Reddit in der
App was am Lesen und du willst nicht, dass er einfach
dich dann auf ein anderes Topic bringt.
Total bescheuert. Ich verstehe
den Sinn auch gar nicht davon. Warum will man so eine
verfickte App pushen?
Reddit ist ein Forum.
Warum brauche ich, um ein Forum zu lesen, eine extra
App? Man kann sich ja eine extra
App installieren, wenn man will.
Soll man seine Post besser verwalten
will, seine subscribten Sachen
besser verwalten. Alles schön und gut. Aber die
Grundfunktionalität, aus einer Suchmaschine
in den Forum zu gehen und dort
eine Antwort zu lesen, die man gesucht hat,
die will ich nach wie vor verwenden können,
ohne dass ich mich registrieren muss, anmelden muss
oder eine App starten muss. Also ich weiß nicht,
was mit Reddit da gerade los ist. Die drehen voll am Rad.
Tomtricks, Magneson,
Exzellent, Wahlextrem, Exzellent,
Exzellentes, Subscriptions, zwei Monate hier.
Huge.
Hast du heute schon mal an Reddit gedacht?
Oh ja, das ist auch nervig. Deswegen verwende
wie gesagt, ich verwende nur noch Apollo Reader.
Weil Reddit, die
Reddit App selbst ist mir richtig schlecht.
Reddit, also mal gucken, was die für
Bewertungen hat mittlerweile. Okay, die ist
hat auch ganz gute Bewertung.
Vielleicht ist die besser geworden. Weiß nicht.
Aber ich verwende immer nur die hier.
Gut.
Leider
gibt es
keine
ums jetzt mal ein bisschen
das Thema zu wechseln.
Es gibt leider keine gute Twitch App
für Android, die nicht
die offizielle Twitch App ist.
Also
für YouTube hast du ja
New Pipe und YouTube Vans
und so, das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut. Aber es gibt
keine, es gibt keinen Twitch
Twitch Vans, das ist ein bisschen doof.
Übrigens, die Android
Kenner, ich muss euch jetzt mal was fragen. Vielleicht weiß
das jemand. Big, Big
Brain Chat. Es sind gerade über 300
Leute da. Kann ich euch mal fragen.
Vielleicht weiß das jemand.
Wie kann ich
über Tasker oder irgendwie
über irgendeine Automatisierungs App
in Android, wie kann ich dort
eine Web App
starten? Also man kann ja
wenn man
was ich meine ist das hier.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile
die Möglichkeit, ich brauche jetzt mal ein
Beispiel dafür.
Es gibt ja die Möglichkeit,
dass du, wenn
bestimmte Webseiten
die richtigen
Sachen im Quelltext drin stehen haben, muss man
einfach zu sagen. Dann kann man die Sachen
auf den Startscreen
packen.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich
Home Assistant habe oder irgendwas anderes
und ich gehe auf die Seite, dann
sagt er mir, hey, möchten sie diese Webseite
nicht als Shortcut auf den Home Screen
hinzufügen. Das ist sinnvoll,
weil dann ist die App immer im
Fullscreen und
ich musste halt nicht im Browser
standen.
Twitter, PWA.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob man das hier
im Browser machen kann.
Install Twitter, genau.
Das geht ja auf Android, also sprich,
wenn ich auf Twitter gehe und ich habe nicht die App,
dann kann ich hier oben sagen, ey,
install, das fragt mich dann
Firefox oder Chrome direkt, wenn ich
das aufmache oder auch Safari
unter IOS.
Dann kann ich die
zu meinem Startbildschirm hinzufügen,
diese Anwendung.
Alles schön und gut.
Was ist denn das? Das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Aber wie starte
ich so eine auf den Startbildschirm
hinzugefügte App über Tasker oder
irgendeine Automatisierung? Wie geht das?
Was soll denn das sein?
Ach, das ist so eine Verknüpfung
zu allen möglichen PWAs, die es gibt.
Ok, warum nicht?
Wie starte ich so was
über Tasker? Ich habe nichts Gescheites
gefunden, ehrlich gesagt.
Die einzige Sache, die mir einfällt,
aber die es äußerst unschön ist,
dass ich einen Klick
simuliere auf mein Homescreen.
Aber das ist kacke.
Also wie starte ich zum Beispiel
aus Tasker oder generell über Android,
wie starte ich eine
Webapp
aufm Homescreen?
Normale Apps starten über Tasker
ist kein Problem. Da kannst du einfach sagen,
Launch App und wählst die App aus, aber PWAs stehen
da nicht drin. Und ich habe legit
keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Das wäre nämlich ganz praktisch, weil ich wollte
es auf meinem Tablet so machen.
Du kannst auch per Code was starten,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung, wie. Ich wollte es nämlich so machen,
dass wenn ich meinen Bildschirm entsperre auf meinem Tablet...
Was meinst du, so was wie
Lama? Nee, was soll das sein?
Ach so Automate, ja
zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ja.
Also es ist jetzt egal, es ist jetzt egal, ob man
Automate verwendet oder Tasker verwendet.
Eigentlich ist es egal, weil alle haben das gleiche Problem.
Also wie starte ich aus
irgendwie einem dieser Automatisierungsapp?
Mir ist auch vollkommen egal welcher. Wie
starte ich eine PWA, die aufm Homescreen ist?
Was ist eine PWA?
Das ist, wenn du auf eine Webseite gehst
und die dich fragt, ob du diese Webseite
auf deinen Startbildschirm, auf deinen Homescreen hinzufügen
willst. Das ist eine PWA.
Also eigentlich eine Verknüpfung zu einer Webseite,
die in einem Fullscreen Browser läuft.
Also wenn du mit deinem Handy auf Twitter gehst,
Home Assistant gehst und das erste Mal
auf die Seite gehst, dann fragt die dich,
möchten sie diese Seite jetzt zum Startbildschirm hinzufügen?
Und wenn du dann sagst, ja will ich,
dann ist das meistens eine PWA.
Und wie starte ich
diese Verknüpfung, die ich dort
auf den Homescreen hinzugefügt habe?
Ich finde nichts.
Das einzige, was mir einfällt, ist von Hand
dort auf den Startbildschirm zu klicken, aber das
geht ja gar nicht.
xFatal, 16 Monate,
danke schön für den Sub.
Hyper Subscriber hier
und wie? Danke schön für die Subscriptions.
Was kennst du?
Android.
Zeig mal hier. Was ist das?
Nein, Obot kann es nicht.
Damit habe ich es ausprobiert.
Wie soll das gehen?
Das geht nicht.
Weil ich habe es mit Automate
ausprobiert. Damit geht das nicht.
Du kannst mit Automate
kannst du sagen Start App, Launch App.
Aber du kannst
nur Apps auswählen,
die echte APKs sind.
Das geht nicht. So, was ist das?
Light Apps Browser.
Ich glaube,
das ist was anderes.
Ich glaube, das ist was anderes, oder?
Na ja, gut, mal gucken.
Es muss ja auch eine Firefox PWA sein
bei mir, weil ansonsten die Kameras nicht gehen.
Ich glaube,
das ist etwas anderes.
Das geht nicht.
Wenn es auf Chrome Basis ist,
sagt es.
Na ja, hätte sein können, dass das einer weiß.
Warum startest du nicht einfach
direkt die Seite? Wo ist der Vorteil?
Das würde ich machen, wenn die dann auch schön
vollscreen ist, habe ich kein Problem mit.
Du kannst doch angeben,
mit XY starten.
Ja, aber wenn ich sage,
also zum Beispiel, wenn ich sage,
starte Firefox und gebe dann die
Url von meinem Home Assistant ein,
dann macht der ja ein Browser-Fenster auf
mit Browser-Bedienelementen
und Urlleiste und sowas.
Aber Knarkraft Knusprig
ist nicht so wichtig.
Aber Knarkraft Knusprig,
wie gesagt, ich wüsste nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ich muss die nicht vom Startbildschirm starten.
Ich will die einfach nur
im Fullscreen starten, so wie es eine PWA macht.
Ich muss mir das nachher nochmal
angucken, aber ich habe da nichts gefunden,
weil was ich machen will ist Folgendes.
Ich habe mir hier so einen Workflow eingestellt
für mein Android Tablet,
will ich ja Amazon Fire Tablet,
dass wenn ich den Bildschirm entsperre...
Ne, das geht nicht. Herz 93. Man kann keinen
Fullscreen automatisch machen.
Fullscreen muss immer interaktiv sein.
Mach's gut, Subaru.
Fuck, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau. Ich will nämlich,
wenn ich meinen Bildschirm entsperre,
will ich, dass direkt nach dem Entsperren
erstes meine Heimautomatisierung aufgeht.
Ja, Tribulon, das Problem hiermit könnte sein,
dass es Chrome basiert ist
und ich muss es in Firefox starten.
Chrome basiert geht nicht, ich muss es in Firefox starten,
weil Chrome
lustigerweise auf den Fire Tablets
keine Videos
abspielen kann.
Die H.264 encoded sind.
Firefox kann's, die haben einen Decoder drin.
Chrome hat keinen Softwaredecoder drinne
für das gängigste Videoformat der Welt.
Muss er nicht, weil normalerweise verwenden
die den Hardwaredecoder von jeweiligen Device,
aber das kann Chrome auf dem Fire HD nicht.
Silk kann's,
aber Silk kann kein Fullscreen.
Es ist echt ätzend.
Ne, der Fully Kiosk Browser reicht nicht,
weil das ist auch Chrome Webview based
und Chrome geht nicht.
Chrome kann meine Kameras nicht anzeigen.
Nur Firefox kann das
unter Android auf dem Fire TV.
Und Silk, aber Silk kann kein Fullscreen.
Tja, das ist nicht so einfach, ne?
Doch Chrome auf Linux hat einen H.264 Decoder.
Was, ein Software H.264.
Unter Linux ist es, äh, Tomox,
unter Linux ist es genau umgedreht.
Unter Linux verwendet Chrome
immer den Softwaredecoder
und bis vor kurzem nie
den Hardwaredecoder.
Ne, iPad kaufen bringt mir ja schon mal gar nichts
an der Stelle.
Mit iPads kannst du ja noch weniger
automatisch machen
als mit Android.
Das ist auch für mich die große Daseinsberechtigung
von Android, dass man viel mehr automatisch machen kann.
Ja.
Ich probier das mal nachher aus, was ihr geschrieben habt,
aber ich fürchte, es wird nicht funktionieren.
Gerade getestet mit Haskell.
Na gut, ich muss, der Home Assistant,
ich brauch die Home Assistant PWA.
Muss ich starten, nachdem der
Bildschirm anlockt wird.
Ich probier das, ich probier mal
PWA zu, PWA zu...
Äh, Firefox. Es muss Firefox-based
sein. Ja, umut, ich hab's gesehen, ich probier das
nachher mal aus. Also, ich hab nichts
Gescheites gefunden bisher. Es sackt ein bisschen.
So, guck mal mal weiter. Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch Schönes?
Wie machen Microsoft... Achso, genau, wir wollten
uns ja How to Speed up Windows angucken, genau.
Also, was macht der denn?
Übelstes Debate-Video.
Post-Champ-Sachen.
Wisst ihr, was witzig ist?
Dass allein schon das
für die meisten 0-15-Anwender
der übelste Hacker-Move ist.
Also, allein schon, wenn ihr das hier macht.
Für die normalen
Windows-Anwender ist das der krasseste
Hacker-Move des Jahrtausends.
Die sagen,
Du kennst dich aber
gut aus mit Computer.
Die harte Version, exzellent.
Moment, hab ich das
auch schon?
Man kann übrigens, glaube ich, Alt-D oder so.
Ne, äh, Alt-R?
Hab ich das jetzt auch schon?
Oh ne, ich hab immer noch 20.04.
Oh nein.
Ich hab immer noch kein 20.H2.
Gibt's das noch nicht, oder wie ist das?
Moment, Check, Update, Update,
Update checken.
Ey, gibt's noch gar nicht, guck mal.
Ich bekomme
kein 20.H2 angezeigt.
Was soll das?
Warum krieg ich kein 20.H2?
Ne, das sind Driver-Updates, das war's anderes.
Das jetzt auch mal.
Warum krieg ich das nicht?
Pepega, Microsoft-Dings.
Huge Pepega.
Oh ne,
nicht so ein doofes
De-Bloat-Skript wieder. Davon gibt's so viele
und ich würd's mir nie im Leben auf meinem Rechner
ausführen, nie.
Wer weiß, was das da alles de-Bloatet, ich hab
kein Bock, mir vorher erst mal 500 Zeilen Skript
gewesen, das ist kein Scheiß-Bot bei mir auf dem Rechner.
Und außerdem, was
genau muss man da eigentlich alles de-Bloaten?
Es gibt also zwei Sachen, die mir spontan
einfallen, erstens, dass man diese ganzen
Candy Crush Geschiss deinstalliert, das kann man aber
auch so machen, und dass man ein paar Telemetriesachen
abschaltet. Aber ansonsten
wüsste ich nicht, was man an Windows
10 großartig de-Bloaten muss.
Okay, es installiert mir schon mal
zig Programme, die ich nicht haben will.
Top. Sehr gut.
Genau das brauche ich.
Genau das, genau, genau das brauche ich.
Ich brauch unbedingt nen Skript, was mir Geschiss
installiert, was ich denn brauch. Das erste geht
noch, das kann man installieren. Notepad++
brauche ich nicht, ich hab Visual Studio Core, Info brauche ich
erst recht nicht mehr, VLC installiere ich mir selbst,
Java will ich erst recht nicht drauf haben,
Adobe Reader und Brave will ich
auch garantiert nicht haben.
Also, wozu? Was macht's denn sonst noch?
Remove all store
App. Okay, das ist in Ordnung, Telemetries
in Ordnung, Disable Cortana ist auch okay.
Das finde ich nicht
gut. Moment.
Das hat er doch hier schon gemacht.
Doch Windows Store.
Das will ich auch nicht,
auch nichts gefixt haben. Also
braucht man nicht.
Ich finde es aber auch geil,
das ist ein, ich wollte hier eins, drei,
drei, sieben, exakt das.
Sie sagen, sie deep loaden dein Windows
und installieren dir erst mal
acht von zehn Programmen, die ich nicht brauche.
Exzellent.
Ich, IRFan
heißt das wirklich so? Ich hab
früher immer IRFan View gesagt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das so ausspricht.
Wie wird man das auf Englisch aussprechen?
Arvn
Arvn View
Arvn View. Ne, das kann man nicht aussprechen.
Ich hab immer IRFan
IRFan View gesagt.
Chocolate ist ein Package Manager für
Windows systemweit, den ich nicht
mehr verwende. Ich verwende nur Scoop mittlerweile.
Scoop ist Package Manager
für Entwicklertools für Windows, der
aber benutzerbezogen ist.
Warum installieren die überhaupt
irgendwas? Das ist eine gute, berechnigte
Frage, wundert mich auch. Wenn es
deep loaded ist, sollen sie vielleicht
nur Sachen wegmachen.
Das ist
einfach nicht sehr gut
im Vergleich zu diesem Programm, das
ist auch frei und open source.
VLC, das ist die Wahl
der meisten von Videoprogrammen
oder Videoprogrammen, also habe ich das
gewählt. In der letzten Video habe ich gesagt,
ich mag MPC ein bisschen besser, das ist
Media Player Classic, aber ich weiß,
die meisten lieben VLC, also habe ich
gesagt, VLC ist ein gutes Beispiel für, wenn sich mal Software durchsetzt wegen der Funktion und nicht wegen der Optik.
Weil man muss halt mal ehrlich sagen,
VLC selber sieht halt
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt richtig
hübsch aus
für das Jahr 2020,
aber die Funktionen machen es halt aus.
Wozu braucht man eigentlich Java?
Sorry, Leute.
Java.
Java braucht man Java.
Nicht Java, Java.
Java.
Was, VLC hat bombe neue
Themes bekommen vor kurzem. Echt jetzt?
Wo? Den muss ich mir gleich angucke.
Wo? Wo geht das?
Hab ich überhaupt ein aktuelles...
Ich hab kein aktuelles VLC.
308, was
ist das aktuelle VLC?
VLC.
Was ist das aktuelle VLC?
311, hoho.
Na, dann muss ich mal updaten.
VLC updaten, exzellent.
Schon die neueste Beta von VLC gesehen, echt hässlich.
Wow, wow, wow. Okay, ich hab lange nicht mal geupdatet.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut, ist ja gut.
So, erstmal VLC updaten.
Oh, VLC still running, okay.
311.
Das ist der Paketmanager, den ich meine, den ich unter Windows verwende.
Das ist aber auch der einzige Paketmanager.
Der taugt, finde ich.
So, VLC.
Okay, 311.
So, also, VLC
Skins.
Das müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren.
Was hat VLCs für Bomben, Skins?
Ist das jetzt neu? Gibt's das nicht schon
ewig?
Sondern ich hübsch, finde ich
die jetzt...
PWA to APK funktioniert?
Ja, Hauptsache, das ist Firefox-based
Chrome-based.
Ja, okay, ich dachte, es gibt jetzt generell
irgendwas Neues.
Dass es VLC-Skins gibt, weiß ich.
Aber die ändern ja grundsätzlich mal an,
dass sich VLC irgendwie oldschool anfühlt.
Nichts.
Dass es wirklich cooler aussieht.
Also, das finde ich jetzt nicht so
wahnsinnig.
Wie sieht dann VLC Beta aus?
Oh, VLC Media Player 4 Beta.
Sieht ja aus wie die Elektronen-Oberfläche, Alter.
Igitt.
Also, dann bevorzuge ich tatsächlich lieber
den oldschool-Look.
Also, das sieht nicht hübsch aus, aber was
ist denn das?
Igitt.
Das...
Das kommt raus.
Das kommt raus, wenn Leute,
wenn Programmierer,
die richtig clever sind,
was
Algorithmen und Funktionen und Sachen angeht,
sich an UI-Design versuchen.
Dann kommt sowas raus.
Okay, das ist die Android-Version.
Na ja,
gucken wir mal weiter hier.
Ich bin stehen geblieben.
Wozu?
Warum überhaupt
nur ein Browser? Man kann einfach alle Browser verwenden.
Ich verwende Chrome, Chromium, Vivaldi.
Ab und zu haben wir sogar noch einen Edge am Start.
Firefox. Dann brauchen wir noch
Opera GX
für RGB-Steuerung.
Nee, aber
Firefox, Chromium
ist eigentlich Default
bei mir.
Ich hab sogar oftmals alle drei Sachen
parallel offen.
Also, ich mach so, ich mach meine
komplette Homeoffice-Geschichten,
mach ich über Chrome.
Kommt drauf, was du machen willst.
Also, ich mach meine ganzen
Homeoffice-Geschichten mach ich nur über Chrome.
Mit dem Browser mach ich
sonst nichts anderes.
So, dann hab ich Chromium für alles andere
und Firefox
für YouTube. Und ein paar andere Sachen,
wenn ich Chrome nicht mag.
Es gibt ja immer noch ein paar Sachen, die besser
im Firefox laufen. Beispielsweise sind die Entwicklertools
finde ich schöner,
die standardmäßigen Entwicklertools
im Firefox schöner als im
Chrome.
Hast du nicht einen dedizierten PC-Notebook
für die Arbeit? Nö.
Ich hab mir einen eigenen Windows-
also, nee, Quatsch.
Ich hab eine Linux-VM,
wenn ich Sachen machen muss und
ansonsten geh ich über einen Browser
drauf.
Oh, jetzt wird's
aber Hacker-Style hier.
Also, wenn ich Random-Scripts
aus dem Internet in der PowerShell
als Admin ausführen muss, dann
da hab ich schon immer so leichte Vorbehalte
dagegen.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch da so geht.
Übrigens,
interaktive PowerShell-
UIs sehen so hässlich aus, ne?
Also,
es gibt ja unter, also viele
Kommandozeilen Sachen, Linux sehen auch nicht
hübsch aus, aber
gerade PowerShell-Scripts, die dann versuchen
solche Progress-Bars zu machen, das sieht
so hässlich aus.
Das sah das unter
Linux mit N-Curses und so
vor 20 Jahren schon besser aus.
Das ist,
er wollte gerade sagen, es ist
super vertrauenserweckend, ey.
Wenn ich sowas hier sage, ey, guck mal,
PowerShell-Admin-Execute,
irgendeine komische Git-Bull, das ist
das Gegenstück zu
sudo-e
weget
pastebin-pipe-bash.
Das war das Gegenstück dazu.
Imp, keine Ahnung.
Also, mir fällt
Windows-Installation immer direkt
irgendwas über,
kann man immer so PXE machen, aber da habe ich
keinen Schimmer vorne, ich habe Windows-Installation
noch nie automatisiert.
Boah.
Ah, das ist schon gut funktioniert.
Wer hat sich bei Microsoft
eigentlich gedacht, es ist eine gute Idee,
die PowerShell-Konsole standardmäßig
blauen Hintergrund zu machen und Fehlermeldungen
dann schwarz auf rot zu machen,
das sieht
ernsthaft aus, wie
in einem
Unix-System von 1985
oder so, es sieht so kacke,
ne, da hat sie keinen farbischen Bildstil,
es sieht so kacke aus.
Was für ein Ding.
O&O Shutup
Free Anti-Spy-Tool
für Linux.
Ah, okay, noch mehr
Random-Software
von irgendwo runterladen und ausführen,
exellent. Also, ich bin
kein Fan von Telemetrie-Funktion in Windows
10, aber ob es jetzt
der weisheitsletzter
Schluss ist,
irgendwelche ungeprüfte
Software aus dem Internet zu laden und auszuführen,
ist fraglich.
Dann würde ich mir lieber gucken, welche Funktion
ich von Hand ausschalten muss,
dass die Telemetrie-Dinger nicht mehr funktionieren
und würde mir das von Hand machen, anstatt
hier anstatt
auszuführen. Aber Hauptsache,
sie sind Microsoft Gold-Partner.
Kennt ihr die ganzen
indischen Scammers?
Die sagen auch immer, sie sind Microsoft Gold-Partner.
This is Peter.
Old Dawn, Old Dawn,
this is Peter.
Microsoft Gold-Partner.
Also, ich kenne das nicht. Es kann durchaus sein,
dass das okay ist, man sich das installieren kann,
aber ich würde es mir vorher mal in Ruhe angucken,
bevor ich es mir installiere.
Weil ich es nicht kenne.
Hätte ich das jetzt schon ein paar Mal installiert
und hätte mir gesagt, okay, das ist in Ordnung,
dann würde ich mir auch nicht jedes Mal neu angucken.
Das ist nicht Sponsor.
Aber warum soll ich das machen?
Warum soll ich das machen?
No, weg.
Braucht man nicht.
Habt ihr die Sicherheitslücke
in Chrome mitgekriegt vor ein paar Tagen?
Richtig Big Brain-Lücke wieder.
Aber so ein Schwachsinn braucht doch kein Mensch.
Es sieht wahrscheinlich genauso aus wie vorher,
nur dass ein paar Sachen deinstalliert wurden.
Hintergrund ist weg.
Aber wozu, wozu?
Was ist ein Schwachsinn?
Ja, geil, okay.
Also ehrlich gesagt,
bevor ich Random Scripts im Internet
in PowerShell Admin pipe,
würde ich mir die paar Settings, die ich brauche,
das wären ja vielleicht 5-10 Sachen sein,
würde ich mir raussuchen, entweder selbst von Hand einstellen
oder selbst irgendwie einen Script bauen.
Gerade unter Windows,
PowerShell Admin,
Pipe, Sudo, Bash,
nee.
Okay, das ist, das ist langweilig.
Post-Depload Processors and Performance, okay.
Doch scheißegal, was da im Hintergrund läuft.
Solange die Dinger keine CPU-Zeit brauchen,
ist ein gestarteter Prozess ein paar Kilobyte RAM,
who cares, ja.
Oder ein paar 100 Megabyte RAM, wenn es Elektron ist, nee.
Aber gestarteter Prozess ist an sich jetzt überhaupt nichts Schlimmes.
Der Schwachsinn braucht kein Mensch.
Übrigens zur Chrome-Sicherheitslücke von vor ein paar Tagen,
die ist eigentlich ganz interessant.
Man weiß leider die Details nicht.
Zumindest solltet ihr gucken, dass ihr mindestens
die Chrome-Version, die hinten 1111 hat oder so, habt.
Also mindestens die Version hier,
mindestens die Version.
Weil die hat eine Sicherheitslücke im Font-Rendering,
was eigentlich ganz witzig ist,
weil die das Gleiche verwenden,
was Linux auch zum Font-Rendern verwendet,
also zum Schrift-Rendern.
Mal gucken, ob das da mittlerweile jetzt mehr Infos...
Hatte Heise da nicht eine ganz, ganz brauchbare Sache
zu...
Ja, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ja.
So, und da haben wir doch auch die Nummer hier da.
Ja, das da ist das.
Das ist die eigentlich interessante Browser-Lücke.
Mal gucken, ob wir dazu jetzt mittlerweile
mehr Informationen haben.
Zumindest anscheinend war das so...
Nee, okay, man weiß noch nichts.
Die halten oftmals die Informationen
zu den Sachen zurück,
bis genug Leute, die Updates installiert haben,
dass nicht die ganzen Möchtigen und Hexer
auf dieser Welt auf die Idee kommen,
das auszunutzen.
Aber gerade diese Sicherheitslücke hier im Chrome,
die war wirklich nicht ohne.
Also freetype ist eine Library,
womit man Schrift rendert.
Also sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Ich glaube unter... Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob es unter Windows auch verwendet wird,
aber wahrscheinlich, weil sonst gibt es kein Problem.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass Chrome freetype gebundelt hat
fürs Font-Rendering und nicht,
dass Windows interne verwenden wird.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Im Detail kenne ich mich da nicht so aus
mit welchen Font-Render-Geschichten, Cross-Plattformen.
Zumindest Linux verwendet es standardmäßig
und Chrome hat es anscheinend auch gebundelt.
Und die Sicherheitslücke war,
wenn PNGs gerendert werden
und wenn PNGs...
Ich weiß nicht, ob Chrome
freetype verwendet, ehrlich gesagt. Keine Ahnung.
Sie werden es zumindest zum Teil freetype verwenden,
weil Windows war auch betroffen davon.
Und unter Windows macht ja eh jeder
ein bisschen was anderes, was Font-Rendering angeht.
Guck dir alte Windows-Apps an,
guck dir WPF-Apps an,
guck dir UWP-Apps an, alles ein bisschen anders.
Ähm...
Nee, das ist egal. Ob du Chrome oder Chromium
verwendest, macht eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied.
Das ist alles unter der Haube das Gleiche.
Ich hab ursprünglich Chromium verwendet,
weil es kein Chromecast unterstützt.
Das war der einzige Grund,
warum ich damals Chromium angefangen hab.
Weil ich nicht ausversehen Sachen streamen wollte
ins Wohnzimmer.
Wenn man sich verklickt.
Man konnte in einem der...
Als Chromecast noch...
Also diese Chromecast-Funktion war
früher ziemlich einfach, sich zu missklicken
bei einem Video.
Das wolle ich nicht.
Der Chat vermutet
schon wieder das Schlimmste hier gleich.
Zumindest, die haben
einen Buffer-Overflow oder sowas gehabt,
wenn sie
PNGs rendern.
Und jetzt könnt ihr euch überlegen,
wie passt das zusammen?
Warum muss eine Library
und ihr kommt bestimmt drauf,
weil ich weiß, wir sind Big Brain Chat.
Es gab heute auch schon ein paar Subs
und wir wissen ja, dass mit jedem Sub
der Durchschnitts-IQ des Chats ansteigt.
Wann muss denn eine Library,
die für Schrift zuständig ist,
PNGs rendern? Habt ihr da eine Idee?
Genau.
Emojis, richtig.
Korrekt, so sieht's aus.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Excellent.
Emojis, und es ging um
PNGs, die embedded
in Schriftarten sind.
Und das wird unter anderem für
Color Emojis verwendet.
Supporting Twitch Prime,
danke schön für den Sub.
Und übrigens, das ist auch ein Thema,
wo ich mich
lange drüber auskotzen könnte.
Es gibt mindestens,
sehr gut,
dass du es fragst,
Extra Mania Gamer.
Es gibt mindestens
vier verschiedene Varianten,
wie farbige Emojis funktionieren.
Es gibt das Format
von Adobe, es gibt das Format
von Microsoft, es gibt das Mozilla-Format
und es gibt wahrscheinlich das Google-Format.
Ich glaube, das sind die vier.
Also sprich,
es gibt vier verschiedene
Ansätze, wie man Color Emojis
machen kann, oder was? Facebook.
Nein, nein, nein, ich meine nicht verschiedene Emoji-Typen.
Ich meine
wirklich Formate, wie das gespeichert wird.
Und ein Format
sind Embedded PNGs.
Deswegen ist ja auch das Problem,
dass
manche Anwendungen, manche Sachen
unter unterschiedlichen Betriebssystemen
unterschiedlich funktionieren, was Color Emojis angeht.
Also es ist nicht so,
gerade Emoji-Support
in Fonts ist eine sehr plattformspezifische
Geschichte.
Und eines der Formate
ist Embedded
PNGs.
Hier, genau,
die da gibt's. Ach nee, Apple war's.
Hier, guck, genau, das, das, das
gibt's. Hier, hier steht's.
Archwiki, eh das Beste.
Genau, also diese verschiedenen
Emoji-
Fonts, also das sind nicht
unterschiedliche Emoji-Fonts.
Also es geht nicht um das Aussehen der Emojis.
Das sind verschiedene Formate,
wie man Informationen
speichern kann, wie Emojis
aussehen. Wie die dann im Endeffekt
die Bilder aussehen. Das ist wieder was anderes.
Das ist die Art und Weise, wie die
Informationen gespeichert werden.
Sondern es gibt dann die Variante
von Google, die Variante von Apple.
Ich glaube, Apple sind Embedded, sind auch
Embedded PNGs. Es gibt die Variante
von Microsoft und von
Mozilla Adobe, das sind SVGs.
Also man sieht schon mal, es ist wieder
unendlich wirr,
wie so ein Color Emoji
auf den Bildschirm kommt.
Die haben natürlich dann auch so
griffige Namen wie
Symbols.
CBDT,
CBLC, alles klar.
Irgendwas davon verwendet
Embedded Emojis, fragt mich nicht.
Und Freetype, Freetype kann
sie halt alle.
Freetype kann sie halt irgendwie alle
und deswegen verwenden wir hier viele Freetype.
Wie gesagt,
so richtig im Detail habe ich mich damit nie beschäftigt.
Und das konnte halt dazu
führen, dass wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
dass wenn du auf eine Webseite gegangen bist,
leider gibt es da noch keine Details zu, wenn du auf eine Webseite
gegangen bist, die eben
manipulierte
Emoji-Geschichten hinterlegt
haben oder so, Emoji-Webfonds
mit Embedded PNGs,
dass es dann einen Buffer-Overflow gegeben hat
in Freetype und du
konntest Sachen auf dem jeweiligen Rechner außerhalb
der Browser-Sandbox ausführen.
Nein, das muss nicht jeder
Browser implementieren, dafür gibt
es ja sowas wie Freetype.
Freetype ist eine Font-Library, die das macht
und der Bug war ja auch nicht
in Chrome, sondern in Freetype.
Allerdings, nachdem Chrome
quasi Freetype mitbringt
in Version XY, ist Chrome
davon auch betroffen. Und gerade Browser
sind von sowas immer besonders
betroffen, weil
der Browser so ziemlich das einzige Programm
ist, was man auf dem Rechner hat, was permanent
Code ausführt, der
unbekannt ist.
Also ein Browser ist ja nichts,
führt ja quasi nie
irgendwas aus,
was ihr programmiert habt. Ein Browser führt
den ganzen Tag unbekannten Code irgendwie
aus und das möglichst sicher.
Deswegen ist es eh erstaunlich und beeindruckend,
wie sicher Browser mittlerweile sind.
Es gibt kaum noch richtige große
Browsersicherheitslücken. Also
schon noch ab und zu so wie hier jetzt, aber
selten und auch nicht mehr in dem Ausmaß,
wie das das früher gegeben hat. Also es ist
das ist auch sowas, wo
die normalen Leute sagen, Alter, es kann doch
nicht so schwierig sein. Warum haben denn Browser immer so
viele Sicherheitslücken? Naja, weil der Browser das
erste ist, was eine
Internetseite trifft
und immer was ausgeführt wird,
was nicht verifiziert ist vorher.
Und also es
ist echt schon beeindruckend, wie sicher Browser
und gerade Chrome und Firefox mittlerweile sind.
Ja,
so und hier gibt es wohl auch
irgendwelche Details, aber das wünsche ich mir jetzt nicht so.
Hier gibt es FreeType
Patches, alles klar, exzellent.
HeapBufferOverflow
Sicherheitslücke, alles klar.
InloadSBitPng,
das ist die Funktion.
Das ist die Funktion und die haben
einen HeapBufferOverflow,
weil sie irgendwelche
Zahlen abschneiden
oder so.
Das will ich mir jetzt nicht so, ach du
große Kacke.
Okay, man kann es auch übertreiben,
also das...
Das müsste ich mir jetzt mal eine Weile angucken,
bis ich das kapiere. Das kann ich nicht so aus dem Ärmel schütteln.
Ja, also
die Sicherheitslücke gibt es in der Funktion
LoadSBitPng.
Wenn PNG-Images
in Embedded-Fonds
verarbeitet werden,
was zum Beispiel bei Emojis passieren kann.
Ja.
Und dann geht es kaputt.
Exzellent.
Ja, das ist
tatsächlich mal eine ziemlich
schwerwiegende Sicherheitslücke gewesen.
Wenn du dir vorstellst, du kannst einfach
irgendeinen manipulierten Webfond oder sonst was
nehmen und dann dort
Code ausführen auf dem Rechner
des
Browser Benutzers,
ist schon kacke.
Deswegen ist es gerade auch besonders, wo
wir wieder... Haben wir nicht letztens ein Video
geguckt? Haben wir nicht letztens ein Video
geguckt, wo irgendein Dude erzählt hat,
er verwendet noch Windows 7,
obwohl es nicht mehr gepatcht wird?
Weil sein Browser ist ja sicher.
Haben wir nicht letzten Sonntag so ein Video
geguckt, wo ich schon gesagt habe, letzten Sonntag
so ein Schwachsinn?
Genau daran sieht man,
dass es wichtig ist, dass sein Betriebssystem
gepatcht ist. Weil wenn sein
Browser mal ein Problem hat, was ja hier jetzt nun
vorkommt, das erste,
was passiert ist, die können Code
ausführen. Im Kontext
hier dieses... Ich weiß
ich, ob es vielleicht sogar noch in der
Sandbox ist, dass nichts passiert, aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen,
nachdem es vontrendet, dass es
außerhalb der Browser Sandbox ist,
rate ich jetzt einfach mal, ich weiß
es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Und
das heißt, du bist erstmal accountgebunden
an diesen Account,
unter dem der Browser läuft. So und diese
Account hat keine Adminberechtigung, aber
hast du jetzt ein ungepatchtes Windows 7,
wo es bekannte
Sicherheitslücken gibt, wie man beispielsweise Adminrechte
bekommen kann, dann ist der nächste Schritt
zu, ich hab dein PC übernommen, ziemlich einfach.
Da muss der Hacker
noch nicht mal richtig krasse Hackerman sein,
sondern in ein paar Monaten gibts da
fertige, fertige
Sachen, die ich auf meinen Webserver
kopieren kann und hab
auf einmal ein russisches Botnetz
am Start, so nach dem Motto.
Das geht immer relativ schnell, wie es da sowas
gibt. Da muss ich noch nicht mal großartig
Hackertyp sein für.
Ich muss einfach nur lang genug warten,
bis das andere für mich erledigt haben.
Und wenn ich da noch genug Leute finde, mit ungepatchtem
Windows, ungepatchtem Browser, dann
hab ich halt Glück.
Und der Pech.
Ja. So sieht es aus.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt?
How does Microsoft make money? Nein, ich will jetzt
irgendwas anderes gucken. Battlefield Top Plays.
Realer Irrsinn, nicht bestellt,
trotzdem geliefert, geliefert von Amazon.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Wenn der Postmann zweimal klingelt
und dann nochmal
und nochmal
und nochmal, dann klingelt er
bei Pascal Pieper
aus Bremen.
Ich bekomme ständig von Amazon
Pakete, die ich weder bestellt
noch bezahlt hab und es geht mir mit.
Ist doch geil. Könnt ihr das bei mir auch machen?
Ich nehm sie. Ich nehm sie alle.
Ich glaube, der Tiere schafft die Nerven.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe, dass sie ihm auch von
Sack geht, aber ich nehm sie. Ich nehm sie alle.
So denn, Pakete kriegen ist doch eine
packende Angelegenheit.
Free stuff, never sub, never
donated, free
entertainment, neighbors Wi-Fi
oder wie auch immer.
Ich habe am Tag bis zu 12
Pakete von drei verschiedenen Paketboten,
die morgens bis abends klingeln.
Das geht schon seit anderthalb Monaten so und irgendwann
ist es auch vorbei. Am Anfang fand
ich es noch witzig, aber mittlerweile ist es einfach
viel zu viel.
Jeder hat sein Päckchen zu tragen.
Und Herr Pieper eben noch ein paar
mehr. Geschickt und
eingefädelt von chinesischen Händlern
aus dem Amazon Marketplace.
Die Chinesen wieder.
Oh Leute, ich hab das böse Wort gesagt.
Jetzt krieg ich wieder
Antworten auf Twitter. Ich bin
ultra rassist, weil ich Chinese gesagt habe.
Hatten wir ja letztens erst.
What? Ernsthaft?
Die können ruhig meine Adresse
willkürlich auswählen. Vollkommen okay.
Die Chinesen sind clever.
Das muss man echt mal sagen.
Die Chinesen sind schon echt
big brain.
Es ist ja echt so, da Kram kostet wahrscheinlich
viel mehr, wenn die das zurückschicken.
Ja, so ein Missgeschickt
kann schon mal passieren.
Dafür darf Herr Pieper
offiziell behalten, was in
seinen Paketen drin ist.
Und hat jetzt einen Haufen
nützlicher Dinge zu Hause.
Das meiste ist wirklich
Rotz. Halloween
Deko, ziemlich viel.
Ein sexy Kimono.
Kinderspielzeug.
Krampfadercreme
für meine Krampfader.
Die brauche ich auch.
Gib die Krampfadercreme.
Katzen, Halsbänder,
mega
rave Handschuhe.
Eine Projektionslampe
für die Decke.
Ein Bugsepper,
mit dem ich Tiere töten kann.
5 von diesen
Babysocken, in dem
man angeblich Babys reinstecken kann.
Amazon bietet zwar die Plattform
für die Händler, kann aber laut eigener
Aussage nur begrenzt in die Geschicke
eingreifen. Warum nehmen
Sie denn noch Pakete an, Herr Pieper?
Ich nehme noch Pakete an, weil mir
der Kundendienst bei
Amazon Prime gesagt hat, dass nur so
Warum nehme ich noch Pakete an, weil es
Free Stuff ist?
Nachvollziehen können, wo die
Leute herkommen, also welcher Händlerprofile
das sind. Gebracht hat
das nichts.
War das ein Fieberthermometer
gerade?
Welcher Händlerprofile
also ich glaube ein chinesisches Fieberthermometer
würde ich nicht verwenden.
Gebracht hat das
nicht.
Das ist echt ein Fieberthermometer, oder?
Elegant.
Das elegante
exquisite.
Also in China
Fieberthermometer muss man den Babys schieben.
Zumindest kein AliExpress
Fieberthermometer.
Ach so, das könnte
Temperaturmesser
für, wenn ich
Braten mache oder so sein. Das könnte auch sein.
Es muss ein Ende haben.
Auf jeden Fall irgendwann.
Es ist voll hier.
Big Brain
Hochkant Computerbildschirm.
Hauptsache
viel...
Fuck.
Der hat einen Bildschirm hochkant, dass er alle Emojis
anzeigen kann. Das ist mal was.
Big Brain
Das ist eine coole Sache ey.
Wenn man den ganzen Tag am chatten ist, ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Was ist denn das?
Erkennt das jemand, was das ist?
Was ist das für ein Chat?
Ist das Skype?
Was ist das? Telegram?
WhatsApp? Nee Telegram.
Telegram. Chat. Ja okay
als Chat kennt sich aus. Telegram
ist das. Telegram und erstmal davon
30% für Emojis. So
muss man es machen. Wir können nur hoffen, dass
der aktuelle Chrome Version hat.
Ja ordentlich
Bench Power Supply und
sonst was. Alle möglichen Sachen.
In der Wendler Gruppe.
Genau was sonst.
Jeder so ein Sendungsbewusstsein
wie sie.
Sie haben Post.
Ist doch nice.
Also ich würde es sofort
nehmen. Und wisst ihr was ich machen würde,
wenn ich das bekommen würde?
Ich würde mir so einen Paketsack
oder zwei Paketsäcke
ans Hoftor machen. Und ein
Schild dran, dass die alle ihre
Sachen in den Paketsack schmeißen sollen.
Das würde ich dann im Stream auspacken und testen.
Weiß ich nicht. Aber es gibt so einen Paketsack.
Paketsack.
Mein Paketsack
für.de alles klar.
Da passt doch gar nichts rein.
Und außerdem
Wie funktioniert denn das?
Das ist doch viel zu klein.
Da passt doch nichts rein.
Mein Paketsack. Okay, das müssen wir uns
jetzt mal angucken.
Ach so.
Ach so. Funktioniert
das.
Aha.
Das kapiert
mein Zusteller nicht.
Die sind meistens
schnittfest, die Dinger.
Also das kapiert der Amazon-Zusteller schon mal nicht.
Die Amazon-Zusteller
sind eh
nicht unbedingt die
mit dem größten Brain.
Die Sprecher klingen immer so
super hyped und glücklich.
Aber gut, würde ich auch machen.
Warum soll ich da einen hinsetzen,
der sagt, jetzt bekomme ich
schon wieder Pakete, was mache ich mit dem Kack.
Dann ist so ein Sprecher schon besser.
Das kapiert er nicht.
Also
wenn ich da gerade an die
Amazon-Zusteller, das kapieren die nicht.
Ich meine, die Amazon-Zusteller bei mir,
die können ja auch jetzt wenig
für. Das sind jetzt nicht
die solch hochqualifizierten
und das sind halt die, die billig sind.
Und die, die eh keine Zeit haben,
was zu machen. Weil die Sache ist die,
Amazon macht es ja nicht direkt.
Amazon hat irgendeinen Subunternehmer, der einen
Subunternehmer hat und der fährt in ein Auto
mit einem Amazon-Aufkleber drauf.
Und die haben keine Zeit und keinen Bock.
Das kann ich verstehen. Allerdings, ich habe
jetzt schon ein paar Mal probiert,
zu kommunizieren mit dem
Amazon-Paket-Lieferer.
Und ich hatte erst einen dabei,
mit dem ich mich auf
so einem Zwischending auf Deutsch und Englisch
unterhalten konnte. Also das
funktioniert schlecht und deswegen glaube ich
nicht, dass sowas hier mit denen funktioniert.
Das macht der im Leben nicht. Im Leben
nicht macht der das.
Das niemals.
Nie. Nie macht der das.
Nie.
Also den DHL-Mann,
der immer
der gleiche ist,
dem kann ich das vielleicht
noch erklären.
Aber
den 50 verschiedenen Amazon-Zustellern
kann ich das nicht erklären.
Also Amazon macht das ohne
Unterschrift bei mir.
Dem DHL-Mann könnte ich es noch erklären.
Das sind immer die gleichen 4, 5.
Aber bei Amazon gibt es so random
Pool aus 50 Fahrern oder so.
Und gerade, dass du das
aufmachen musst und dann wieder zumachen.
Und außerdem, wie ist das?
Ach so, guck mal, du brauchst sogar noch
ein Schloss dafür.
Im Leben nicht.
Das klappt nicht.
Leute, das klappt nicht.
Im Leben nicht.
Das klappt nie.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Aber das scheitert da dran,
dass die Pakete, die machen nicht mit.
Übrigens,
das ist ein super sicheres Ding hier oben.
Niemals, nie.
Okay, okay, okay.
Bitte alle Pakete in meinen
Paket-Sack ablegen.
Das sagt der Amazon-Lieferant.
Nee, ich nehme es einfach wieder mit.
Oder ich schmeiße es über das Tor.
Das macht Amazon bei uns auch ganz gerne.
Please put all my packages
in my parcel-bag.
Dann kommt es in Französisch,
dann kommt es in
Türkisch,
oder?
Dann in Polnisch,
oder sowas.
Und das da unten, was ist das?
In Italienisch.
Und dann noch in Arabisch.
Oh ja, unbedingt.
Na gut, so ist das.
Es orientiert sich halt an dem,
was verbreitet ist.
Ich vermute mal,
dass das Arabisch unten drunter ist.
Nele, genau.
Was geht das?
Was geht das meine Nachbarn an?
Ob ich da ein Paket-Sack an meiner Tür habe?
Das klappt nicht.
Wer hätte auch nur denken können,
dass man sich die unterschiedlichen Varianten
von mein Paket-Sack
auf meinpaket-sack.de anschauen kann?
Das klappt nicht.
Nie klappt das.
Okay, also zeigt mal her,
Sicherheit, Security.
Das klappt nicht.
Okay, also zeigt mal her,
Sicherheit, Security gibt es hier.
Wie ist das hier?
Alle Pakete sicher verwahrt.
Die Safe von meinem Paket
ist auch sicher vor Öffnungsversuchen
mit Messern.
Okay, kostet.
Kostet, Online Shop.
Wäre, wäre, okay.
Ich meine, das ist ganz schön teuer
für einen Sack, aber für einen Sack
mit einem Schloss, den du wahrscheinlich
in zwei Sekunden offen hast.
Aber die machen
das scheitern an den Zustellern bei uns.
Also wie gesagt,
meinem DHL-Zusteller kann ich das erklären.
Aber spätestens bei
bei Hermes auch noch, das sind auch meistens
die gleichen, aber spätestens sollte mal doch
was von DPD kommen oder von GLS
oder von Amazon ins Amt schnipsen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
die schmeißen das auch ein und schreiben...
Also ich hab's schon geschafft bei Amazon,
dass die das zugestellt haben.
Und dann stand, also ich hab's
geschafft, ich war einfach nicht da.
Und dann stand dann bei Amazon drin,
zugestellt an Briefkasten.
DHL hat eine eigene Box, ja, die Telekom
hatte auch mal eine eigene Paketbox.
Das Problem ist nur, dann bräuchtest du
ja wieder fünf verschiedene Paketsäcke
von unterschiedlichen Anbietern.
Also das Sinnvollste ist so was hier,
was für alle gilt.
Aber das scheitert daran, dass das die...
Ich hab echt riesen Zweifel,
dass da die meisten
Paketzusteller mitmachen.
Amazon Paketzack, haben die auch so was?
Hat Amazon auch so was?
Amazon hat Paketstation, ja.
Das weiß ich.
Amazon Locker.
Ja, da muss ich mal schauen.
Also vielleicht gibt's, vielleicht ist das
echt ne Option, die Sachen an die
Pakestation liefern zu lassen.
Na ja gut, schauen wir mal weiter.
Was haben wir sonst noch schönes hier?
Wir können hier nur Battlefield Top Plays gucken.
Was haben wir geguckt? 25 Home Automation Ideas.
Das letzte Mal
haben wir Teil 1 geguckt.
Das war eigentlich ein ziemlich gutes Video.
Haben wir das letzte Mal 25?
Oder?
Das letzte Mal schon geguckt?
Oder haben wir das letzte Mal
Teil 1 geguckt?
Ich bin mir da jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher.
Wo ist Part 1?
Volume 1.
Ich glaub wir haben Volume 1 geguckt.
Genau, das haben wir das letzte Mal geguckt.
Dann gucken wir jetzt Teil 2.
Das ist auch so ein Chandlin, den habe ich
erst in letzter Zeit entdeckt.
Der hat wirklich ganz gute Ideen, was
Home Automatisierung angeht.
Und auch ganz gute Tests, was
Lampen und so was angeht.
Die anderen Sachen sind ein bisschen
ziemlich Kokona bezogen.
Weil bei den Amis kannst du halt
Schalter in die Wand sägen und so was.
Das funktioniert hier halt nicht wirklich.
Also wenn ihr euch beispielsweise mal
diese Schalter anguckt,
das funktioniert
bei uns nicht.
Das ist so einfach
die typische Kokona Wand hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
What the fuck?
Also das funktioniert
halt bei meiner Wand hier nicht.
Im Freedom Land
funktioniert das.
Es ist 11.53 Uhr.
Guckt, das sind alles so Kokona-Switches.
Das funktioniert bei uns nicht.
Wenn ihr euch das schon anguckt,
das kannst du im Leben nicht bei uns einbauen.
Also das kannst du vergessen.
Das ist halt Kokona-Technologie.
Aber
die anderen Sachen, die wir hier
schon mal geguckt haben,
die wir hier schon mal geguckt haben,
aber die anderen Sachen,
die wir hier getestet haben,
sind echt ganz interessant.
Zum Beispiel auch die Smart Bulbs,
also die RGB Lampen und
dimmbaren Lampen und so.
Ich habe mir beispielsweise jetzt zwei
zwei Lampen gekauft.
RGB Lampen.
Weil ich sie bei ihm im Video gesehen habe.
Und ich habe ja
in den letzten Streams immer wieder gesagt,
ich habe kaum Automatisierung gemacht,
geht. Ich bin gerade dabei ein bisschen zu experimentieren was man so machen
könnte.
So, schauen wir mal.
In this video I'll show you 25 automation ideas as I go throughout my day.
Sagt ob es laut genug ist.
I have a wide range of automation ideas that you can use for inspiration in your home.
Ok, Amazon Smart Assistance die alles aufzeichnen stelle ich mir nicht hin.
All the details about how I set these up are written in an article linked below and I'll
be going to more depth on these automations in future videos so make sure to subscribe.
Übrigens was wir letzte Woche erfahren haben ist die Telekom, falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet,
die Telekom hat auch einen Smart Assistant Speaker also sowas wie Alexa und Echo Dot
und sowas bei Amazon. Das nennt sich Magenta, ich glaube Magenta Speaker sogar und wisst
ihr was man sagen muss um das anzusteuern? Man sagt bei Amazon ist Alexa, bei anderen
ist Siri und Google. Man muss bei der Telekom sagen Hey Magenta! Das ist schon so Cringe
und Fremdschämen, das würde ich im Leben nicht verwenden.
Das ist Ebaro, das stimmt aber. Das ist wirklich Hey Magenta.
Bevor wir das gucken, gibt es noch längere Fragen im Chat, also mein Bruder und ich machen
gerade einen Game Server, wahrscheinlich Minecraft oder sowas, so der Klassiker für viele Leute
sich selbst hosten. Also brauchen wir einen MySQL Server und einen Web Server mit PHP
um SQL Abfragen zu machen. Ich habe als Web Server Nginx genommen, Nginx ist top, kann
man nichts mit falsch machen, aber je nachdem was ihr machen wollt, kann man es auch viel
einfacher haben. Was sagst du zu Nginx? Zweite Frage, wartet mal kurz, juckt's am Ohr, das
Headset kurz abziehen, so. Zweite Frage, wenn ich vor dem Game Server und Web Server ein
Reverse Proxy Firewall hängen will, was soll ich da nehmen? PF Sense? Ne, weder noch. Also
ich würde einfach die eingebaute Ubuntu Firewall nehmen, ufw, einfach ufw, allow ssh, ufw enable
und ufw default deny und dann kann eh nichts mehr drauf zugreifen von außen auf den Server.
Es sei denn, du machst irgendwelche Docker Geschichten, dann muss man ein bisschen genauer
gucken, weil das geht an ufw vorbei, dann muss man ein paar Sachen einfügen, dass das
funktioniert. Also ich würde erstmal ufw einschalten, so wie ich das im vorletzten Stream oder
so gemacht hab, erstmal ufw einschalten und damit ist der ganze Firewall Aspekt schon
mal außen vor, da brauchst du keinen PF Sense davor oder sowas, das ist totaler Overkill.
Dann würde ich generell vor die ganze Geschichte einen Reverse Proxy stellen, der einmal lets
encrypt SSL Zertifikate für mich macht und der vor alles irgendwie einen Basic Auth oder
sowas macht, dass nicht random Sachen im Internet hängen, die man da nicht hängen haben will.
So und da kannst du auch den nginx für verwenden, du kannst, ich persönlich mag den hier am
liebsten, der ist schön einfach, 5 Zeilen Eintrag und es funktioniert. Aber wie gesagt
mit nginx und so kann man eigentlich wenig verkehrt machen. Die Sache ist nur die, also
die Frage ist, muss es PHP sein, wenn du eh einen Hetzner Server hast, also es sei denn
ihr habt was, was in PHP programmiert ist, ansonsten kannst du auch etwas anderes nehmen
und nachdem ihr eh schon einen Reverse Proxy davor habt, brauchst du auch nicht noch einen
extra Web Server, sondern kannst eigentlich, zum Beispiel wenn du jetzt ein.NET Programm
machen würdest, dann kannst du einfach.NET starten und deinen Reverse Proxy auf den internen
.NET Web Server loadbalancen lassen, ohne dass du einen extra Web Server brauchst. PHP hat
bestimmt auch einen eingebauten Web Server, Python hat bestimmt auch einen eingebauten
Web Server, dann brauchst du nicht noch einen nginx dazwischen, wobei ich keine Ahnung hab,
wie es mit PHP ist. Genau. Also wenn es irgendeine Game Engine gibt, die keine SQL Abfragen
machen kann, dann frag ich mich, was das für ein Kram ist, weil im Zweifel gibt es doch
sicherlich irgendwelche Schnittstellen, dass man das machen, naja gut. Achso, what? Ihr
baut ein eigenes Game, was dort im Backend läuft? Ach, jetzt versteh ich's, jetzt versteh
ich's, ah ne ne ne, das würd ich anders machen. Also, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab,
ist, ihr verwendet irgendeine Programmiersprache, sagen wir jetzt mal, und diese Game Engine
hier, und ihr wollt SQL Abfragen machen, und weil ihr quasi nicht wisst, wie man aus
dieser Game Engine, was ist denn das C, C++, C Sharp, was ist das, Go, keine Ahnung, wie
man da SQL Abfragen macht, wollt ihr Webrequests machen, und die Webrequests sollen euch Sachen
aus einer Datenbank zurückliefern. Das würd ich ganz anders machen, das ist eine ziemliche
Krücke, das würd ich nicht machen. Also, wenn man's relativ easy machen will, ohne
Web-Server, nimmst du ein Postgres mit GraphQL davor. So, das ist die eine Geschichte, das
ist dann quasi eine Datenbank, die direkt schon eine Web-Schnittstelle hat, wo ich abfragen
kann. Das ist die eine, wenn ich wirklich über den Umweg von Web-Geschichten gehen will,
dann würd ich ein Postgres mit GraphQL davor nehmen. Das ist out of the box, ein fertiges
Ding, und funktioniert. Aber, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es nicht möglich ist,
aus einer Game Engine, oder irgendwie hier Abfragen zu machen, gegenüber einer Datenbank,
weil die läuft ja mit irgendwas. Es gibt zig C++-Libraries, Go-Libraries, was auch immer,
für Datenbankzugriff. Das würd mich sehr wundern, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Und
wenn ihr wirklich Webrequests machen müsst, dann würd ich, wie gesagt, nicht über den
Umweg von PHP-Script, was in die Datenbank geht, nehmen, sondern irgendwas wie zum Beispiel
Postgres und GraphQL zusammen. Wie heißt denn das? Postgres, Graph-Elephant, oder so?
War das das? Nee. Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt. Ich kann's jetzt nicht... Also Postgres
ist so mit die meist, nee, bei MySQL, mit die meistverbreiteten Datenbanken, die es
gibt. Und ich hab letztens was Schönes gesehen, das war ein GraphQL-Frontend für Postgres.
Und ich bin... War das das hier sogar? Ich müsste mir das noch immer im Detail angucken.
Ich hab's noch nie verwendet, aber ich hab's letztens gesehen, hab mir gedacht, ey, das
ist ein richtig cooles Projekt, wenn man's verbraucht. GraphQL ist quasi so ein bisschen,
ähm, SQL-Lite, ohne so richtig SQL zu sein, über HTTP. Und deswegen bietet sich das an,
wenn man das denn über den Umweg von irgendeiner Web-Schnittstelle machen will, das mit GraphQL
zu machen. Da wirst du doch mal genauer gucken. Ich find, irgendwas mit Elephant hieß das
doch, oder? War das nicht Elephant? Also das ist das Logo von denen. War das das da? Nee,
das war irgendein Anbieter. Ich bilde mir ein, das hieß, dieses GraphQL-Frontend hieß
irgendwie so. Müssen wir mal nachgucken, ich kann's euch ehrlich gesagt grad nicht sagen.
Aber ich würd's sehr wundern, wenn man, wenn man nicht direkt Abfragen machen kann gegenüber
einer Datenbank. Nein, nein, nein. GraphQL ist eine webbasierte Abfragesprache. Du kannst
das ohne Probleme gegen jede x-beliebige Datenbank machen, wenn du einen Adapter hast. Also du
kannst das gegen SQL-Lite machen, gegen SQL bestimmt auch, gegen Postgres. Aber Postgres
ist ganz schön, hab ich zumindest letztens was drüber gelesen, dass du quasi so, das
mehr oder weniger so out of the box fertig konfiguriert kriegst, dass du Postgres mit
GraphQL mit ein paar, mit drei, vier Schritten quasi starten kannst und es funktioniert.
Theoretisch auch gegen Excel, wenn du was programmierst, was das übersetzt, ja. Das,
das geht auch. Das muss man sich auch mal im Detail angucken, das hab ich so noch nicht
gemacht. Wär vielleicht, wär vielleicht auch mal was. Ähm, sind wir denn stehengeblieben?
Ah, hier. Das ist, das ist doch echt overkill, oder? Ich mein, das erste finde ich cool,
das erste finde ich cool, wenn er aufwacht, dass dann quasi Sonnenaufgang simuliert wird.
Es gäbe natürlich auch noch die Möglichkeit, den echten Sonnenaufgang durch das Fenster
reinzulassen, aber das wär glaube ich zu oldschool. Also ich mein, wenn man die Auswahl
hat zwischen echtem Sonnenaufgang und RGB-Sonnenaufgang, was nimmt man dann? Chat, also ich bin eindeutig
für RGB-Sonnenaufgang. Wer braucht echten Sonnenaufgang? Und außerdem ist zu der Zeit,
wo du aufstehst natürlich nicht unbedingt der rechte Sonnenaufgang, ja das stimmt. Das
ist eine coole Idee, das ist eine coole Idee. Sowas hab ich mir auch überlegt, ob ich das
nicht machen soll. Ich hab mir gesagt, ich hab mir zwei RGB-Lämpchen gekauft, das hab
ich mir auch wirklich überlegt, ob ich das nicht machen soll, sowas. Wisst ihr was natürlich
richtig big brain wäre, Choose My Name? Genau. Was richtig poggers wäre, man müsste einfach
ne Automation machen, die quasi checkt, also die über ne Web API abruft, wann Sonnenaufgang
ist, wenn Sonnenaufgang ist, 15 Minuten vorher, bei der Outdoor-Kamera, den Sonnenaufgang
recordet und wenn du dann aufstehst, spielt es dir den echten Sonnenaufgang vor deiner
Haustür um 11 Uhr auf deinem Display neben dem Bett ab. Das wär doch mal was. Das ist
aber Next Level Big Brain Automation. Wer braucht RGB-Sonnenaufgaben, wenn er echten
Sonnenaufgang recordet haben kann auf seinem Display? Und dann dazu noch RGB machen. Und
wenns bewölkt ist, ja dann ist halt der echte Sonnenaufgang nochmal bewölkt. Übrigens
mir ist gerade noch was eingefallen zu dieser Game Engine-Geschichte, die kein SQL kann.
Das ist doch vollkommen egal, ob das sicher oder unsicher ist. Das ist alles lokal auf
eurem Server drauf. Von außen kommt da doch eh keiner dran. Ich würd das ganze Ding nicht
mal mit Passwörtern schützen. Wozu? Du speicherst in deiner Datenbank ja eh nur Sachen von und
aus. Dein Game-State in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Also quasi das, was du normalerweise
im RAM hast, was du persistent speichern willst. Das heißt, wozu irgendwelche Passwort-Ontentifizierungen,
wenns rein lokal ist. Würd ich wahrscheinlich eh komplett weglassen. Also je nachdem. Vielleicht
hab ichs auch noch gar nicht richtig kapiert. Mir ist aber noch was dazu eingefallen. Es
kann doch jede x-beliebige Programmiersprache C-Funktionen aufrufen. Oder? Außer Go, die
das nur sich umwegen können. Aber sonst kannst du zumindest von jeder x-beliebigen Programmiersprache
externe C-Funktionen, FFI, genau, aufrufen. Warum macht ihr nicht einfach ne Mini-C-Library
oder ne C++-Library, meinetwegen, wenns ein muss, oder ne Go-Library oder irgendwas, was
euch die passenden Funktionen als C-kompatible Sachen exportiert, und die ruft ihr auf aus
eurer Game Engine. Das muss gehen. Du musst FFI, also du musst irgendwelche C-Funktionen
callen können. Also mir fällt quasi keine Programmiersprache, jetzt mal brainfuck außen
vor ein, die keine C-Funktionen callen kann. Übrigens, Go kann das nicht, weil Go das
um 5 Umwege macht, um es zu können. Also Go kann es aber nicht direkt. Also wie gesagt,
Leku, du müsstest das dann gar nicht einbauen und neu kompilieren. Du kannst bestimmt, wie
heißt das Ding? What the fuck? Irgendwie sowas hier. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist, ich
kenn mich damit null aus, aber du musst daraus externe Funktionen aufrufen können. Was ist
denn das sonst für ne Game Engine? Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es irgendeine
runtime, was auch immer gibt, die nicht externe C-Funktionen aufrufen kann. Das ist so die
Basics der Basics eigentlich. Was ja auch wichtig ist, weil sonst kannst du ja mit nix
anderem interagieren. Das kannst du aus Python machen, aus Hubi, wahrscheinlich sogar aus
Brainfuck mittlerweile. Aber die einfachste Sache, wenn das alles nicht geht und du wirklich
das über Webrequests machen musst, was übrigens übelst lahm ist, ne? Ja, also das mit PHP
finde ich auch übelst übelst der Hack, das würde ich nicht machen. Also man muss ja
auch sagen, Webrequests sind ultra langsam. Ich mein, wenn du dir überlegst, so ein Function
soll, dauert ein paar Nanosekunden. So ein Webrequest dauert, was weiß ich, mit allem
drum und dran vielleicht mal 1-2 Millisekunden. Das ist auch ein riesen Overhead, den man
sich damit einfängt. Aber ich kann dazu leider nicht wirklich viel sagen, weil ich habe
weder diese Engine noch bisher verwendet, noch weiß ich, was das für Restriktionen hat,
noch hab ich das Problem so hundertprozentig erfasst. Aber das mit Webrequests über den
SAP-Skript in die Datenbank hört sich eklig an. Oh, das will ich übrigens, das will ich
mir auch noch machen, sowas hier. Das ist richtig Big Brain, was der hier jetzt treibt.
Also ich finde, die Motivationsrede am Anfang auf einem Display ist bescheuer, das braucht
kein Mensch. Das ist cool. Das hier ist total overkill. Ich brauche kein motivational YouTube
morgens, wenn ich aufstehe. Ich brauche kein, der auf meinem Tablet morgens mir ins Ohr
schreit, schreit, do it, just do it. Das muss echt nicht sein. Die sollen alle ihre
Klappe halten. Äh, nee, das muss, das muss nicht sein. Das nächste, was er hier hat,
finde ich eigentlich ganz cool. Also das nächste ist cool. Das hier, sowas will ich mir unbedingt
auch noch unter das Bett bauen. Ich habe es mal mit einem Gewichtssensor probiert, aber
das funktioniert nicht so genau. Das ist so eine Matte, die erkennt, wenn Druck drauf
ist. Und damit kann man super Automations auslösen. Zum Beispiel könnte man einen Schalter einbauen,
quasi, es ist nach 22 Uhr und das Bett ist belegt länger als 15 Minuten. Wenn ich jetzt
noch vergessen habe, irgendwo was auszuschalten, schaltet er automatisch aus, weil ich bin
im Bett. Also sowas will ich unbedingt auch noch einbauen. Mal gucken, ob der, mal gucken,
ob der die Matte verlinkt hat. Hat er die Matte verlinkt? Ja. Bett, was, oh. Ich habe
Bett Pleasure Sensor gelesen, habe ich schon gehört. What the fuck. Wow. Seid ihr noch
bei Sinnen? Warum ist der Scheiß so teuer? Da, ist es ja nicht euer Ernst, oder? Alles
so. Ich weiß ja nicht, ich weiß ja nicht, wie das bei dir aussieht, ob du 15 Minuten
still auf der Matte legst, ohne dich zu bewegen. Aber wenn ja und es nach 22 Uhr ist, dann
geht der Geschirrspüler aus. Das ist dann tatsächlich ein Problem. So, äh, warte mal,
wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Ich wollte diese, ich wollte diese, mal gucken, was die
Matte kostet. Du kannst ja auch, du kannst ja auch einen Bewegungssensor noch installieren,
der dann erkennt, wenn da, äh, wenn es da gerade zur Sache geht, dann kannst du das
ausschalten. So was kostet denn sowas? Gibt es das in Deutschland? Wow. Warum Nokia? Das
hat doch mit Nokia nichts, nichts zu tun. Okay, das ist definitiv zu teuer. Außerdem,
das hier ist IT-Informatiker-Stream, das Problem haben die meisten Leute hier natürlich gar
nicht. Wenn die im Bett liegen, dann liegen die einfach im Bett, um zu schlafen. Paper
Hands. Ne, ähm, das ist ganz schön teuer. True, Setge. Ähm, das ist ganz schön teuer.
Sleep-Sensor-Bett oder so. Das gibt es doch garantiert billiger. Warum ist das so teuer?
Das ist einfach nur ein langgezogener Drucksensor. Das ist einfach nur ein langgezogener Drucks-
Warum ist das so teuer? What the fuck? Ich glaub, ich glaub doch kein 120 Euro für
einen publischen Drucksensor aus. Äh, nein. Körperwaage. Da hab ich da, äh, also übrigens
die Waage, die wir mal zusammen im Stream eingerichtet haben, die mit Bluetooth, also
diese, die, die über Bluetooth, äh, Bluetooth, die, die Sache. Die funktioniert seit einem
halben Jahr oder so ziemlich gut. Blood Pressure Monitor. Die wollen es jetzt aber echt wissen.
Das ist, das ist unglaublich teuer. Oh, guck mal, es ist 3 Euro reduziert. Poggers, gleich
wieder. Hat das, hat das Home Assistant, äh, Integration? Hat das Home Assistant Integration?
Scheint. Moment, Moment, Moment, was? Ich brauch nen Account, ich brauch nen, ich brauch
nen Account bei den Chinesen irgendwo oder was? Dass ich, dass das Ding erkennt, ob ich
im Bett bin? The fuck? Nee, das nehm ich nicht. Ach nee, okay, braucht man nicht, braucht
man nicht. Das ist Nokia. Es sind alles Chinesen mittlerweile. Alles, alles hängt da irgendwie
zusammen und die, wahrscheinlich läuft das in der Alibaba Cloud oder so. Okay, es geht,
es geht auch. Warum brauch ich irgendwelche Callbacks? Das ist nen, what the fuck? Das
ist nen Sensor im W-Lan oder so, der einfach funktionieren soll. Nee, auf Twitter darf
ich das gar keinen Fall sagen. Einfach nen Drucksensor, genau. Ich brauch kein Online-Account.
Das muss ich mir mal im Detail angucken. So, schauen wir mal weiter. Was macht den hier?
Also so ein Ding, das steht bei mir auch auf jeden Fall noch auf dem Plan, dass, äh, da
bin ich die ganze Zeit schon so am Gucken, nen Drucksensor für den, äh, fürs Bett.
Und was cool ist, dass sogar das Gewicht noch, noch erkennt, wobei das Gewicht nicht wirklich
aussagekräftig ist, wenn man so verteilt drauf legt. Aber zumindest kann ich den Unterschied
erkennen, ob ich drauf leg oder die Katz grad im Bett rumhüpft, weil das wird das Ding
kaum merken. Hab ich, hab ich absichtlich nicht gemacht? Also ich hab mir auch schon
überlegt, ob ich nicht vielleicht meine, äh, ich hab ja Tablets oben und unten im Flur
hängen, ob ich die nicht auch morgens irgendwas vorlesen lassen soll, also zum Beispiel Wetter
oder nächsten Termin oder sowas. Aber warum ich's nicht gemacht hab, ist, weil ich weiß,
ich erschreck mich des Todes, wenn ich durch den Flur laufe und an nichts, an nichts denke
und auf einmal kommt ne Stimme von meinem Tablet. Ich krieg nen halben Herzinfarkt. Und, äh,
deswegen hab ich das nicht gemacht. Okay, da bin ich grad dabei. Das hab ich, das hab
ich grad, weil ich bin ja grad, hab ja grad angefangen mit, äh, Zigbee Thermostaten
an der Heizung. Und Fenstersensor hab ich ja schon, also das, das, das funktioniert,
im Wohnzimmer funktioniert das schon, dass wenn ich das Fenster aufmache, dass dann die
Heizung ausgeht. Oh, das ist cool. Oh, das ist coole Idee. Das, das ist, das ist ne coole
Idee, das gefällt mir. Das ist ne coole Idee. Dazu muss man aber erstmal nen Workout machen.
Das ist ne coole Idee, das gefällt mir echt. Welche Sensoren hast du? Äh, ich hab, äh,
SeaWave, äh, Moment. Ich zeig dir, ich hab, äh, SeaWave, alter AliExpress, geh weg. Window,
ihr bestes Leben, alles klar. Äh, so. Äh, weder noch, wo sind die überhaupt alle hin?
Im irgendwie Coolcam oder so hießen die Dinger. Hab ich mir mal bestellt, die Dinger hab ich,
aber wie gesagt, nicht kaufen, einfach so. Ich hab die bestellt, als es die, als es
die mal für 10 Dollar bei Banggood gab. Das Stück. 10 Dollar, das Stück konnte man machen,
ansonsten viel zu teuer. Da hab ich gleich, äh, etwas größere Bestellung getätigt.
Das ist, das ist tatsächlich ganz cool, dass es dir die, äh, Termine vorliest. Okay,
das brauch ich nicht. Äh, du wirst keine SeaWave Window Door Sensors finden, die 5
Euro kosten. Und wenn, dann würdest du dich mal interessieren, welches. Ach so, 5 für
50. Äh, das ist okay. Zeig mal. Das, das ist okay. Das ist, das ist in Ord, das ist,
das ist in Ord, das ist ein guter Preis. 5 für 50 ist okay. 10 Euro pro Door Sensor
kann man ausgeben. Natürlich wärs besser, wenn, wenn es noch günstiger wäre, aber ja.
Das, der Preis ist okay. Scheint auch gerade ziemlich im Angebot zu sein. Das kann man,
das kann man sich gönnen. Was kostet denn der Versand? Sagen wir mal, nehmen wir mal
3 Stück, dann haben wir 15 Stück, das reicht, würde reichen. Kostet Versand was? Kostenloser
Versand auch noch. Ja, wenn man, wenn man ZigBee hat und ZigBee Ähm, Aquara Sensors
verwenden kann, ist es okay. Das ist tatsächlich ein ganz guter Deal, ja. Aber ich hatte damals
nur SeaWave. Wenn man ZigBee hat, kann man das auch damit machen. Man darf aber nicht
vergessen, ZigBee ist auf der gleichen Frequenz oder ähnliche Frequenz wie WLAN SeaWave
nicht. Also deswegen finde ich SeaWave auch an sich die nettere Technologie, aber gerade
was Thermostate angeht oder so, gibt es halt nur Müll. Das ist tatsächlich recht günstig.
Also hätte ich nicht schon, hätte ich nicht schon ähm, meine Fenster und so damit ausgestattet,
ich würde mir das wahrscheinlich kaufen. 50 Euro für 5 Stück, inklusive kostenlosen
Versand, ist nicht schlecht. Gut, es ist AliExpress, man wartet einen Monat drauf, aber scheiß
drauf, ja. Zwei kaufen, 1% bekommen, exzellent. Achso, man muss das anklicken, ne. Guck mal,
man kriegt sogar noch, man kriegt sogar noch 1% Guck mal, man hat, man bekommt sogar noch
2%, das ist echt okay. Keine 150 Euro, 15 Stück und ähm, kein Versandkosten, das ist
echt nicht übel. Schick mal bitte Link hier. Moin Twinkor. Ja, das ist gut hier, also wenn
ich nicht schon welche hätte, würde ich mir die wahrscheinlich holen, aber wie gesagt,
das lohnt sich nur, wenn man eh schon Z-Wave Sachen daheim hat. Also wenn man keine Z-Wave,
wenn man kein Z-Wave, das ist kein WLAN. Also Achtung, ne. Also wenn man das jetzt irgendwie
über WLAN betrachtet, oh ich, Moment, ja, es ist Z-Welle Plus, ja, alles klar. Ach
Moment, Warenkorb Link, äh. Und ich hab das falsche geschickt, mein Warenkorb Link bringt
hier wohl nicht allzu viel, denke ich mal. Ja. Ah, ist der, ist der. Der Link dazu. Um
die Leute nicht zu verwirren, ich lösche mal mein, kann ich meine eigene, ey ich kann
meine eigene Nachricht gar nicht löschen, oder? Lul. Ich wollte gerade meine Nachricht
löschen, das geht nicht. Dass ich die Leute nicht verwirre mit Warenkorb Link, aber gut.
Ich kann auch meine eigene Message nicht löschen, das ist ja witzig. Wie, mal angenommen, ich
hätte jetzt Mist im Chat geschrieben, wo ich nicht will, dass es jemand sieht. Wie krieg
ich meine eigene Message wieder weg? Das ist tatsächlich immer eine interessante Frage.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Mich selbst bannen, genau. Tja, interessant. Keine Ahnung, wie ich meine
eigene Message löschen kann. Ist ja auch nicht wild, ist ja nichts Schlimmes, aber
trotzdem interessant, dass ich nicht, dass ich nicht meine eigene Message leeren kann.
Ja. Und wie gesagt, das ist, das ist aber halt rein, rein Sea-Wave. Das heißt, wenn
man keinen Sea-Wave aktuell im Einsatz hat, dann würde ich das nicht empfehlen. Wenn
ihr Zigbee habt, dann könnt ihr die Aquarador Windows Sensors verwenden, die sind ja noch
ein bisschen günstiger. Die sind sogar noch ein ticken günstiger. Wenn ich sie aus Russland
bestelle, bekommen wir das am Start. Also wenn ihr Zigbee habt, dann würde ich sowas
hier nehmen. Und über WLAN gibt es nichts Gescheites. Und Sea-Wave ist wie Zigbee.
Es ist ähnlich, es ist ähnlich. Es sind zwei unterschiedliche Protokolle, sind unterschiedliche
Leute für zuständig, aber vom Ansatz her sind die ähnlich. Es sind beides zwei Protokolle
für Heim-Automatisierungs- oder für IoT-Geräte und es sind beides Protokolle mit Mesh-Netzwerk,
also sprich umso mehr Geräte und umso mehr Basis-Stationen du hast, umso besser ist
das Netzwerk. Und es sind beides Sachen, die für ultra-low-power-Geräte gedacht sind.
So. Und gerade solche Fenster-Tür-Sensoren möchte man ja auch, dass sie eine Weile halten
und ich will nicht nach einem halben Jahr überall das Ding. Also ich habe jetzt welche,
die sind drei Jahre alt und die Batterie geht immer noch. Und das ist auch eine Zeitspanne,
die ist okay. Dann ab und zu man Batterie wechseln. So. Und im Bereich WLAN gibt es
da nichts, weil WLAN halt ein bisschen viel Strom braucht. Deswegen gibt es bei den meisten
WLAN-Geräten was, was halt nur maximal ein halbes Jahr oder so hält. So. Dann gucke
ich jetzt mal schnell in den Chat, weil ich habe jetzt gerade gesehen, dass jetzt gleich
drei Fragen auf einmal gekommen haben. Hey Max, eine Frage. Wie kann ich, wenn ich bei
einem Debian-Server die Platte mit dem Bordmittel verschlüsselt habe, wenn ich den Neustart
über SSH das Encryption-Kernwort mit schicken? Hast du es schon so eingerichtet, dass der
dich, also hast du schon voll verschlüsselt, dass er dich beim Booten fragt nach einem
Passwort? Dann brauchst du das hier. Dann installierst du das hier. Unter Debian installierst du
das hier. Also hier, das da, Dropinit, ramfs musst du installieren und dann musst du glaube
ich nur noch einmal dein Image updaten und es geht direkt. Ich glaube viel mehr musste
man gar nicht machen. Ich glaube du musst dein SSH-Key noch hinkopieren. Aber lese
dir mal einen Guide dazu durch. Das ist nicht schwierig. Das haben wir auch schon ein paar
mal im Stream gemacht. Also das ist das Paket, was du brauchst für Debian. Das ist quasi
ein SSH-Server. Der ist embedded in deinem Boot-Image und dann kannst du dich per SSH
einloggen und er fragt dich nach deinem Passwort. Also hier, guck dir mal irgendwie so einen
Guide an. Das ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert. Also ich habe gefunden, wie man auf C++ von
der Engine aus zugreifen kann. Kann dann C++ die Fault Mission... Naja, also du hast in
der C++ Standard Library nichts drinne für irgendwie MySQL Libraries oder so. Aber du
kannst dir einfach irgendeine C++ MySQL Library nehmen und das damit machen. Da gibt es mit
Sicherheit jede Menge für. Ach guck mal, hier ist sogar das Link zum Watt. Guck mal,
hier haben wir es doch gemacht. Oder auch nicht. Doch. Verschlüsselung. Guck mal, hier ist
sogar das Watt. Welches Watt denn? Ja, das Watt. Ja, guck mal da. In dem Watt haben wir
das sogar schon gemacht. Clilux Server verschlüsseln. Das will ich nicht. Nein, das will ich nicht.
Ja, hier, hier. Aber da haben wir es ganz abgedreht gemacht. Da haben wir selbst, da haben wir
quasi per PxE gebootet oder solche Dinger. Das musst du natürlich nicht machen. Du brauchst
nur den letzten Part, wo ich hier irgendwo, frag mich nicht, den Kram installiere. Muss
ich mal ein bisschen durchklicken. So, weiter. Da sind wir stehen geblieben. Kann man bei
G-Drive keine Ahnung. Aber es ist nicht schwierig. Guck dir lieber den Guide an. Du musst einfach
nur diesen Drop-Init-Rama-FS installieren und ich glaube den SSH Key reinkopieren und
dann rebooten und dann geht das schon. So, was hat er sonst noch hier für Sachen?
Das sieht kacke aus. Das sieht kacke aus. Man könnte den Kram ja da dran kleben. Wobei
er hat den dran geklebt. Manche LED-Strips haben das Problem, dass sie ultra heiß werden,
wenn sie da fest aufliegen. Gibt es eigentlich eine Liste an Produkten, die ich empfehle?
So eine Art FAQ. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Wir wollten sowas schon mal erstellen, aber
es lag auch nicht am Sebaro oder so. Der Sebaro hat schon angefangen und ich habe dem Sebaro
aber nie was geschickt. Also das lag an mir. Der Cute-Mod ist unschuldig. Da mache ich
aber mal was. Das ist eine gute Idee. Da kann ich gleich ein bisschen Ref-Links unter
das Volk bringen. Vielleicht bekomme ich mal mehr als 20 Euro Amazon Ref-Links. Seit ich
kein YouTube-Zeug mehr mache, gibt es... Ich hatte teilweise... Vor ein paar Jahren
hatte ich über 1000 Euro Amazon Ref-Links an Weihnachten. Mittlerweile sind es keine
Ahnung, 20 Euro oder so. Das Gute an Amazon Ref-Links ist, dass es halt kein was mehr
kostet. Das ist eine coole Idee. Das ist eine coole Idee, wenn es klingelt, dass die Lampen
pulsieren. Das ist eine coole Idee, die gefällt mir. Oh, die habe ich auch. Da habe ich auch
zwei Stück von. Die sind richtig cool. Damit kann man Sachen drücken lassen. Die sind
nice. Da habe ich auch zwei Stück. Das ist echt cool. Moment, hat er jetzt... Das ist
schon Big Brain, oder? Eigentlich richtig cool. Dafür könnte ich das auch machen. Das
könnte ich das auch verwenden. Eigentlich ist das eine richtig geile Idee. Ich habe
einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch und ich habe noch mindestens einen von diesen
Switchbots über. Das wäre eigentlich richtig nice. Dann muss ich nicht mein Schreibtisch
von Hand hochfahren, sondern könnte mein Schreibtisch über meinen Home Assistant hochfahren. Alternativ
ist halt auch die Sache, ich könnte einfach auf den Knopf drücken. Weil ich habe hier
die Bedienung von dem Tisch liegt 30 cm von meiner Hand weg. Aber die Idee ist cool. Die
Idee gefällt mir. Die hat was. Gute Idee, gute Idee. Könnte ich auch machen. Eigentlich
eine richtig coole Idee für den Vorratsschrank. Eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee für den
Vorratsschrank. Ich glaube, so etwas in der Richtung werde ich nochmal einbauen. Das
sieht viel zu stylisch aus für einen publischen Abstellschrank. Guck mal, richtig coole Beleuchtung
für den Abstellschrank, muss ich sagen. Aber es ist fast schon Perlen vor die Säue, wie
man das so schön sagt. Eigentlich fast schon, es sieht schon zu gut aus für einen Abstellschrank.
Guck mal, hier ist der Smart Home Ersatzteile Schrank. Ja, das Solar von Astor, das wäre
natürlich noch besser, wenn ich den Tisch gar kein Schalter mehr drücken müsste. Geht
wahrscheinlich ohne Probleme, ESP32 dran und dann von Hand die Kontakte, das geht bestimmt.
Gibt es eigentlich einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch mit Rest-API? Ne, aber das könnten
wir bauen. Also ich könnte garantiert diesen Control-Button-Ding, könnte ich garantiert
ersetzen durch einen ESP32, der das für mich schaltet und dann könnten wir dem Ding auch
einen Rest-API verpassen. Moment, Amazon hat jetzt eine Alarmanlage? Amazon Guard? Oder
ist Amazon Guard eine Funktion von Echo? Ich verwende kein Amazon Zeug, ich habe kein Schimmer.
Ah, das sieht so aus, als wäre man zu Hause. Okay, das fällt für mich schon mal komplett
raus, weil ich weder Alexa noch Amazon Echoes noch irgendwelche Amazon-Dinger habe. Hat
meiner nicht, hat keine Kameras, meine hat nur so einen Laser-Abtast-Sensor. Ich will
auch ehrlich gesagt gar keinen China-Roboter mit Kameras haben. Aber der Staubsauger-Roboter,
da steht ja gerade im Wohnzimmer und ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich macht er auch nur das
Wohnzimmer aktuell. Der funktioniert ziemlich gut seitdem wir den, den haben wir ja auch
im Stream geflasht. Hier, da, da ist er. Karte vom Wohnzimmer, hier ist die Eingangstür,
null. Guck mal, hier sieht man wann er gefahren ist. Man sieht sogar noch die letzten, man
sieht sogar noch wie er das letzte Mal gefahren ist, hier. Hier ist die Docking-Station, hier
ist die Docking-Station, hier ist das Sofa, da kommt er nicht runter aktuell, weil da
was davor hängt. Hier ist ein Sessel, da kommt er auch nicht runter und hier hat er
sauber gemacht. Ist auch cool, dass man, dass man das. Das stimmt nicht so ganz, die Docking-Station
ist nicht da, die Docking-Station ist da. Das ist ein Zimmer, ja. Jaja, das ist nur
das Wohnzimmer. Das ist nicht meine Wohnung, das ist nur das Wohnzimmer. Hier ist die
eigentlich, hier ist die Tür zunächst zum, zum Flur. Das ist grad nur ein Zimmer was
auf der Map drauf ist. Ja. Übrigens, so ein schickes Web-Interface gibt es auch nicht
ohne Custom-Firmware, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, warum ich alles flashe was China-Firmware
hat und ich mir keine China-Geräte anschafe, die man nicht flaschen kann. Ich muss übrigens
mal gucken, ob es ein neues Tuya, Tuya-Convert-Version gibt für China-Geräte. Ne, gibt's nicht.
Ah, exzellent. Moment, das erkennt das Ding. Da hab ich irgendwie, meint ihr das funktioniert
gut? Ob der das, ob das gut funktioniert? Ich hab da irgendwie meine Zweifel, dass das
so zuverlässig geht. Außerdem, warum scheißt sein Hund in die Wohnung? Warum scheißt sein
Hund überhaupt in die Wohnung? Das ist doch die eigentliche Frage. Und wo ist, wo ist
mein Kack-Emoji da? Guck mal, der guckt auch schon so, der guckt auch schon so. Ich wurde
erwischt. Wartet mal kurz.
Ja, also warum scheißt sein Hund in die Wohnung? Ja, kein Wunder, wenn er remote
zu dem Hund was sagt.
Hä? Und das hab ich nicht kapiert. Ah, das ist, wenn die Tür auf ist. Okay, das ist
nicht schlecht. Ist das grad sehr laut? Das ist doch Sponsort, oder? Das ist Sponsort.
Patrick hat Resub, danke, nee, du hast nicht Resub, du hast Abo verschenkt? Achso, ich hab
dir das letzte Mal, ich hab dir das letzte Mal, ach jetzt, diese Meldung hab ich so noch
nie gesehen. Ja, nice, für den Sub, huge. Wir hatten was gekriegt, Captain Seekai hat
wieder eins gekriegt, exellent. Den hab ich schon öfters hier gesehen, der hat's definitiv
verdient. Danke schön für den Sub. Das ist ja, du bist ja auch schon ganz schön lange
dabei, das ist ja quasi schon. Eigentlich, eigentlich eher.
Ja, das brauch ich nicht, das ist unsinnig. Nee, das brauch ich nicht. Das brauch ich
nicht, zumal das eh sehr laut ist. Okay, das ist übel, sell out. Ja, ist jetzt gut.
Kommt bei mir nicht in die Tüte, wir haben so ne old school Türgegensprechanlage, da
hatten wir es ja schon ein paar Mal von, über das Abenteuer mit meiner Türgegensprechanlage
und Klingelsignal abgreifen, hab ich mir schon oft genug ausgelassen. Das kommt bei mir
allerdings nicht in die Tüte, ich will keine dieser, vor allem guck mal hier, das ist so
typische Kokona-Installation hier mit dem Kabel durch die Wand und sowas. Das ist ne
Siedel-Türgegensprechanlage, ja. Dom PC, neun Monate, danke schön für den Sub. So,
aber sowas kommt bei mir nicht in die Tüte, weil mich nervt zwar ein bisschen, dass man
meine aktuelle Türgegensprechanlage, also wir haben so ein Ding hier. Hätte ich damals
was anderes installiert, hätte ich mir damals um Smart Home schon Gedanken gemacht, als
wir hier eingezogen sind. So ein Ding haben wir da, aber es hat auch seine, was Unify Klingel,
ne hab ich noch nicht gesehen. Unify Door, Bell, die kenn ich ja nicht. Das ist wirklich
super wirre Technik, wie das funktioniert. Ich hab ja mal so ein Ding gebaut, glaub haben
wir uns nicht so ganz zusammen im Stream angeguckt, wie man das hier abgreifen kann. Das Klingelsignal.
Eigentlich, eigentlich ne coole Sache, aber ich hätte wahrscheinlich jetzt was anderes
eingebaut, wenn ich mir damals schon um Smart Home Sachen Gedanken gemacht hätte. Aber
die Sache ist die, warum ich das nicht austausche, ist, der Kram funktioniert wirklich sehr
robust. Also wir haben zwei Gegensprechanlagen, Telefone im Flur hängen, direkt daneben hängt
das Heimautomatisierungstablet, passt ganz gut. Das Zeug ist wirklich sehr robust, weil
mal angenommen, man hat so ne, mal angenommen man hat hier so ein Ding, Moment wo hab ich
es denn, mal angenommen man hat so ein Ding. Sobald, sagen wir mal, die Fritzbox nicht
da ist mit dem Wlan oder sobald man den Router neu startet, irgendwas, funktioniert die Klingel
nicht mehr. Das ist halt der Vorteil von diesem Oldschool Zeug, egal was ist, wenn nicht gerade
Stromausfall ist, geht die Klingel. Und ja, ich hab ja hier so ein Ding mal gebaut, müssen
wir mal gucken, ob ich noch die Bilder finde, ob das eins von beiden. Dieses Bild hab ich
jetzt eigentlich nicht gesucht. Und das auch nicht, okay, ich find mal, ich find, ich find,
ich find, die ist gar nicht mehr, wo hab ich, Image, CC, CC, ah wie hieß das denn, ja,
vielleicht hab ich sie mal in der VM. Gut, wie auch immer, ich finde das Bild gerade
nicht mehr dazu, ich hätte mir das vielleicht mal bookmarken sollen. Wir haben ja im Stream
irgendwas gebaut, was erkennt, wann bei der Klingel geklingelt wird. So, und das funktioniert
folgendermaßen, war das Pick, nee, das war irgendwas mit CC, CC Image, ich bin mir relativ
sicher, es war Image. Ja, ich bin ja auch blöd, dass ich mir die Dinger nicht mal bookmarken
kann. Image, vielleicht hab ich hier auf dem Desktop noch eins, oder in der VM. Zumindest,
zumindest haben wir was gebastelt, ich start mal die VM, dann können wir nebenbei gucken,
was es abgreift, was das Klingelsignal abgreift. Und es ist halt ziemlich, äh, es ist halt
ein bisschen, äh, es ist ein bisschen, äh, es ist ein bisschen, äh, es ist ein bisschen,
ja. Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hat, vielleicht muss ich einfach
mal vor immer neu starten, oder so. Äh, ja, knäher wäre ganz einfach, weil ich noch
nicht geupdatet hab. Zumindest dann, dann, ich, das geht mir, warte mal, History, History,
是 must be changed. Yes, everything is as it should be. Name it. M.Sim, I will name
was post image ah post image punkt cc warum findet er das nicht mit image mit image cc
post das ist eine sache wo ich firefox deutlich besser finde die history suche sagt in chrome
so da ist es doch das ist die kaputt eine tastatur und das ist ein ding so genau das ist das teil was
ich gebastelt habe nee ist es nicht oder doch nicht nee das ist der usb stick scheiß drauf
bevor ich das bild jetzt finde zumindest diese siedler sachen ist super kompliziertes zeug
nee das ist das innen das ist das innen das ist das innen telefon das bild apc lustig
ich finde schon toll dass du das besser findest als ich also schneller findet als ich ist ja auch
gucken was haben wir hier das ist noch was anderes kann ich jetzt in meiner history nach post image
punkt cc suchen und dann finden wir was moment das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen post image punkt
cc so viel macht es jetzt einfach mal alles auf und dann hoffen wir dass es irgendwo dabei ist
und jetzt erst mal liegt nach ja genau das ist es pc lustig warum warum findest du die
bilder von mir schneller als als ich selber tapps overload
das ist immer das gleiche
aber er hat der pc lustig hat schon gefunden nämlich das hier meine ich also das ist die
türkigen sprechanlage von der eins an hier ist das ding was ich gebastelt habe und zwar
folgendermaßen funktioniert das das ist richtig die schönste variante aber so also was was der
da macht ist einmal habe ich das ist in sp 32 das hier ist ein sensor für das ist ein magnet
sensor da man daran kann man erkennen wenn das telefon aufgelegt wurde oder nicht als telefon
ist das hier und die haben im hörern ein magnet drinne und ich stecke einfach diesen magnet hinter
den hörern und dann erkenne ich also diesen magnet sensor weil eben weil im also hier im
hörern ist ein magnet drinne woran das telefon selbst auch erkennt ob das teller der telefon
hörer aufgehangen aufhängt oder nicht so und hier habe ich ein magnet sensor ich habe vergessen
wie der kram heißt ein hall sensor genau und er erkennt ob das ob der hörer aufgehängt
ist oder nicht das heißt anhand dessen weiß ich an welchem handgespräch gerät jemand
dran ist das ganze habe ich übrigens fett in heißkleber gepackt dass es nicht aus versehen
irgendwie sich hier kurz schließt so das sind sp 32 und hier dran ist das teil von in der
galerie so und hier dran ist man erkennt man erkennt es nicht so genau ist der anschluss
für die für die gegensprechanlage wo wo woran der sp 32 erkennt ob geklingelt wurde
oder nicht super komplizierter geschiss eigentlich dafür so und diese siedelsachen funktionieren
folgendermaßen die haben irgendwie eine normale spannung von ich sag jetzt mal ich glaube
24 volt oder so auf der leitung wenn es klingelt geht es hoch auf 27 und wenn abgenommen wird
geht es runter auf 15 so und diese spannungsänderung muss man erkennen und weiß in welchem zustand
die gegensprechanlage ist also total abgedrehtes oldschool zeug aber ein vorteil hat die tür
gegensprechanlage so eine oldschool tür gegensprechanlage versus so eine neue sie funktioniert sie
funktioniert ob das wlan geht sie funktioniert ob die fritzbox geht sie funktioniert einfach
was ich schon ein vorteil finde ja und dadurch dass ich jetzt abgegriffen habe wann geklingelt
wird kann ich zumindest mal eine notification schicken auf alle handys wenn geklingelt wurde
und man vielleicht gerade im garten ist oder im auf der terrasse ist dann kriege ich den
notification geschickt es hat gerade geklingelt ist eigentlich ganz nützlich was was nicht
funktioniert ist mit dem ist das telefon mit dem typ an der tür sprechen das funktioniert
nicht das ist auch noch mal noch mal ein bisschen komplizierter dass das einzurichten aber deswegen
kommt mir keine neue tür sprech gegensprechanlage ins haus weil ich dieses setup hier eigentlich
ganz gut finde weil es schlicht ergreifen funktioniert immer funktioniert und ich mache
es jetzt so wenn es klingelt und ich das mit diesem esp 32 erkenne ob es klingelt dann
geht direkt auf dem tablet im flur geht der browser auf mit der kamera ansicht von der
tür also sprich ich habe dann im flur man hat es ja hier gesehen ich habe im flur das
tablet hängen und das telefon und wenn es klingelt geht das tablet an direkt in die
browser ansicht und zeigt mir die kamera vom hoftor und dann kann ich hier dran gehen also
sprich ich gehe zwar an die tür gegensprechanlage aber ich sehe vorher schon ob das vielleicht
jemand ist wo ich lieber faken will dass ich nicht daheim bin
drei abos nee und insgesamt drei abos verschenkt an pc lustig pc lustig hat aber von liko
gekriegt dankeschön für den sap exquisite subscription dankeschön benutze normales
chromium oder an google chromium ich glaube mittlerweile normales chromium damit hardware
die coding geht
top das war so so genau kommen wir weiter das ist der grund warum ich das nicht zu einer
moderneren tür gegensprecher lager austauscht weil das zeug einfach so wie man so rock solid
erst und funktioniert
ja das wollte ich auch noch machen habe ich nicht ich hatte verschiedene ansätze erst
mit einem rüssel sensor aber am besten dürfte wahrscheinlich echt seinen stromverbrauch
zu erwachen
eigentlich gute idee aber die einfachste variante ist einfach keine kinder haben
das habe ich nicht verstanden was wenn es draußen dunkler wird macht er die lichter
entsprechend hoch oder das ist eine coole idee also wenn man sein haus so eingerichtet
mit smart lichter und schalter und alle möglichen das ist eine gute idee
wisst ihr was ich bei dem auch ganz cool finde der hat alles so indirekt beleuchtet das sieht
zwar cool aus aber irgendwie habe ich den eindruck die räume sind nie richtig hell
das kann doch nicht sein ernst sein jetzt das funktioniert doch im leben nicht
das funktioniert jetzt genau in diesem einen fall
das funktioniert genau in diesem einen fall wo diese toys so da liegen in dieser größe
und da ne bock steht im leben funktioniert es nicht wirklich sinnvoll und dann muss
du so ein fettes ding hinten dran an der fernbedienung also wenn man schon so eine stylische fernbedienung
hat wenn man das dann unbedingt haben will dann mache ich mir dann so einen fetten tracker
hinten dran also das sind doofe idee gefällt mir nicht ganz davon abgesehen ich finde die
fernbedienung die fernbedienung ist glaube ich eines der wenigen sachen die immer an
der gleichen stelle legt außerdem habe ich drei fernbedienung ich habe die fernbedienung
vom fernsee ich habe die fernbedienung vom schiel tv und ich habe die feier tv fernbedienung
mit allen drei kann ich das schiel tv fernsteuern also ich finde immer irgendwas außerdem gucke
ich quasi kein fernsee ja das ist ganz nett ich bin ich doofe frage chat bin ich der einzige
der bei wenn er filme guckt nie das licht ausmacht ich mache nie dunkel wenn ich filme
guck ich lasse immer ganz normal beleuchtung an ich mag das gar nicht wenn es so richtig
dusch da ist bis in dem könnte man vielleicht ja und weil wir jetzt in weil wir jetzt in
usa sind geht es die selbstschussanlage los vor der tür freedom
ich muss ja sagen die beleuchtung von ihm sieht wirklich hübsch aus mich würde mal
interessieren ob er ob die räume bei ihm auch irgendwann mal richtig hell sind weil
diese also jetzt wille soll es ja gar nicht hell sein aber dieses ganze indirekte beleuchten
was er hier hat wobei hier nicht aber den anderen sagt es macht den raum nie so richtig
hell oder hätte ich ja keinen bock drauf wenn mir alexa sagt ich soll den müll raus
räumen das ist ja schon bei der switch immer so nervig gewesen zeit mal was stand bei der
switch immer zeit mal rauszugehen oder irgendwie sowas ja das ist echt übertrieben das ist
echt übertrieben der ist aber der macht den zell auch aber auch gut hier man spricht
das ding auch noch das fake wahrscheinlich fern das fern steuert gerade irgendjemand
das ist jebait also sind wir ein paar gute idee dabei da macht wirklich gut videos aber
es ist auch schon ein busy übertrieben allerdings kann man das gar nicht so sehr sagen weil
die meisten leute würden auch sagen sie finden das übertrieben was ich hier mache für die
meisten leute ist es schon übertrieben wenn du ein fenster tür sensor hast oder irgendwie
ein licht was die die bahnverspätung anzeigt oder irgendwie ein heizungsthermostat was
sich automatisch regelt das ist die meistens für die meisten leute schon richtig teufels
zeug mit der gerade in deutschland wir sind ja eh ein bisschen technologiefeindlich
die fernseh ausmachen und so mache ich auch nicht also was ich sinnvoll finde ist halt
wenn man wirklich ins bett geht und vergessen hat was auszuschalten und das erkennt ok da
max ist jetzt im bett 15 minuten nach 22 uhr ich mache mal das licht im bad aus und oder
ich schicke vielleicht noch den message wenn er vergessen hat das fenster im bad zuzumachen
oder so das finde ich sinnvoll aber dinger die für mich dann sagen so nach dem motto
jetzt ist genug fernseh geguckt nee das muss nicht sein
der zweite 0 euro pc aus gratis teil was haben wir sonst noch usb ports kabel da kann ich
flamen wenn es unterschiedlich ich flamme gerne über usb
und das ist langweilig ok das langweilig ich ok wo zeigt der die usb klassiker kennt jeder
kennt auch noch jeder kennt auch noch jeder ja kennt auch noch jeder was der neue ist rot
echt sind die rot ich dachte rot sind die dinger die quick charge können auf meinem
mainboard hast du immer noch ein bad man weiß es nicht was ist was ist dann usb 4 usb
4 ist dann jetzt müssen sie langsam anfangen farben zu recyceln was wird dann usb 4 lila
regenbogenfarbe das ist ja ein usb c stecker es bleibt ja ein usb c stecker stimmt ja das
ist old school das ist der richtig old school usb anschluss so sahen die dinger zu zeiten
von usb 1 usb 2 aus da hast du geräte immer an diesen fetten angeschlossen oder usb c
jetzt neu erdenkt ja geht an rechner und das geht halt ans gerät das wissen wir schon
ja ja ok ok weiter mini ok was denn das ok jetzt wird jetzt kommen wir eher in die abgedrehten
sphären von usb dinger die kein mensch verwendet mini b habe ich noch nie gesehen ich kann
mini usb aber ist das das gleiche micro usb mini usb ok
ist das moment das ist doch das was ich ohne micro usb verstehe oder das ist das ist das
sind die ganz normalen anschlüsse oder ich wusste nur mir ist bloß nicht klar dass die
dinger micro b heißen ja dann habe ich das mein plujetti hat mit hat mini und die elgato
capture card hat auch noch mini also sagt man dazu eigentlich korrekterweise nicht mini usb
und micro usb sondern man müsste sagen usb micro b ok das habe ich noch nie sagen gehört jemand
den habe ich auch schon mal irgendwo gesehen ja ich glaube ich habe einen
ich glaube ich habe ein externen usb 3 so wechselrahmen für für ssd ist der so ein
ding hat so geil was es da wieder für 30 milliarden sagen gibt ja das ist ja absicht
dafür umgedreht passen die da rein ok habe ich noch nie gesehen wusste ich gar nicht dass
der existiert wozu ist das war was ist die da sein ah das ist ein uhr das ist einfach
ein schnellerer schnellere variante von micro b
also bei der ssd zum beispiel ja gott sei dank der macht diesen ganzen anderen kram überflüssig
aber die haben doch echt die haben doch echt komplett dachschaden ja zum glück ist er nicht
noch auf usb standards oder so eingegangen so der zweite 0 euro pc aus gratis ebay teilen
dann zeigt mehr also der erste 0 euro pc war nicht wirklich 0 euro das war eigentlich mehr
nen gbait video weil er hat zwar den pc für 0 euro bekommen aber hatte bestimmt 50 euro
fahrtkosten hallo ja und willkommen zurück zu einem neuen video von mir es geht heute
weiter mit dem pc aus ebay klein anzeigen teilen die mir geschenkt wurden und eigentlich ist
der kram ja schon fertig es gab zwei teile habe ich was funktionstüchtiges zusammengebaut auf
jeden fall aber wir haben noch teile übrig und da bin ich sehr zuversichtlich dass da zumindest
irgendetwas lauffähiges bei rumkommen sollte und aus diesem grunde werde ich das jetzt auch
gleich tun ich lese mir noch mal eben schnell die kommentare durch vielleicht hat noch irgendwas
irgendjemand was angemerkt oder gesagt ja mach mal das mach mal das dann können wir das hier
vielleicht was asynchron bei mir ist es passt eigentlich somit weitermachen und dann nochmal
ausgegebenem anlass weil scheinbar immer noch nicht bei allen angekommen ist ich bin kein pc
oder sonst was reparatur dienst für irgendwas das ok wenn du so ein channel hast kann ich
verstehen ich mein bei mir unter den videos damals haben die leute schon geschrieben so nach dem motto
hilfe max mein trucker geht nicht kannst du mir sagen woran das liegt und so was gestern wieder
irgendwie hat er jemand geschrieben pc funktioniert nicht oder schmutzig oder so was keine ahnung
wie gesagt nö wieso soll ich das machen ich dachte du reparierst sachen für cash habe ich das dann
gesagt habe ich das gesagt das habe ich nicht gesagt ich meine ihr könnt gerne fragen stellen
oder hilfe von mir kriegen die leute sind immer so geil und dann beschweren sie sich danach noch
so nach dem motto du bist so abgehoben du hilfst noch nicht mal einem viewer oder so was
bitte mal bisschen den ball flach halten und am besten auch mal lesen bevor man mir was abschickt
und ich meine jetzt nicht leute die noch extra dazu schreiben ja tut mir leid ich habe lese
rechtschreibschwäche oder sowas das ist teilweise besser zu lesen als das ist die geilste ausrede
schade also ich weiß es gibt genug leute das haben aber es gibt auch genug leute das als
ausrede verwenden da wäre noch was im hinterkopf gewesen was ich noch zeigen wollte oder konnte es
fiel mir nicht mehr ein und in den kommentaren war es auch nicht dabei beziehungsweise nicht
irgendwas was die sachen aus dem ersten teil betrifft aber wir haben ja noch die sachen die
quasi übrig sind wie gerade schon gesagt der netzteiltester hatte gesagt power gut signal
aber das sind schaku netzteile sogar was halbwegs gutes
was brauchbares ja also kein lc power zumindest schon mal allerdings sind die anderen spannungen
erst mal in ordnung ob das hiermit dann klappt oder abstürze gibt oder so weil ich habe hunger
es ist ja auch zeitverzögerung umstellung gewesen es war zeitverzögerung die sachen
drin die noch übrig sind dass sieben sieben fünfer volt mit dem kort zwei duo moment sehe
ich da zwei idee anschlüsse erkenne ich das richtig zwei idee und zweimal sata ok das muss
aus einer übergangszeit sein das sind ja auch noch normale pci guck mal hier ist noch pci
express und normale pci das muss eine übergangsphase gewesen sein bei bedarf diese grafikkarte die
wahrscheinlich schlechter ist als die grafiklösung hier drin ein kühler floppy laufwerk ein sata
kabel haben wir noch übrig und ach das gehört dazu ok und dann gab es noch die drei festplatten
ja irgendwie sowas was ist das für ein dickes gereppene bei der cpu ich würde sagen es sind
chips als kühler und die andere die hat glaube ich oder onboard grafikkarte das macht ok smart ok
ja nimm mal diese hier und wer sich noch zurück sind ich habe ja im ersten hat jemand von euch
jemals schon aus den smartwerten einer festplatte irgendwie nützliche informationen rausbekommen
ernst gemeinte frage ich noch nie das ist zwar da aber wirklich bringen tut das nix ich glaube
es hat sich noch nie eine platte bei mir über smartwerte angekündigt wenn sie kaputt gehen
ja
exquisite gehäuse nur vom feinsten immer noch irgend so ein ranzzeug drin das müssen wir jetzt
erstmal ignorieren leider habe ich das laufwerk wo ist das ach das habe ich in dem pc verwendet
dann ja ok dann gibt es eben kein laufwerk und wir haben ein exzellentes kohle aber das ist ja
auch nicht der goal bei diesem pc dass er nach irgendwas aussieht nicht das gold würde ich sagen
verfracht ich den kram von da mal das gold wäre auch schwierig zu erreichen dass der noch was
ordentlichen aussieht aber das ist ja nicht wie ganz geht ja um null euro rein und dann schauen
wir mal wie und ob und was überhaupt funktioniert irgendwie was oder wie oder was
peter jam bevor es nun einmal ganz weiter geht wollte ich noch einmal zeigen und beweisen dass
das mainboard tatsächlich funktioniert trotz der abgebrochenen halterung hier für den
arbeitsspeicher die kannst du so rausziehen und der arbeitsspeicher bleibt drin und es läuft
dann auch alles allerdings funktioniert die grafikkarte nicht hier so eingestellt dass
er automatisch die pc express grafikkarte nehmen soll aber ob das wirklich das problem wahrscheinlich
ist dass er die grafik an das hier normalen chipsatz ist vielleicht ist das damals war ja noch nicht
so viel in der cpu drin heute hast ja quasi alles was früher auf mainboard war mainboard war in der
cpu du hast sata gedöns in der cpu du hast alle die ganze chipsatz funktionieren in der cpu die
grafikkarte in der cpu heute ist alles in der cpu drin also eigentlich könntest du heute wahrscheinlich
mainboards bauen nicht so groß sind das bord an der stelle ja auch kaputt besorge ich mir mal
eben eine andere karte schieb sie da rein und merke mich sofort noch mal bevor es da wirklich als
eigentliche zusammenbauen geht und ein test mit einer anderen grafikkarte beweist dass mainboard
ist an der stelle nicht kaputt sondern die grafikkarte das ist übrigens eine arty radion x 300 se mit
128 megabyte speicher ich habe keine ahnung wahrscheinlich schlecht ich weiß nicht genau
welche spezifikation das ist aber die sind wirklich verdammt langsam das kann auch nicht sein dass die
kaputt ist also tatsächliche ok weil ich habe mit smart werden noch nie irgendwas sinnvolles
rausbekommen es ist ja generell so zumindest in meiner erinnerung irgendwelche karten gehen
sehr viel schneller kaputt weil sie eben thermisch und leistungstechnisch belastet werden bei solchen
karten die halten eigentlich ewig ich versuche noch mal was wenn das was es kommt nicht von
ungefähr dass in manchen surfer hardwares noch arty rage pro und sowas verbaut ist on board
das sind sachen von 1998 geklappt hat dann der kram funst die karte läuft wieder das habe ich
getan ich habe dieses hart gewordene hiebpett einmal beseitigt und gemerkt dass sich das um
verschiedene bauteile neben dem eigentlichen gpu chip auf dem chip gesammelt hat ihr wisst was ich
meine das habe ich eben sauber gemacht und jetzt kriegen wir auf jeden fall wieder ein bild ich
habe auch diesen jumper gewechselt ich weiß nicht was er tut steht einfach nur mpeg 3 daneben
entklammern kann aber auch sein dass das für irgendein anderes bauteil zutrifft also nun endlich
moment was hat er denn da ist es ist es so eine wärme bildkamera wo man erkennt wie warm was
ist gibt es da irgendwas günstiges ich habe mir das auch schon überlegt ob ich mal so was holen
aber der kram kostet gleich 500 euro oder so und das war es mir nicht wert guck mal sieht
richtig ordentlich aus das gehäuse mittlerweile macht doch was her
es macht gleich copyright strike so ich habe jetzt mal gedacht weil ich die ganze zeit immer
windows benutze und ja bei meinen rick irgendwie mal linux verwenden wollte probiere ich mal mit
was wollte ich einfach mal irgendwie gezeigt haben hat mir null gefallen hatten wir irgendwann im
stream ganz cool fand irgendwie so beim täglichen nutz das war so eines der linux dinger die voll
auf windows machen aber guckste zwei icon und zwei buttons tiefer erkennt halt sofort das ist kein
windows deswegen ich bin der meinung es bringt überhaupt nichts wenn man so tut als wäre man
windows und quasi wenn man nur ein bisschen an oberfläche kratzt ist schon wieder kein windows
ist das heißt man sollte ganz klar von anfang an gleich das machen dass es eben kein windows ist
dann sind die leute auch nicht enttäuscht und denken das geht alles mir unter windows weil geht
es halt nun mal nicht und bis jetzt läuft es noch also alles gut auch mit diesem total ranzigen
usb stick der schon zweimal umgebogen wurde wo vorher wenn noch sieben als installation
drauf war aber können wir mal warten schau mal schau mal hier ist übrigens immer noch der
laptop von warum steht das schau mal ich weiß nicht mehr wie er heißt da habe ich auf jeden
fall mal ein video zu machen auch man das zum mainboard sauber machen oder so hier aus der
umgebung hier das ding musste mal abholen ansonsten ich kann das ja nicht hier liegen lassen und
verstauben lassen und der tatbestand ist nur folgende dass ich diese wir haben noch keine
bunten 2010 ausprobiert da gibt es glaube ich nichts großartig spannendes drin das einzig
spannende in 2010 ist glaube ich der zfs installer und da habe ich irgendwo gelesen dass sie nicht
alle module drin haben so dass encryption abgrundtief langsam ist wenn nicht das probieren
wir vielleicht mal muss man das kann man aufschreiben angeblich haben die jetzt nämlich
ein zfs installer und auch eingebaut zfs encryption aber ich habe im vorfeld irgendwo gelesen dass
die irgendwelche module nicht drin haben so dass es halt extrem langsam ist sie vor meinem krank
sein aufgenommen habe und mich deswegen noch nicht mit dem laptop beschäftigt habe aber das
hat sich geändert manche von euch haben es bestimmt schon gesehen und wer es noch nicht gesehen
dass oben rechts einmal an den bildschirm heran schauen dort gibt es eine verlinkung entweder
für jetzt oder für später oder für einen neuen tab öffnen oder sonst irgendwas in der art ich
verwende jetzt hier läuft eigentlich so ganz in ordnung und dann habe ich mir jetzt gerade
gedacht während der ab der vorteil ist wenn der linux drauf installiert du musst keine 20.000
treiber nachinstallieren die schwierig zu bekommen sind für den old school kram macht google ich
einfach mal ein bisschen um zu schauen taugt zfs oder lieber btrfs auf jeden fall zfs also zfs ist
das deutlich bewährtere von beiden experience da ist und habe ich auch mal die grafikkarte
gegoogelt und da steht jetzt dabei dass sie hyper memory unterstützt ich habe irgendwann mal ein
pzgames hardware retro video gemacht vor drei jahren oder so das waren glaube ich keine
rti karten aber es waren grafikkarten die sich dann einfach am arbeitsspeicher mit dem grafik
speicher bedient haben das gab es und ich finde es gerade das gab es diese karte das auch macht
ich werde gleich mal schauen ob es mit der interne grafik ich hatte mal so einen wohnzimmer pc so
fragt mich nicht 2004 rum oder so der hatte eine onboard grafikkarte die hatte kein eigenes ram
der musstest du quasi normal also betriebssystem ram hier abzwacken hier vielleicht besser lauf
ziemlich das kacke system oder könnte man weiß es noch nicht aber natürlich muss er erst mal
updates nachreichen so und dann schalten wir das ding ein paar tage später noch mal ein
wahrscheinlich noch mal ein bisschen die das war ein karton hinter mir das zweite mal schauen
wir mal ob er noch hochfährt was man halt auch wieder schön daran sieht dass so bei
diesen pc ist von witten der von wann wird in der pc sein 2008 9 darum will ich zu sagen da
hat keiner auf optik geachtet wie gesagt hier bunte kabel halb zusammengebundene kabel weiße
kabel schwarze kabel rote gelbe orange und die boards sahen halt einfach auch total billig aus
heute hast du dann irgendwelche hochglanz boards mit metallschilds drauf und alles mögliche und
damals hier so nach dem auto alles drauf gequetscht was irgendwie geht bäm zu in karton fertig
so machst du keine youtube videos mehr weil mich youtube nicht sonderlich motiviert gerade aber
vielleicht kommt im december was komplett unerwartet ist wenn ich das wirklich auf die
reihe bekomme und dann nicht nur ein video ich bin beeindruckt also man möchte jetzt ja glaube ich
wissen was das ding kann oder wie sich das teil im alltag schlägt also schlecht youtube videos laufen
tatsächlich 720p und 30 fps sowie ich das gesehen habe ok das ist wirklich müll wenn das nicht
1080p hinbekommt aber der sollte doch eigentlich 1080p hinbekommen was ist das für eine cpu hat
das hier mal mitbekommen also 1080p die cpu decoden wüsste doch eigentlich auch eine alte cpu hinkriegen
war zwei du sollte doch 1080p die code bekommen an 4k ja das nicht aber unter den uns hast du
immer noch das problem dass allgemein video decoding im browser so eine schwieriges scenario ist alles
drüber funktioniert so überhaupt nicht ok also nicht von der bildschirmauflösung her sondern es
geht einfach nicht weder mit der internen grafik einheit noch mit dieser komischen arti karte die
darin verbaut ist zu öffnen so an sich ist es ruckelt heute ursprünglich aufgeschrieben
haben dass es ok ist aber ich habe an dem abend ein zwei bierchen getrunken also ok ist aber
was an den schwanz bei finanzen einziehen also habe ich das noch mal revidiert und
nein das ist nicht ganz so das ist wirklich das kannst du vergessen es gibt aber leute
soll ich aber sagen es gibt genug leute die merken nicht dass es leckt ich sehe das nicht
doch schnell genug ich merke das nicht passt doch alles gibt es ganz viele so leute und dann kam
ich irgendwie während der browser noch geöffnet war auf die idee mir mal das cpu modell und den
arbeitsspeicher und so weiter anzeigen zu lassen also habe ich die einstellungen geöffnet und dann
ist der pc tatsächlich eingefroren so quasi die maus konnte ich noch bewegen habe ein bisschen
gewartet das hat sich immer noch nicht gebessert ist sogar ein paar mal aufgetreten später noch
habe ich mir gedacht komm ich würde es mal interessieren wie es unter wind ausläuft hier bei
der kiste start aber apropos neustart 90 sekunden waren das irgendwie oder 100 sekunden falls das
nicht ganz richtig war ich werde später noch mal nachmessen an der videolänge dann werde ich das
jetzt korrigieren das ist manchmal ein wenig zeitraubend und dann habe ich natürlich die
einstellung irgendwann noch öffnen können mir ist dann aufgefallen ja 1,9 gigabyte ram müssten
eigentlich zwei sein okay der müsste doch der müsste doch 1080p video decoded kriegen
jetzt vielleicht kein 60 fps aber da haben wir ja noch bei der grafikkarte die besonderheit dass
sie sich tatsächlich arbeitsspeicher vom haupt pc ziehen kann ich weiß nicht inwiefern der
arbeitsspeicher davon betroffen wird ich weiß nur dass es sein kann weil hyper memory oder so hieß
das ich weiß es nicht mehr genau aber das gibt es auf jeden fall also dann dachte ich noch kommen
so als letzten test könnten wir doch mal minecraft probieren und dann fingen die richtigen probleme
an ich habe nämlich mein password vergessen das kommt davon dass man das ding fertig macht dann
eine woche nichts macht und das kein problem jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt kriegt er den kriegt er
den den trick hin zum booten das passport gefragt wird ich wollte es erst zurücksetzen da gibt es
ja so ein paar metode ja ja genau zum beispiel das ist eine der metoden die funktioniert
ja das ist richtig gut aber irgendwie hat das nicht geklappt ein ich glaube man muss es ich
bin mir nicht ansehen was ist was ist das hier von wobei das ist eigentlich richtig da gibt es
ja so ein paar das ist eigentlich richtig das müsste es müsste eigentlich funktionieren ich
bin mir jetzt ganz sicher ja was alles das hier in der richtigen stelle eigentlich aber das
müsste eigentlich klappen ich würde es mit bin sh probieren nicht gerade bin bash weiß aber
bash ist eigentlich auch überall drauf es müsste eigentlich gehen man kann es noch mit s probieren
oder mit eins hinten dran single user es geht auch bei manchen aber irgendwie hat das nicht
geklappt ein password wurde vorher nicht vergeben und als ich es vergeben habe konnte ich es auch
benutzen aber trotzdem konnte ich keine sachen installieren und dann habe ich noch tausende
passwörter geraten und so weiter und naja jetzt hat er mir noch mal installiert super filip und
dann ist mir noch aufgefallen dass es bei dieser linux version sehr sehr komisch ist wenn man
etwas installieren möchte und das falsch schreibt zum beispiel mc mit night commander zum beispiel
dann schlägt er dir sogar vor einzutippen apt install mc gibst du das eins auch da konnte
ich gefunden werden habe ich nachgeschaut ist halt das problem dass viele dinger halt übelst
unpolished sind dieser sources punkt konf heißt sie glaube ich das ist immer beim thema ich habe
doch eben gerade noch gesagt das sieht aus wie windows aber sobald du ein bisschen an der
oberfläche kratzt merkt man halt es ist kein windows deswegen hat es finde ich auch überhaupt
keinen sinn den leuten in wie vor zu gaukeln es wäre wie windows war einfach nix drin also
musste ich das auch noch eben nachrüsten kurioserweise damit ich auch mal so ein paar
sachen installieren konnte wirklich im terminal und nicht nur okay das ist ultra unpolished
diesen installer hier der naja nicht ganz funktioniert aber dann war es endlich so weit
ich wollte minecraft starten und frag mich nicht warum er das zweimal installiert hat ich habe
mich angemeldet wollte noch ja habe ich das nach installiert und dann gab es fehler 0 da dachte
ich mir grafikträger könnten zu fehler 0 excellent und das ist auch das was ich jetzt gerade seit
gefühlt zehn minuten versuche hier laufen zu lassen und es passiert einfach nichts der soll
nix laden der soll man probierst mal unter windows also die chancen dass es da funktioniert sind
deutlich besser weil du hast gerade genug zeit gehabt zum laden du könntest langsam mal anfangen
und wenn das hier nicht fertig wird dann wird das auch nichts mit minecraft da kannst du dir sicher
sein es steht nun moment der wahrheit vor der tür ich habe gerade extra den treiber runtergeladen
er sagte mir ist nicht support dann google ich und dann sagt mir die internetseite von
soren alle karten neu als 2013 laufen automatisch gut das lasse ich jetzt mal so dahingestellt
ach ja und ich habe mal hier eine x 570 passt super ich weiß ein euro pc und hat den arbeit
zweimal zwei gigabyte aufgestockt mehr kann das ding nicht ach ja und ich habe den das
passwort aufgeschrieben 12 und der benutzer heißt carlos das war vorher auch so ich weiß
auch nicht was das sollte das dauert immer so lange aber apropos lange ich habe hier vorne
ein wlan stick drin die gab es bei pollin für 99 cent ich weiß doch genau warum weil qualitativ
bestimmt absolut wahnsinn stick so standard treiber von windows damit nicht gehen und der
dvd treiber auch irgendwie nicht läuft das heißt man benötigt wahrscheinlich irgendwas anderes oder
ein umgeschriebenen treiber oder so weil das ding dann einfach nicht läuft aber hier hat es
tatsächlich funktioniert ist aber trotzdem langsamer als lan lan und jetzt
machst du gut okay das ist ja nicht zu ertragen langsam
und eine minuten zehn später haben wir dann fertig geladen hier und 59 fps passt vermutlich
nicht so ganz flüssig also ist jetzt schwierig so zu spielen ja 30 fps vielleicht gerade so eben
die cpu 6.850 fullscreen und den treiber aber schön zu sehen dass es zumindest irgendwie
funktioniert nur wahrscheinlich mit der uralten karte nicht ist aber auch verständlich und
wen es interessiert wenn man jetzt in diesem zustand youtube videos gucken möchte funktioniert
1080p zwar ruckelfrei allerdings nicht in 60 fps ja das ist okay nur in diesem fenster so ab
und zu mal kommen dann so 30 und dann mal wieder 50 oder 60 und dann immer vor und zurück aber
internet brosen an sich vor allem bei ebay kleine anzeigen wo ich sie einmal gerade gezeigt habe
sieht es eine ganze menge besser aus aber also jetzt kann man sagen ok web experience ist ok
nicht mehr und nicht weniger aber das liegt höchstwahrscheinlich nicht nur an der grafikkarte
das ist das ist alle pack da eben eine grafikkarte rein ich würde zwar unter windows probieren die
chancen dass das besser läuft sind gar nicht mal so übel und zehn erfinden das irgendwie weiß
ich nicht eine 9500 gt oder gt 220 irgendwas anderes außer dieses hässliche ding da vorne
arbeitsprecher ist auf jeden fall wichtig dass er größer wird was feines ist es dann nicht aber
man kann es auf jeden fall benutzen und ja und es gibt genug leute die nicht merken dass es lahm
ist das erste was ich jetzt tun werde ist die grafikkarte wieder ausnehmen das passt überhaupt
nicht aber ich hatte ja auch noch gesagt netzteil müssen wir testen und bis jetzt also gab es da so
keine probleme also entweder gibt es bei diesem teil kein powergood signal oder das powergood
signal ist fälschlicherweise ausgefallen kann sein kann auch nicht sein solange sich raucht
ist alles gut keine schlechte mark also von daher habe ich das schon gezeigt wenn man den pc aus
macht habt ihr gehört festplatte geht aus dann laufen die lüfter hier noch ein paar sekunden
weiter das ist das kommt nicht unbedingt notwendig aber das machen viele netzteile irgendwie cool
und vielleicht auch ganz gut wenn das system stark belastet wurde also ich finde man kann
hier nicht unbedingt von starker belastung sprechen oder andere architektener knackst weg weil
zeitstempel ja ok wirklich 0 euro war das jetzt auch nicht da wurde viel zeug dazu gebastelt noch
weil ich habe übelst hunger aber ich bin schon viereinhalb stunden und ich gehe jetzt auf
ich geh jetzt was futtern und mal aufs klo döner bestellen ich habe von gestern noch was
dann noch bratkartoffeln und ein bisschen kram so das passt schon
ich habe noch ziemlich viel ziemlich viel zeug hier offen
irgendwas was wir nächste woche gucken speichert das einfach mal mal einfach mal alles hier zack
buchmark all tabs
session heute ist der 25 zehnte
nein meine toilette ist nicht smart die ist die hat zwar spülung von bobbis und föhnen
und alle möglichen abgedrehten sachen drin aber die kann man nicht über smartphone steuern
mal gucken ob es eine app mittlerweile für gibt mal gucken was supported wird vielleicht
vielleicht vielleicht wird ja vielleicht wird ja mein klo supportet
das eike ich habe einen
ja das da das ist übrigens das video von mir was irgendein russischer klo channel geklaut hat
das bin ich das ist mein klo video und das ist jetzt hochgeladen worden auf be dead 24 aber
der chat hat schon hat schon gefunden be dead 24 gekommen hat er hat einfach einfach das klo
video von mir hochgeladen smartphone gibt es da irgendeine möglichkeit das an smartphone zu
bekommen ist da irgendeine app für das ist leider noch ein bisschen alt da gab es noch keine apps
smartphone
ne oh warum hat es so schlechte ratings für seriöse qualität
was fünften wc sitz what the fuck ich habe echt keine schmerzen damit das funktioniert wunderbar
leider gibt es keine app die man klo supportet tja pech gehabt da muss ich weiter knöpfe drücken
was erster link gerade was für ein erster link apps und tools
da ist nichts für mein nix für mein klo dabei
leider gibt es da nix warum braucht man fürs klo eine app warum nicht da die ist da die eigentliche
frage ich glaube mein klo hat ja auch kein wlan oder so was ich könnte so was ich könnte
so was selber basteln da müsste ich halt irgendwie gucken wie ich die fernbedienung vielleicht mit
einem esp 32 nachmachen kann das würde funktionieren ich könnte die fernbedienung nachmachen also die
infrarot befehle lernen und dann könnte ich über die app auch auslösen dass das klo spült und sowas ok
warum brauchst du dann auch zusätzlich 72 rollen klo papier ja weil man sich trotzdem den hinteren
abputzen muss mit klo papier zwar du brauchst jetzt nicht mehr so viel aber drüber putzen
musst du trotzdem noch einfach dass das ganze wasser auch abgeht weil ich verwende den eingebauten
fern nicht mag ich mag ich irgendwie nicht gut jetzt haben wir die wichtigsten sagen ja noch mal
geklärt also wir sehen uns jetzt was futtern bis denn macht's gut zu